TO CALL TO ORDERED THIS
AFTERNOON'S- MEETING OF THE
ASSEMBLY RATHER AND TAX
COMMITTEE OF THE I'VE BEEN
HONORED TO BE NAMED BY THE CHAIR
BY THE SPEAKER AS THE CHAIR OF
THE COMMITTEE AND LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH ALL OF YOU IN
THIS ROLE WE HAVE TWO OPTIONS
FOR WITNESS TESTIMONY TODAY IF
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC HERE IN
THE ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
ON A BILL I WILL ASK YOU TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME WE WILL ALSO BE
USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH ANY
WITNESS CAN TESTIFY. ON A BILL
THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING IS. 877-692-8985 SEVEN
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS. ONE
THREE ONE FIVE ONE TWO SIX YOU
CAN ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY REVAN TAX COMMITTEES
WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV
SCREEN IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALLBACKGROUND
NOISE THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST AND YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE THE ECHO
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATED
PHONE SERVICE. YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT. 916-319-2098 AND
MY STAFF WILL BE THERE TO HELP I
ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE NOW I'D LIKE TO GO OVER
A FEW ADDITIONAL HOUSEKEEPING
ANNOUNCEMENTS FOR THE BILLS
BEING TAKEN UP TODAY WE WILL
TAKE NO MORE THAN TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
OR WITH CONCERNS THESE WITNESSES
HAVE TWO MINUTES EACH TO PROVIDE
THEIR TESTIMONY ALL SUBSEQUENT
WITNESSES SHOULD STATE THEIR
NAME THEIR ORGANIZATION AND
THEIR POSITION ON THE BILL. I
ALSO WOULD LIKE TO GIVE NOTICE
THAT TODAY WILL BE THE LAST
HEARING IN WHICH THE COMMITTEE
WILL ALLOW PRIMARY WITNESSES TO
TESTIMONY TO- TESTIFY REMOTELY
BY PHONE FOR ALL FUTURE HEARINGS
PRIMARY WITNESSES WILL NEED TO
TESTIFY IN PERSON FINALLY AS YOU
LIKELY HAVE NOTED I'VE DECIDED
TO RETAIN THE CHAIRS OF POLICY
ON TO ZACKS. ORIGINALLY ADOPTED
BY MY PREDECESSOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR A COPY OF THIS POLICY
CAN BE FOUND ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. FOR THOSE UNFAMILIAR
WITH THE TERM A TAX EXPENDITURE
IS THE UMBRELLA TERM FOR CREDITS
EXEMPTIONS EXCLUSIONS DEDUCTIONS
AND OTHER TAX BREAKS. THESE
BILLS ARE GENERALLY INTRODUCED
TO ENCOURAGE SOME FORM OF
BENEFICIAL BEHAVIOR. BUT THERE'S
A COST TO EACH OF THEM IN THE
FORM OF FOR GONE STATE REVENUES.
WHICH BRINGS US BACK TO THE
POLICY. ABSENT EXTRAORDINARY
CIRCUMSTANCES ANY TAX
EXPENDITURE MEASURE WILL
INITIALLY BE SET FOR TESTIMONY
ONLY. WITH NO VOTE TAKEN AT THE
CONCLUSION OF- THE MEASURES
PRESENTATION. A VOTE ON A TAX
EXPENDITURE MEASURE MAY AT THE
CHAIR'S DISCRETION. BE TAKEN
ALIVE LATER TIME. IN ADDITION WE
WILL CONTINUE REQUIRE THAT ANY
TAX EXPENDITURE BILL TO-
INCLUDES BOTH THE SUNSET DATE
AND A PERFORMANCE- AND
PERFORMANCE METRICS TO BE
ELIGIBLE FOR A VOTE. ACTIVE A
SHORT TERM BUDGET PROJECTIONS I
BELIEVE IT IS THE COMMITTEE'S
RESPONSIBILITY TO WEIGH INTO
THESE BILLS HOLISTICALLY WITH AN
EYE ON BOTH THEIR POLICY AND
FISCAL IMPACT. THIS POLICY WILL
ABLE WILL ENABLE THE COMMITTEE
TO DO JUST THAT AND I WELCOME
THE INPUT OF THIS COMMITTEE'S
MEMBERS AS WE WAY. PRIORITIES SO
IT LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE A QUORUM
AND HAS HIGHLAND CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. IRWIN HERE WHEN.
GRAY GRAYSON. LEVINE. MAYES
MULLIN PETRIE-NORRIS. HER HAIR
RIVAS SARAH. YEAH OF COURSE
THANK YOU QUORUM HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED WITH THAT WE WILL
MOVE TO OUR FIRST- ITEM ON THE
AGENDA AB SEVENTEEN OH SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BOERNER HORVATH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. WHENEVER MOVE
THE BELL. THANK YOU SO MUCH-
MADAM CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES- AB
SEVENTEEN OH SEVEN SPONSORED BY
THE CALIFORNIA STATE CONTROLLER
AB SEVENTY OH SEVEN SIX TO
SECURE A PERMANENT FUNDING
SOURCE FOR THE SENATE A SENIOR
CITIZENS AND DISABLED CITIZENS
PROPERTY TAX POSTPONEMENT
PROGRAM THIS PROGRAM ALLOWS
HOMEOWNERS WHO ARE SENIORS ARE
BLIND OR HAVE A DISABILITY DID
YOU FOR CURRENT YEAR PROPERTY
TAXES ON THEIR PRINCIPLE
RESIDENCE IF THEY MEET CERTAIN
CRITERIA INCLUDING AT LEAST 40%
EQUITY IN THEIR HOME AND ANNUAL
HOUSEHOLD INCOME OF FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED AND TEN
DOLLARS OR LESS. AMONG OTHER
REQUIREMENTS ESTABLISHED IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN THE
PROGRAM RECEIVE GENERAL FUND
SUPPORT UNTIL THE PROGRAM WAS
SUSPENDED IN TWO THOUSAND NINE.
DUE TO THE RECESSION. IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN A SIGNIFICANTLY
DIFFERENT VERSION OF THE PROGRAM
WAS RESTORED REMOVING ANY
GENERAL FUND SUPPORT AND MAKING
THE PROGRAM ENTIRELY SELF
FUNDED. USING COLLECTIONS ON
EXISTING PROGRAM ACCOUNTS.
COLLECTIONS HAVE DECREASED DUE
TO THE NO NEW LOANS BEING MADE
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND NINE. AND
TWENTY SIXTEEN WHEN THE PROGRAM
WAS SUSPENDED RESULTING IN THE
STATE COMPTROLLER'S COLLECTING
ON A DWINDLING NUMBER OF LOANS.
OR WAITING UNTIL RECENTLY HOMES
BECOME DUE AND PAYABLE. AB
SEVENTEEN OH SEVEN WOULD REQUIRE
TRANSFER FROM THE GENERAL FUND
TO THE PROGRAM ON JUNE THIRTIETH
TO BRING THE PROGRAM FUND
BALANCE TO FIFTEEN MILLION IN
YEARS THAT THE BALANCE IS LESS
THAN FIFTEEN MILLION. IN YEARS
WHEN THE FUN IS OVER FIFTEEN
MILLION THE STATE COMPTROLLER WE
CONTINUE TO TRANSFER BALANCES IN
EXCESS OF FIFTEEN MILLION TO THE
GENERAL FUND. AS REQUIRED UNDER
CURRENT LAW. AB SEVENTY NO SEVEN
HELP SENIORS AND DISABLED
INDIVIDUALS MOST OF THEM ON A
FIXED INCOME STAY IN THEIR HOMES
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND I HAVE TO WITNESSES.
MAYBE OUR WITNESSES CAN BE BRIEF
AND IF THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE THEY CAN
ANSWER THOSE DIRECTLY. AND
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL URBAN TREE FLOW. ASSISTANT
DEPUTY COMPTROLLER AND LINDSEY
ROSS MANAGER FOR THE PROPERTY
TAX POSTPONEMENT PROGRAM AT THE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE AND THEY'RE
ON THE LINE THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WITH A MODERATOR PLEASE
CONNECT US NOW TO OF ENTRY FILE. THANK YOU THAT HAVE BEEN
SHIPPED OUT OF STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE. THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY I
THINK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND
DID A GREAT JOB- EXPLAINING THE
BILL IN THE REAL WORLD IMPACT-
IN THIS PROGRAM AB. I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
AND CAN HAVE A MODERATOR PLEASE
CONNECT US WITH LINDSEY ROSS WHO
IS I THINK YOU MENTIONED IT BUT
THE MANAGER OF PROPERTY TAX
BECAUSE- OF THE PROPERTY TAX
POSTPONEMENT OF PROGRAM AT THE
STATE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE.
THANK YOU MADAM JERRY. LYNN BE
ROBIN THE MANAGER OF THE
PROPERTY TAX COMPONENT PROGRAM-
AT THE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE AND
WE APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. ALL RIGHT DO WE HAVE
ANY WITNESSES IN THE ROOM
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS KAREN LAYING ON THE OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTY TREASURERS AND TAX
COLLECTORS OR THE SPONSOR OF THE
BILL THAT BROUGHT IT BACK IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN SUPER PROUD OF IT
SO THANKFUL FOR YOU TO CARRY IT.
PLEASE AT PROTECT THINKS MUCH.
THANK YOU AND WHAT THE MODERATOR
NOW OPEN UP THE LINE FOR
SUPPORTING TESTIMONY. BUT GO TO
GENERAL PUBLIC COMMENT IS THAT
CORRECT MADAM CHAIR I GUESS
PLEASE. THANK YOU TO PUT
YOURSELF IN Q. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. WE HAVE ONE THAT'S
ALREADY IN THE QUEUE WE WILL GO
TO THE LINE OF ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SIX ONE TWO SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO CHAIR AND MEMBERS
IS THAT THE CHAVEZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
WE DO HAVE TWO MORE THAT ARE
QUEUING UP PLEASE ALLOW A MOMENT
FOR US TO PROVIDE THEIR LINE
NUMBERS. WELL NOT A LINE NUMBER
FIFTY EIGHT THAT'S FIVE EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
LIKE HERE YES FROM THE SAN
FRANCISCO CHAPTER OF STAR LEGACY
FOUNDATION AND I SUPPORT AB. ONE
SIX NINE SEVEN. THANK YOU ORDER
LINE NUMBER FORTY EIGHT FOUR
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE
FORTY EIGHT CAN YOU CHECK YOUR
LINE FOR MUTE. MY NAME IS SHORT
. FROM THE CAMPUS CHAPTER OF
STAR LEGACY FOUNDATION AND I
SUPPORT. EIGHT EIGHT ONE SIX
NINE. ARE THOSE ALL THE
WITNESSES MISTER MODERATOR WE DO
HAVE NE MORE THAT JUST AT THE
VERY END POP THEMSELVES INTO Q.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
AND WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER
SIXTY SEVEN THAT SIX SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
KAREN GONZALEZ I'M CALLING THE
SUPPORT A. B. ONE SIX NINE
SEVEN. THANK YOU ARE YOU DO HAVE
ONE ADDITIONAL IT'S MY NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY EIGHT
THAT'S ONE TWO EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. LINE ONE TWO EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE CHECK YOUR
LONG COMMUTE. I DR OKAY JOKE CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YES YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU. OH SORRY- I APOLOGIZE MY
NAME IS DR OKAY JONES AND I AM A
BROKERAGE RESEARCHER AND A
MEMBER OF THE INTERNATIONAL
STILLBIRTH ALLIANCE- I WOULD
LIKE TO PROVIDE MY SUPPORT. FOR
AB ONE SIX NINE SEVEN THANK YOU
. ALL RIGHT ZERO SHARE MORE
THAT'S POPPED IN THE QUEUE ARE
ARE WE ARE THEY'VE ON FOR THE
RIGHT BILL. BUT WE DO NOT ASK
WHAT BILL THEY'RE TALKING ON
MADAM SPEAKER I'M SORRY. WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT TO AB. SEVENTEEN
OH SEVEN. OKAY IF YOU'RE NOT
WISHING TO SPEAK ON AB SEVENTEEN
OH SEVEN PLEASE FOR THREE PRESS
ONE ZERO TO TAKE YOURSELF OUT OF
THE QUEUE. ALL RIGHT WE HAVE ONE
MORE THAT HAS REMAINED IN Q.
LOOKS LIKE WE'RE GOING TO.
RETURNED A LINE NUMBER ONE
TWENTY EIGHT ONE MOMENT PLEASE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND THEY
REMOVED THEMSELVES WILL TRY LINE
SIXTEEN TO- HI HI MY NAME IS
HONORING FARA I'M NOT SURE IF I
GOT THE RIGHT A BELL BUT I'M IN
SUPPORT OF THAT THE BILL FOR THE
FILBERT CRUSH- AND I'M
REPRESENTING POSH AND BEEN ON
AMERICAN HEWITT AT THE WORK.
RIGHT RIGHT RIGHT LINE NUMBER
FIFTY EIGHT FIVE EIGHT.
RIGHT WILL TRY LINE NUMBER SIXTY
FIVE SIX FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ALLOW YES YOUR LINE IS OPEN
THOUGH AND- HI MY NAME IS.
CHAPTER. OR. NINE I'LL REPEAT
AGAIN FOR EVERYBODY ON THE LINE
FOR TALK IN OFF THE SUPPORT OF
AB SO. OH SEVEN. MAN I'M SURE
WE'VE EXHAUSTED THE QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. STE OKAY ALL RIGHT
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM. A
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN A
MAIN LINE FOR ANY OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU IF YOU'D
LIKE TO PROVIDE OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY ON THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND THERE'S NO ONE IN THE
QUEUE AT THIS TIME AND CHAIR ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH DO WE
HAVE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. OKAY I HAVE A
JUST ONE QUESTION IF YOU CAN
CLARIFY HOW DOES THAT
POSTPONEMENT WORK WHEN A HOUSE
IS PASSED ON. TO A CHILD AS PART
OF AN INHERITANCE DOES IT
CONTINUE OR- IS THE INHERITOR OF
ON THE HOOK FOR THE- FOR THE
FUNDING. I'LL TURN THAT OVER TO
MY WITNESSES RIGHT. VENTURA AT
THE STATE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE
AND I WILL HAVE- DURING THE
LINDA ROSS THE DRESS THAT
QUESTION. I REMEMBER WHEN THE
RAFI- MANAGER OF THE PROPERTY
TAX COMPONENT PROGRAM- TYPICALLY
WHEN A CLAIM IS THAT THESE THE
ACCOUNT THAT THEY COME DUE AND
PAYABLE- SO THE SHORT ANSWER TO
THAT QUESTION WOULD BE YES AT
THE TIME THAT THE QUEEN OF POP
OF THE WAY IT WOULD BECOME DUE
AND PAYABLE IF IT. INHERITED BY
A CHILD- IT THE SECOND BAND DOES
DEPEND ON DOES THE CHILD NEED
THE ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS OF
THE PROGRAM WHERE THEY AN OWNER
AT THE TIME- THERE COULD BE SOME
VARIABLES TO WEAR THEIR
PARTICIPATION MAY CONTINUE-
HOWEVER THAT IN MOST CASES IT
WOULD BECOME DUE AND PAYABLE AT
THE TIME THE CHILD INHERITS THE
PROPERTY- IN WHICH CASE. YOU
KNOW IF IT CANNOT BE YOU ALREADY
PAID AT THAT TIME WE DO WORK ON
PAYMENT PLANS. WITH- FAMILY
MEMBERS. I THANK YOU FOR THE
UGLY. SO WE HAVE A- MOTION BY.
QUIRK IN A SECOND BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEVINE- MISSOURI PART
BACK TO HAVE A CLOSING
STATEMENTS RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHTS AND THE
MOTION IS TO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS- IS HIGHLAND CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS IRWIN HI- WHEN I
WHEN I WHEN I AGREE. GREAT I
GRAYSON. LEVINE LEVINE I MAYES
MAYES I'M MULLIN PETRIE-NORRIS
PETRIE-NORRIS ARTWORK OUR WORK
RIVAS SARAH HI THERE ARE. THAT
BILL IS OUT EIGHT ZERO EIGHT
ZERO AND- THE REST OF THE BILLS
WILL BE FOR TESTIMONIALS AND I
DO ENCOURAGE ALL THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS TO REMEMBER WE'RE GOING
TO BE PRIORITIZING ALL THE BILLS
THAT WERE PASSING ON TO
APPROPRIATIONS SO ASK ANY
QUESTIONS OR CLARIFICATIONS OR-
LET ME KNOW WHAT YOUR THOUGHTS
ARE- AFTER THE HEARING. ALRIGHT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- WE ARE GOING ON
TO EIGHTEEN SEVENTY THREE.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS. FIRST OF ALL I'D LIKE
TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS WOULD LIKE TO THANK
YOUR STAFF FOR ALL THEIR WORK ON
THE BILL. AB SEVENTEEN OR
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY THREE WILL
PROVIDE A 40% TAX CREDIT FOR THE
INSTALLATION OF SPECIFIED
ELECTRIC VEHICLE SUPPLY
EQUIPMENT. AND MULTI FAMILY
DWELLINGS- BE- MULTI FAMILY
BUILDINGS BEGINNING JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. THE
AVAILABILITY OF EASY CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURES AND OVERALL
COMPONENT IN THE SUCCESSFUL
DEPLOYMENT OF ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES. THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION ESTIMATES THAT THREE
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED SORRY
THREE HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND
EVEY CHARTERS. WILL BE NEEDED A
MULTI FAMILY DWELLINGS FOR
CALIFORNIA'S TWENTY THIRTY D. AS
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES. HOWEVER
THE LACK OF ACCESS TO HOME
CHARGING STATIONS REMAINS A
MAJOR BARRIER TO EVEY ADOPTIONS
FOR THOSE LIVING IN MULTI FAMILY
UNITS. THE ENERGY COMMISSION
FOUND THAT LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES HAVE FEWER EASY
CHARGING STATIONS FOR CAPITAL.
CAPITA THE MIDDLE INCOME
COMMUNITIES RELIABLE ACCESS TO
EASY STATIONS IS PARTICULARLY
CHALLENGING FOR RENTERS AND
THOSE LIVING IN MULTI UNIT
DWELLINGS. RECENT STUDIES HAVE
SHOWN THAT AS MUCH AS 85% OF
CHARGING A FOR PERSONAL AFTER
VEHICLES OCCURS AT HOME BUT MOST
PEOPLE LIVING IN APARTMENTS AND
CONDOMINIUMS ALSO KNOWN AS MULTI
FAMILY. BUILDINGS ARE MULTI UNIT
DWELLINGS DO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO
THESE CHARGING STATION.
INSTALLING A RECHARGING STATION
SPECIALLY IN OLDER MULTI FAMILY
RESIDENTIAL BUILDINGS THEY DO
NOT HAVE THE NECESSARY
INFRASTRUCTURE REQUIRES AN
INVESTMENT BY THE DEVELOPER OR
THE BILL BILLING OWNER. AND THIS
CURRENTLY NO INCENTIVE. TO
REALLY DO THIS AND ACTUALLY TO
RETROFIT OLDER- MULTI FAMILY
DWELLINGS. EIGHTY SEVEN-
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY THREE WOULD
HELP OWNERS OR DEVELOPERS WITH
THE COSTS WERE INCURRED OF.
COSTS PAID OR INCURRED FOR THE
INSTALLATION OF EVEY CHARGING
EQUIPMENT AND NEW CONSTRUCTION
ADDITIONS AND ALTERATIONS TO
EXISTING BUILDINGS. INCREASING
ACCESS. TO EVEY CHARGING
STATIONS A MULTI FAMILY BUILDING
CAN ADDRESS THE BARRIERS THAT
WE'VE TIME AND TIME AGAIN IN THE
STATE OF. CALIFORNIA TO EVEY
ADOPTION BY LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND ENSURING THAT
THESE COMMUNITIES ARE NOT LEFT
BEHIND IN CALIFORNIA'S
TRANSITION TO ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THIS IMPORTANT
INCENTIVE TO EXPAND ACCESS TV
CHARGERS FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
AND BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS CERTAINLY AND YOU'LL
HAVE- I TAKE IT NO. NO WITNESSES
NO WAY ROOSEVELT MYSELF SO I'M
ALSO HAPPY TO HEAR YOUR FEEDBACK
AND THOUGHTS ALL RIGHT- ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES- THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. IN THE
ROOM. THE AND CAN THE MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINE THE MAIN
TELEPHONE LINE FOR SUPPORTING
WITNESSES. YES IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK ON AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. WE DO
HAVE ONE THAT IS PARTY CURED UP
WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE THAT'S
ONE THREE THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS THIS IS JULIE MELANAU
SKI BALL AND BE HAPPENING
CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION. I
WOULD LIKE TO ADD THAT THERE-
WASN'T MENTIONED AT THAT THAT
CALIFORNIA'S. CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM CURRENTLY
NEED THREE AUTHORIZATION. THIS
BILL SORT OF COMES IN AND SHE
OFTENTIMES. UP FOR WHEN THE
INCENTIVES ARE GOING TO GO AWAY-
CHARGING INSTALLATION. SO WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THEMSELVES
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT MODEL THAT
WAS THE ONLY. THAT WAS THE ONLY
A WITNESS ON THE LINE RIGHT. WE
DO HAVE TO ADDITIONAL AND WE'LL
GO TO LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FIVE THAT'S ONE TWO
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BRADY
GARRISON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING OFFICIALS IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
THREE THANK YOU. AND LASTLY WILL
AYE NUMBER FIFTY SEVEN THAT'S
FIVE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU PRESS TOO YOUNG FOR
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE HERE IN SUPPORT. AND
MANAGER WITH THAT WE HAVE
EXHAUSTED ACU ALL RIGHT IS THERE
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. KICKING THE
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINE
FOR ANY OPPOSITION TESTIMONY.
pAB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. FROM. I'M SURE
THERE IS NO ONE SHOWING UP IN
OPPOSITION OF THE SUN ALL RIGHT
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. MISTER CLARK ARM SO
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THE FREE
RIDER PROBLEM. SO I LIVE IN A
MULTI FAMILY BUILDING WHICH IS-
GETTING PEOPLE IN NOW WHO CAN
DO- WHO HAVE ELECTRIC VEHICLES-
THE- MANAGERS OF THE BUILDING OR
PUTTING THEM. P FOR ELECTRIC
CHARGING STATIONS. ARM AND BUT
THEY'RE DOING IT ANYWAY AND THIS
IS WHAT'S KNOWN AS THE FREE
RIDER PROBLEM. TYPICALLY IN
UPPER INCOME RANCHING AND
THERE'S A LOT OF IT MATTER FACT
ALMOST ALL NEW. MARKET ALMOST
ALL NEW APARTMENT YOUR MARKET.
RENDON AND- WHEN YOU'RE AT THAT
MARKET YOU'RE REALLY ON THE
UPPER MIDDLE CLASS YOU JUST
DON'T CARE TO OWN A HOME. I
WOULD PREFER A PROGRAM THAT HAD
GRANTS TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
UNITS RATHER THAN TAKING
EVERYONE IN. BECAUSE YOU'RE JUST
GOING TO BRING A LOT OF PEOPLE
WHO. AGAIN IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
DONE ANYWAY BECAUSE THESE ARE
OPERATE CALM THEY'RE COMPETING.
FOR CUSTOMERS- SO I THINK THE
POTENTIAL IS JUST A LOT OF MONEY
HERE. IT WOULD GO OUT THAT WOULD
REALLY WOULDN'T HELP WHEREAS IF
YOU HAD IT FOR STRICTLY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS. ARE
EITHER IS A TAX BREAK OR AS A
GRANT I THINK IT WOULD WORK
BETTER THANK YOU. MAY I ASK ARE
YOU- IF THE CHAIR FOR ME- ARE
YOU ASKING FOR LIKE DEED
RESTRICTED AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ARE HOW DO YOU WANT TO. THE FOR
ALL LEAVE IT UP TO YOU BUT THE
MAIN THING IS. GIVEN THE HELP
MORE TO THE PEOPLE WHO REALLY
NEED IT AS OPPOSED TO THOSE WHO
CAN AFFORD. MODERN MARKET RATE
HOUSING.AND I THINK THAT'S A
VERY FAIR POINT BECAUSE OUR GOAL
IS TO GIVE IT TO. THE RIGHT
CALIFORNIANS THAT IS THE GOAL
WE'VE SEEN IN STUDY AFTER STUDY
YOU SEE THAT YOU'RE NOT SEEING
THE UPTAKE IN EVEY CHARGERS AND-
AS SOMEBODY WHO IS A RENTER
MYSELF. I UNDERSTAND THAT IT YOU
KNOW I HAPPEN TO HAVE A GARAGE
IF I DIDN'T HAVE A GARAGE IF I
HAD JUST A CARPORT SPACE AND
THAT APARTMENT COMPLEX. I WOULD
NOT HAVE AN EASY RIGHT NOW YEAH
SO WE ARE TRYING TO GET AT THAT
PROBLEM AND SO- WE CAN LOOK AT.
ADDING SOME GUARDRAILS AROUND
HERE IT ALSO HOPE YOU
APPROPRIATIONS WHO WOULD BRING
DOWN THE COST IT'S- PROBABLY BY
FACTOR FIVE OR SIX SO. JUST SAM
YOUR ROCKET SCIENTISTS ALL TRUST
YOUR MOUTH MORE. THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS.
WHEN I THINK AS WE ARE LOOKING
TO IT AS THE CHAIR SAID IN A
PRIORITIZE THE AT INVESTMENTS
THAT WE MAKE IN TAX TAX
EXPENDITURES THE THING I WOULD
LOVE TO UNDERSTAND IS HOW WITH
THIS SPECIFIC PROPOSAL HANGS
TOGETHER WITH THE IT WAS LIKE
THREE BILLION DOLLARS THAT WE
ARE INVESTED IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET IN BUILDING OUT- ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE ACROSS THE STATE
I KNOW IN IN- THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AND IN MUCH OF WHAT
WE'RE DEBATING NOW I'M WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT ADDING AN
ADDITIONAL BILLIONS OF DOLLARS-
SO I THINK ONE THING THAT WOULD
HELP ME IS TO UNDERSTAND HOW
THIS HANGS TOGETHER. WITH THOSE
OTHER PROPOSALS YOU KNOW DO WE
NEED ANOTHER LINE ITEM OR IS IT
REALLY ABOUT ENSURING THAT IS
WE'RE INVESTING ANOTHER THREE OR
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS IN BUILDING
OUT CALIFORNIA'S SEVEN FOR
STRUCTURE THAT THIS IS PART OF
THAT PROPOSAL I THINK THEY WORK
IN TANDEM MY UNDERSTANDING OF
SOMEBODY WHO HAS AN EASY AND YOU
KNOW I CAN'T GET FROM AND
SENATORS TO CARLSBAD AND BACK
HOME ONE CHARGE I'M NINE SIX
CARBONS AND SINISTER CORONADO
AND BACK ON ONE CHARGE. RIGHT
LIKE I CAN'T DO THAT ON MY AV SO
WHEN WE'RE BUILDING OUT
INFRASTRUCTURE YOU'RE BUILDING
OUT INFRASTRUCTURE FOR MANY
DIFFERENT TYPES OF BEHAVIOR BUT
A MULTI FAMILY HOUSING WE'RE NOT
SEEING THE MARKET BUILD AND LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES THEY'RE NOT
RETROFITTING WHEN THEY DO
SUBSTANTIAL INNOVATIONS THAT'S
JUST NOT HAPPENING AND MOST
PEOPLE ARE AT HOME WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THE TIME IT TAKES TO CHARGE I
MEAN THERE'S ONE THING FOR FAST
CHARGERS THAT SOLVES RANGE
ANXIETY AND THEN ANOTHER THING
OF IF I'M GONNA GO AND I'M GONNA
BE USING MY EASY AS A COMMUTER
VEHICLE. HOW AM I GETTING THAT
FIRST CHARGE SO I'M NOT STARTING
MY DAY GOING YOU KNOW SPENDING
AN HOUR CHARGING IT SOMEWHERE
AND. SO I THINK THEY HAVE TO
WORK TOGETHER BUT I DON'T THINK
WE SOLVED EQUITY PER OF- EEVEE
CHARGER IF WE DON'T HAVE A
DEDICATED LINE I TO MULTI FAMILY
LAW INCOME COMMUNITIES AGE NOT
IN OFFICE THE UPTICK. AND I WILL
I WANT TO DO IT EITHER FIVE
THERE IT AND I TOLD AGREE WITH
THAT I'M SORRY IF WE ALREADY TO
HAVE A LOT THAT WAS MY QUESTION
IS THAT WE DO WE- HAVE A LINE
ITEM I. IS OKAY THAT'S
INTERESTED INCENTIVIZE. THE REST
OF EXISTING MULTI FOR. OR WHEN
YOU HAVE THE OUT OF AFFORDABLE
UNITS. THE YOU KNOW I HAVE A
DIFFERENT BILL THAT DEAL WITH
THE WHAT DO YOU DO THE PLUMBING
THE FULL TO. THAT THE DIFFERENT
CON. DOWN AND THE KIND OF WORK
TOGETHER AND THAT WAY IS HOW DO
WE ACTUALLY GET. THE CHARGERS IN
EIGHT WHERE WHERE PEOPLE NEED
THEM. PEOPLE NEED THEM ALONG THE
WAY BUT PEOPLE NEED THEM IN
THEIR HOMES. WELL I CERTAINLY
I'M CERTAINLY AGREE AND
APPRECIATE. YOUR GOAL TO BUILD
OUT INFRASTRUCTURE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BECAUSE- I THINK
WE CAN ALL RECOGNIZE WE'RE NEVER
GOING TO. MEET OUR CLIMATE
OBJECTIVES ARE ZERO MISSION
OBJECTIVES. WITHOUT THAT PIECE
OF THE PUZZLE. I JUST. HAD DID
ANYBODY. THE JUST KIND OF A LONG
LINES THE NEW HOMES- NEW MULTI
HOME ARE READY. US IN FIRST. TO
FOR EVEY SO WHAT IT WOULDN'T A
MORE IF TO JUST DIRECT TO-
RETROFITS OF BUILDINGS IN THE
LAW MY UNDERSTANDING OF CURRENT
LAWS THE ONLY REQUIRE THE
PLUMBING. FOR NEW EVEY IS NOT
THE ACTUAL CHARGES THAT'S LIKE
SAYING GIVE A PLUMBING FOR A
TOILET IN THE HOUSE BUT YOU
DON'T ACTUALLY PUT IN THE
TOILET. THAT'S WHAT OUR CURRENT
LAW DOES AND I HAVE A DIFFERENT
BILL THAT ADDRESSES THAT. AND SO
HOW DO YOU INCENTIVIZE THEM
PUTTING IN BOTH THE PLUMBING AND
THE TOILET SO ARE NOT ONLY DOING
THE CAPACITY FOR THE CHARGER
WHICH IS CURRENT LAW AND NEW A
NEW UNITS BUT ACTUALLY THE
CHARGES THEMSELVES OF THEM
THEY'RE USEFUL. BECAUSE ALL AND
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS AS A OUR
COLLEAGUE SAID YOU'RE SEEING
THEM IN AND HIGHER AND HOMES OF
THEY KNOW PEOPLE HAVE EV'S
THAT'S A VALUE ADDED. ON IT TO
THE PROJECT YOU'RE NOT SAYING IT
AND LOWER INCOME AND ONE THING
WE COULD CONSIDER IS JUST DOING
RETROFITTING- MY CONCERN WOULD
STILL BE WHAT GETS US FROM JUST
THE PLUMBING FOR EV'S TO THE
FULL EVEN CHARGING AND WHAT
WHAT'S THAT DELTA THERE BUT I'M
HAPPY TO WORK. WITH YOU OR
ANYBODY STAFF ON ON THAT
QUESTION THAT WOULD BE GREAT AND
I GUESS THE OTHER QUESTION IS
AND AGAIN MY FIRST DAY HERE. OF
WOULD. IT BE MORE EFFECTIVE AND
TARGETED TO DO A GREAT PROGRAM.
WE COULD CONSIDER THE GRANT
PROGRAM I MEAN I UP WITH THAT
CREDITS THAT'S WHAT I BUT THEY
MIGHT BE OTHER WAYS TO DO IT IN
A HAPPY TO EXPLOIT PEN WAS SIDE
A- ASSEMBLY MEMBER- SUCH AS-
ALSO. WELL THANK YOU VERY FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE- I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU
TO CONSIDER THIS IMPORTANT
PROPOSAL FOR CALIFORNIA THAT
BEATS MEETS BOTH OUR CLEAN
VEHICLE GOALS AND IF YOU HAVE
ANY OTHER THOUGHTS PLEASE FEEL
REPAIRS THAN ANYBODY ELSE AND
THAT EITHER HAS ANY THOUGHTS.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO REACH OUT TO
MY OFFICE WERE OPEN FOR
SUGGESTIONS THE BEST WAY TO HELP
SOLVE THIS ISSUE. THANK YOU TO.
HAVE A QUARTERBACK AT THE NEXT
ITEM ON OUR GENDERS FOR ITEMS.
AB NINE A LOT BY SOME MEMBER.
GAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
NICE TO SEE YOU HERE IN THIS
COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU TO THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
PLEASED TODAY 2% A. B. NINETEEN
ELEVEN WHICH WOULD CREATE A TAX
CREDIT TO SUPPORT THE
PRESERVATION OF TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF AT RISK OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS IN THIS
BILL IS AIMED SQUARELY AT OUR
STATE'S HOUSING CRISIS WHICH-
ALL OF US ARE VERY MUCH AWARE
OF. AND IT'S AIMED AT ADDRESSING
A VERY SPECIFIC PROBLEM WHICH IS
THAT THERE ARE PROJECTIONS THAT
OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS WE MAY
LOSE BETWEEN THIRTY AND THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND UNITS OF DEED
RESTRICTED AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE URGENCY TO
BUILD A NEW AFFORDABLE HOUSING
TO MEET OUR HOUSING CRISIS BUT
THE IDEA THAT WE MIGHT LOSE
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND UNITS OR
SOMETHING. OF TREMENDOUS CONCERN
TO ME AND SO WITH THIS PROGRAM
WOULD DO IS TO CREATE A TAX
CREDIT MARKET INCENTIVES THAT
WOULD INCENTIVIZE THE OWNERS OF
THOSE BUILDINGS WERE DEED
RESTRICTION OR SUBSIDY IS ABOUT
TO EXPIRE. TO SELL ABOUT
BUILDING TO A MISSION DRIVEN
NONPROFIT THEY COULD CONTINUE TO
OPERATE THAT AS AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN THIS WOULD HAVE I
THINK A NUMBER OF IMPORTANT
BENEFITS FIRST OF ALL IT WOULD
STABILIZE OUR SUPPLY OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SO HOPEFULLY
WE CAN BUILD ON THAT AND NOT
GOING THE WRONG DIRECTION IT
WOULD PROTECT THOSE TENANTS WHO
ARE AT RISK OF DISPLACEMENT. AND
I ALSO THINK THAT IF WE WERE TO
LOSE THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND UNITS
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING THINK
ABOUT THAT IF THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND FAMILIES IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WE WOKE UP ONE
MORNING AND FOUND THAT THE RENTS
WERE GOING TO DOUBLE OR TRIPLE
OVERNIGHT I THINK THAT THAT
WOULD HAVE SEVERE CONSEQUENCES
FAR STATES HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
AND SO THIS IS A PROPOSAL OR WE
CAN RESERVE UNITS OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR ABOUT TWENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A UNIT YOU
THINK ABOUT THE PRICES TO BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN SOME OF
OUR URBAN AREAS YOU'VE PROBABLY
SEEN- AUDITS FROM THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES WHERE THEY CAN COST
SIX SEVEN HUNDRED EIGHT HUNDRED
K. A DOOR. RATHER THAN DOING
THAT WE CAN PRESERVE UNITS FOR
ABOUT TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
AND SO THIS WOULD CREATE A
PROGRAM. WHERE WE WOULD- WE
WOULD INVEST. FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. THAT WOULD HELP
US PRESERVE ABOUT TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND UNITS OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. I'M REALLY PROUD THAT
THIS IS AN APPROACH THAT HAS.
GARNERED BROAD SUPPORT FROM A
LOT OF DIFFERENT GROUPS THAT
AREN'T NECESSARILY ALIGNED SO
YOU HAVE- TENDED IN EQUITY
GROUPS ON THE SAME SIDE AS
LANDLORDS YOU HAVE BUILDERS. AND
LABOR THAT OF ALL COME TOGETHER
BEHIND. A PROPOSAL. LIKE THIS
AND- ALSO BROAD SOME. FROM IT'S
A WHERE YOU A- JAMES. AN ALEX
THAT ARE BOTH CO AUTHOR WHICH IS
A COM THAT YOU DON'T SEE VERY.
AROUND SO WE FEEL VERY GOOD
ABOUT THIS. WE THINK- IT COULD
BE A REALLY BIG DEAL. LEVER THE
POWER OF THE MARK LEVERAGE.
POWER OF TAX CREDITS- TO HOW
PRESERVE. AFFORDABLE HOW APART.
SOME OF THEM OF ALL. RIGHT AND
AFFORDABLE FOR. IN THIS OF
CALIFORNIA SO. LOOKING FOR THE
TO THE- WOULD RISK. ASK FOR
YOUR- AND AN AYE VOTE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. AND HAVE TO
WITNESSES HERE TO TESTIFY WITH
ME TO IT TODAY- IN PERSON IS
MARK STIVERS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP- AND THEN ON
THE PHONE WE HAVE VERONICA BT.
FROM THE CALIFORNIA COALITION
FOR ROLE HOUSING. CYBERSTATES
YOU YES MARK DIVERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP.
THE LEGISLATURE ACTUALLY CREATED
THE PARTNERSHIP MANY YEARS AGO
TO ADVISE AND PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE ON HOW TO PRESERVE
THE AFFORDABILITY OF THESE AT
RISK. DEVELOPMENTS AND THIS BILL
IS CRITICAL OUR EFFORTS BECAUSE
IT GIVES OWNERS AN INCENTIVE. TO
SELL ENTITIES WILL MAINTAIN
AFFORDABLE FOR FIFTY FIVE YEARS
IN THESE OF THESE DEVELOPMENTS
THAT ARE CURRENTLY AFFORDABLE
BUT AT RISK OF CONVERTING THE
MARKET RATE WHEN THE- AT. WHEN
THE RESTRICTIONS EXPIRE BUT
THERE'S A WHOLE NOTHER UNIVERSE
THAT THIS BILL ALSO ADDRESSES.
WITH WHAT WE CALL NATURALLY
OCCURRING AFFORDABLE HOUSING. HE
ARE CURRENTLY MARKET RATE OF.
THAT AREN'T AND THAT ARE. FOR TO
THERE UNDER. PRESSURE FOR IT TO-
OWNERS TO MAXIMIZE THE RENTS. AN
INCREASE RENTALS HOMEOWNERS. ON
THOSE RENTERS MAKING. IT VERY
DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO STAY. AND
THIS IS CHRISTIAN OPPORTUNITY
FOR TO BRING THOSE INTO THE
AFFORD HOUSING. WHERE WE KEEP
THEM AFFORDABLE FOR FIFTY FIVE
YEARS- IT BASICALLY ALLOWS
NONPROFIT UPTICK. MARKET PLACE
RIGHT NOW THE- THEY'RE THEY'RE
COMPETING AGAINST. IN A YEAR
INVEST. AND REAL IN. TRUST WE
CAN CLOSE VERY QUICKLY. AND THIS
IS A TOOL THAT BYE BYE. ALLOWING
THE OWNERS TO RESULT TAKE SOME
EQUITY OUT OF THE PROPERTY AND
BE THEN NOT BE SUBJECT TO
CAPITAL GAINS ON THAT. IT'S A
TOOL THAT NO OTHER BUYER CAN
OFFER TO THE SELLER. AND THEN
PUTS US AT THE TOP OF THE HEAP
IN TERMS OF WHO THE SELLER MIGHT
WANT TO WORK WITH AND- BRING
THEM INTO THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
REAL SO WE VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION AND WE
LOOK FOR THE PERFECT TIME FOR
THE COMMITTEE SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RIGHT AND YOU'RE A SECOND
WITNESS ON THE LINE AS OF FOR
ANNIKA BEAUTY IS THAT CORRECT
ALL RIGHT. MODERATOR PLEASE
CONNECT US NOW. PRANA BECAUSE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA COALITION
FOR RURAL HOUSING. GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M BROWN ACTIVITY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION PEROT HOUSING ESTATE
WIDE ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
REPRESENTING DEVELOPERS
AFFORDABLE HOMES GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS AND LOCAL SUPPORTERS
OF ALL COMMUNITIES WE HAVE A
LONG HISTORY OF SUPPORTING AND
EXPANDING EFFORTS TO PRESERVE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND AS SUCH
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AB NINETEEN
ELEVEN. IN ADDITION TO THE GREAT
POINT MANY AUCKLANDERS FIBERS I
WANNA GIVE YOU A WORLD THE FACT
ABOUT IMPORTANT THE FELLOW. WE
CAN. I WOULD IS HAVING QUITE OF
BAGHDAD OCCUR AFFORDABLE. BUT
ANYWAY. HOUSING FOR AND AREAS IS
WHEN THE GENERAL OF MAKING A
MOVE TO REMOTE. MEETING TO
MIGRATE AWAY FROM AREA. AND
SHORT TERM RENTALS OVER HOUSING
. AB NINETEEN ELEVEN CAN HELP
WITH A PORTABLE HOUSING UP. IN
WORLD OF FORTY TO FIFTY. IN
ADDITION TO THE INCREASING COST
OF MARKET RATE HAS WORLD
COMMUNITY THAT THEY THINK. OF
COVENANTS AND HOW DO YOU KNOW.
THROUGH THE U. S. YEAH. FIVE
FIFTEEN. WELCOME BLOCK ONLY ONE
WHAT ABOUT HOW A DEVELOP THE
DIFFICULTLY IN. LOW INCOME WITH
FOR. YOU MAY HAVE FEWER NO
OTHER. ALTERNATIVE. IN ADDITION
THE RENTAL HOUSING. COMMITTED TO
PRESERVING MY HOME THANK. ACCESS
TO HD DEVE UTILIZED MOBILE HOME
PARK. NUMBER OWNERSHIP PROGRAM.
WE PROVIDE TECHNICAL.
PRESERVATION PROJECT THERE
INTERESTED IN KEEPING HOME
ACROSS THE STATE I DON'T.
REMEMBER DIFFICULT BUT NOT FOR.
AND PARK RESIDENTS TO KEEP MY
REQUIRES. PUTTING THOUSAND OF
LOW INCOME PRESIDENT AT RISK OF. AB NINETEEN ELEVEN HELPING BUT
THE BY REVENUE AND I'M- TO
MAINTAIN REPEAL AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AFFECT. FOR THE VERY
GOOD FOR RESPECT ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE YOU FOR FREE TIME. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU IS THERE ANYBODY
IN THE ROOM WITH TO SPEAK
SUPPORT. BUT TIED DAVID ON OF
THE HOUSING CO AND STRONG SO.
MODERATOR IS THERE ANYBODY- THE
MAIN FOR A STE TEST. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK ON AB
NINETEEN ELEVEN IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. WE WILL
START WITH LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE
ABOUT EIGHT INCHES SO FAR WE'LL
START WITH LINE NUMBER THIRTEEN
THAT'S ONE THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES THIS IS NICCOLO DELUCA
COLLEEN IN STRONG SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF THE MAYOR OF OAKLAND
AND NONPROFIT HOUSING OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. BUT I. ON THE OTHER
LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY FOUR THAT'S ONE FIVE FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MICHAEL GUNNING
WITH THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION HERE IN
SUPPORT. NOT A LINE NUMBER
THIRTY EIGHT THAT'S THREE EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
TERRY STRUGGLING WITH THE LOS
ANGELES BUSINESS COUNCIL
CONSTRUCT SUPPORT THANK YOU.
EXCELLENT LINE NUMBER THIRTY SIX
THAT'S THREE SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIRMAN HONORABLE MEMBERS
DOESN'T NEGATE HARRIS CALLING ON
BEHALF OF SAN DIEGO HOUSING
FEDERATION I'M CALLING IN TO
VOICE OUR STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
NINETEEN ELEVEN WE ARE ALSO
CONSTRUCTION OF THE CELL THANK
YOU. EXTRA LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THAT'S ONE
FIVE ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON SURE MEMBERS CAN
DISCUSS THE- WHAT WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY A PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR THE MEASURE AND- DRY.
PORT THANK YOU. THE LINE NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND TWELVE THAT'S
ONE ONE TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON KEREN MEMBERS
THIS IS RACHEL SMITH FROM WORLD
COMMUNITY ASSISTANT CORPORATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB ONE NINE
ONE ONE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GROWING NUMBER EIGHT EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE PETER WARD- WITH LIKE-
THE VALLEY INDUSTRY AND COMMERCE
ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN ELEVEN
THANK YOU. I'M NOT GOING NUMBER
SEVENTY THREE THAT SEVEN THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MADAM CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBER EXACTLY WARM UP
ON BEHALF OF LA FAMILY HOUSING
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
NINETEEN LEVEN THANK YOU.
THANKS WILL I NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
AND FORTY SIX CENTS ONE FOUR SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MITCH
MANTOVA CANSECO HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION IN
SUPPORT. NOW THE LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO THAT'S ONE
FOUR TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON AMBER MADISON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT. AND WHAT THAT
MEANT I'M SURE WE HAVE EXHAUSTED
THE QUEUE. ALL RIGHT- DO WE HAVE
ANY BODY IN THE ROOM IN
OPPOSITION. IS THERE ANYBODY ON
THE LINE IN OPPOSITION. BUT
SPEAKING OPPOSITION OF AB ONE
NINE ONE ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I'M SURE
THERE IS NO ONE SHOWING UP IN
OPPOSITION TO AB NINETEEN ELEVEN
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU ANY COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS. FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS DR BURKE- SO ARE YOU
FIRST OF ALL YOU SORT OF HAVE
TWO PARTS TO THE BALLOT I'M NOT
SURE THAT THEY ARE ACTUALLY
COMPATIBLE. BUT LET'S FIRST TALK
ABOUT THE DEED RESTRICTED
PROPERTIES. ARM AGAIN HAVING
SERVED ON THE CITY COUNCIL I
KNOW HOW IMPORTANT IT IS TO KEEP
THESE DEED RESTRICTED
PROPERTIES. ARE GOING BUT NOT
ALL OF THEM ARE CREATED EQUAL
SOME OF THEM HAVE DONE
REASONABLE MAINTENANCE OVER THE
YEARS THERE WERE- SOMEONE TAKING
OVER. OTHERS YOU'RE MORE
QUESTIONABLE AND I'VE SEEN NON
PROFITS GET INTO PROBLEMS WHEN
THEY'VE PURCHASED THE BUILDING
AND THEN FIND OUT HALFWAY
THROUGH THAT. THEY REALLY CAN'T
MAKE IT WORK- I DON'T KNOW THAT
THERE'S ANY SOLUTION TO THAT BUT
IT'S SOMETHING. BASICALLY NOT
ALL PROPERTIES CREATED EQUAL
SOMETHING YOU MAY WANT TO THINK
ABOUT. SECOND PART AGAIN THIS IS
SO DIFFERENT IN AND PARTICULAR
MOBILE HOME PARK SO HAYWARD HAS.
NINE MOBILE HOME PARKS WHICH
REPRESENT- ARE REALLY AFFORDABLE
HOUSING OTHER AREAS- MOBILE HOME
RENT CONTROL- PEOPLE ARE
REQUIRED TO KEEP UP THE PARKS TO
A CERTAIN LEVEL. THEY'RE ALSO
WE'VE ZONED IT SO THE ONLY THING
THAT YOU COULD PUT IN THIS AREA
IS A MOBILE HOME PARK. FURTHER
IF A NONPROFIT WERE TO BUY THE
MOBILE HOME PARK AND WANTED TO
PUT IN. IN OUR APARTMENT
BUILDING. MOST OF THESE FOLKS
ARE RETIRED- FIXED INCOME. IT
WOULD BE A MAJOR DISRUPTION TO
THEIR LIVES SO I'M NOT QUITE
SURE THAT THIS IS THE RIGHT
THING TO DO. IN THAT
CIRCUMSTANCE SO THOSE ARE ALL
THINGS TO THINK ABOUT AS TIME
GOES ON I DON'T EXPECT YOU WOULD
HAVE A COMPREHENSIVE ANSWER
RIGHT THIS MINUTE. I JUST AS YOU
THINK AND IF YOU HAVE AN ANSWER
THAT'S CERTAINLY WORTH THINKING
ABOUT BUT THOSE OF US. YOU KNOW
TWO DIFFERENT CONCERNS THAT I
HAVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANK
YOU DR CORK AND ALL- OF- TRY TO
ADDRESS YOUR THOUGHTFUL
QUESTIONS QUICKLY THEN I'LL TURN
IT OVER TO MR STIVERS WHO HAS
THE REAL EXPERTISE HERE- BUT
JUST ON THE SECOND POINT. SO
THIS BILL IS NOT ABOUT
CONVERSION SO WHEN P. THAT
SOMEBODY WOULD BUY A MOBILE HOME
PARK AND THEN BUILD AN APARTMENT
BUILDING THE IDEA HERE IS ABOUT
PRESERVATION. OF EXISTING UNITS
THE IDEA HERE IS ABOUT
STABILIZING FAMILIES THAT LIVE
IN THOSE CURRENT UNITS RIGHT TO
ME THE EXAMPLE THAT I THINK OF
FOR THIS BILL. IS THERE'S A BIG
YOU KNOW APARTMENT BUILDING
SOMEWHERE THAT'S DEED RESTRICTED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND THEN ALL
OF A SUDDEN IT'S AT THE END OF
THOSE FIFTY FIVE YEARS OR
WHATEVER IT MAY BE AND IT'S
ABOUT TO BECOME MARKET RATE AND
SO. THOSE TENANTS ARE RESCUED D.
HERE IS TO CONVINCE THE OWNER OF
THAT BUILDING RATHER THAN
RAISING EVERYBODY'S RENTS TO
MARKET RATES OR SELLING THAT
BUILDING TO SOMEBODY WHO'S GOING
TO OPERATE IT OR TEAR DOWN AS
MARKET RATED. TO TRANSFER IT TO
A YOU KNOW AT THAT MISSION
DRIVEN NONPROFIT IN HAYWARD THAT
WOULD CONTINUE TO OPERATE AS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SO THOSE
FOLKS WOULD BE STABLE I SO I.
ALL OF THE LAST MISTER SHRIVER'S
COMMA BUT I DON'T THINK WE NEED
TO WORRY AS MUCH ABOUT THE
SECOND CONCERN- AND THEN ON THE
FIRST OKAY NO I AGREE. IF YOU'RE
IF IT HAS TO BE MAINTAINED HIS
MOBILE HOME PARK THERE WAS JUST
A QUESTION OF THE QUALITY OF THE
DEVELOPMENT. AND SHOULD BE
GIVING THE TAX BREAK ON IN ALL
CASES IN I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER
TO THAT SO I GUESS WHAT I WOULD
SAY THERE IS THAT- YOU KNOW
THAT'S- BECAUSE THIS IS
VOLUNTARY IT'S GOING TO BE A
MARKET MECHANISM THAT'S GOING TO
DRIVE IT. FIRST OF ALL YOU'D
HAVE TO HAVE A NONPROFIT. THAT
WOULD ONE ACQUIRED. PROPERTY
THEY WOULD BE DOING A LOT OF.
DEAL BUT ALSO THIS. THING IS
TRUE. OF A BUYER THAT WOULD BE
LOOKING TO OPERATE IT NOT. AS A
AND NOT AS AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS
MARKET RATE HOUSING NORMALLY
THEY WOULD COME IN. THE
UNWILLING TO BID ON THE BUILDING
BECAUSE IT WAS MAINTAINED
PROPERLY OR THERE WASN'T.
APPROPRIATE UPKEEP SO I DON'T
KNOW IF MR CYBER AS ANYTHING.
BUT I THINK TO ME THAT THE FACT
THAT IT'S NOT AUTOMATIC THE FUND
HAS TO BE A BUYER THAT WANTS TO
COME IN EITHER MARKET RATE FOR.
OR IN THIS CASE TO GET THE TAX
CREDIT- QUALIFIED NONPROFIT
DEVELOPER- THEY'RE PROBABLY NOT
GOING TO WANT TO BID ON A
PROPERTY THAT SUB STANDARD. I'VE
JUST SEEN IT HAPPEN SO. BUT
MAYBE THAT'S RARE IT MAY BE
SOMETHING I SHOULDN'T BE WORRIED
ABOUT THANKS FOR GOING I WOULD
ADD TO THAT IS THAT THEY THAT
THE NONPROFIT DEVELOPERS HAVE.
CHEN WE HAVE ACCESS TO RESOURCES
INTO MARKET TELEVISION NOT TO DO
A REHABILITATION LIKE SOME TYPE
OF SUBSIDY FROM THE CITY OR THE
STATE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING SO.
SOMETIMES THEY CAN ACTUALLY MAKE
THAT WORK OR THE MARKET SIDE.
CAN'T REALLY MAKE THAT WORK.
THANK YOU. THIS PETRIE-NORRIS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND- THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THAT MEASURE
FOR IT IS I THINK I'VE TOLD YOU
I THINK IT'S A REALLY GOOD IDEA
I JUST I'M WONDER IF YOU COULD
SPEAK TO THE POINT THAT WAS
RAISED IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
AROUND- THE FACT THAT KIND OF AS
THIS IS STRUCTURED IT WOULD
POTENTIALLY BE SUBSIDIZING
MARKET RATE UNITS AND IS THERE
ANY NOTHING THAT WE CAN DO OUR
WORK AROUND. THAT WE COULD
INCLUDE TO MITIGATE THAT YEAH
IT'S A VERY FAIR POINT- AND I
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION AND I'LL
ANSWER THEM ALLOW MR STIVERS TO
CHIME IN HERE I FIRST WHAT MIGHT
MY CONDITION AS I ASSUME THAT
THIS IS PROBABLY GOING TO BE MY
GUESS IS FEW AND FAR BETWEEN
CASES WHERE YOU HAVE SOMEONE
WHO'S WHO'S LIVING IN ONE OF
THOSE UNITS AND AGAIN EVENTUALLY
OVER TIME YOU'RE GOING TO
CAPTURE A 100% OF THE UNITS- AND
I GUESS THE OTHER THING I GOT
IS. YOU KNOW WE'RE LOOKING TO DO
THE BEST THAT WE CAN HER SO I
WOULD RATHER TAKE A BUILDING
HAVE NINETY OR 95% OR 89% OF
THOSE UNITS PRESERVED AND MAY BE
SUBSIDIZED ONE PERSON WHO WHO IS
IN A LOW INCOME TENANT TO LIVE
IN IT FOR SOME PERIOD OF TIME
THEN LOSE THE OPPORTUNITY TO ANY
OF THOSE UNITS AND SO I THINK
THAT'S JUST PART OF WHITE- WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO WORK YOUR **** MY
HOPE AND EXPECTATION IS IT'S
GOING TO BE RELATIVELY FEW AND
FAR BETWEEN WHERE YOU HAVE THAT
TYPE OF SITUATION ARISE I DON'T
KNOW. MARK IF YOU HAVE ANYTHING
YEAH JUST AT THE MARKET RATE
UNITS WOULD STILL RENT IT IF THE
PEOPLE ARE OVER INCOME THERE
THEY WERE THEY WERE ABOVE THE
LAW THE LOW INCOME RESTRICTION
IN THE BILL THEY WOULD CONTINUE
TO PAY MARKET RENT SO THEY WOULD
TURN OVER THE NORMAL WAY AND
MOST MARKET RATE UNITS TURNED
OVER ABOUT 42% PER YEAR SO IN
THREE YEARS YOU'RE PROBABLY
GONNA GET TO A 100% AFFORDABLE
DEVELOPMENT AND YOU HAVE FIFTY
TWO MORE YEARS UNDER THE
RESTRICTION WHICH IT'S
AFFORDABLE. THE OTHER
CONSIDERATION THERE IS THE
ALTERNATIVE TO THE WAY THE BILL
PROPOSES THAT IS IF THEY HAD TO
ALL BE AFFORDABLE ON DAY ONE
THOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE MAKING TOO
MUCH MONEY WOULD HAVE TO BE
EVICTED AND WE'RE REALLY TRYING
TO PREVENT EVICTIONS HERE AND
LET THE MARKET CURRENT TAKE ITS
COURSE TURN THESE OVER OVER TIME
BUT THAT SUCH A LONG DEED
RESTRICTION THAT WE THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF PUBLIC BENEFIT
FOR A VERY SHORT TIME I'M WHERE
FEW UNITS. WILL BE- MARKET RATE.
THANKS FOR. THAT THAT
CLARIFICATION I THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT. NUMBER LIVING YEAH I
THINK YOU SAW THAT ONE OF THE
POINTS THAT YOU MADE IN THE
PRESENTATION WAS THE- IT SHOULD
DEED RESTRICTIONS THAT ARE ARE
PRESENT IN THE CURRENT- HOUSING.
ONE OF THE- ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT HAS BEEN DONE BY BY PUBLIC
AGENCY MARIN COUNTY IN
PARTICULAR IS TO BUY EXISTING
HOUSING STOCK THAT COULD BE LOST
I DON'T THINK THAT ANY OF THAT.
WHAT IS DEED RESTRICTED BUT IT
WAS IF THEY DIDN'T PURCHASE IT
TO PRESERVE IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
LOST IT TO THE POINT THAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO MAKE- SO WHAT EXACTLY
IS THE DEED RESTRICTION
REQUIREMENT. IN IN YOUR BILL
THAT HAS TO BE PRE EXISTING FOR
PEOPLE QUALIFY FOR THAT. SO THE
IDEA HERE IS THAT IT'S BOTH A
DEED RESTRICTED SUBSIDIZED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ANY I GUESS
WHAT WE REFER TO AS NATURALLY
OCCURRING AFFORDABLE HOUSING SO
SORT OF WHAT YOU EXACTLY WHAT
YOU ARE MENTIONING- AND- WERE
THE ESTIMATES THAT THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
PUT OUT AGAIN MR STIVERS
MENTIONED THIS IS THE ENTITY
THAT WE AS THE LEGISLATURE
CREATED. AND SAID GIVE US ADVICE
ABOUT HOW TO DO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WHILE AND SO THEY'VE
COME BACK AFTER TALKING TO
MARKET PARTICIPANTS AND SAYING
WE THINK THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT IDEA. BUT IT'S LOOKING
AT EXACTLY THAT AS WELL- SO I
HAVE A- BUT- A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS KIND OF- FOLLOWING
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK I GUESS
FROM MY- LOCAL GOVERNMENT
EXPERIENCE. A LOT OF THE MOBILE
HOME PARKS OBVIOUSLY THEY DO
PROVIDE AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND-
MUCH OF IT IS A- NATURALLY
OCCURRING BUT WHAT WE'VE SEEN
OVER THE YEARS IS HE'S- OF
MOBILE HOME PARKS FALLING INTO
DISARRAY WHEN THEY'RE IN.
PRIVATE HANDS. HOW WOULD YOU
GUARANTEE. THAT THESE THESE
PARKS ARE MAINTAINED OVER THE
YEARS. WANT TO TAKE THAT MARK.
I'M THE FIRST FOR THE NONPROFITS
ARE MISSION ORIENTED IN THE
GINNELLY WILL ONLY GET INVOLVED
IN THESE IF THEY CAN. DO A GOOD
JOB OF MAINTAINING GOOD SOLID
STABLE HOUSING FOR THE RESIDENTS
BUT IT'S ALSO TRUE AS I
MENTIONED THAT THE NONPROFITS
HAVE- ABILITY ACCESS TO
RESOURCES THAT THE OTHER MARKET
PARTICIPANTS DO NOT SO- VERONICA
BRADY WAS MENTIONING AT THE CITY
WE HAVE THE MOBILE HOME PARK
PURCHASE AND REHABILITATION
PROGRAM. NONPROFIT TAX HAVE
ACCESS TO STATE FUNDS TO DO
REHABILITATION OF THOSE
DEVELOPMENTS IF THEY ARE
OCCUPIED BY LOWER INCOME
RESIDENTS AND SO- THAT PLUS THE
FACT THAT THE NONPROFITS AREN'T
SORT OF TRYING TO MAXIMIZE
PROFIT THEY'RE TRYING TO. YOU
KNOW BE IN FOR THE LONG TERM AND
PROVIDE STABLE HOUSING THIS IS
FINANCIALLY FEASIBLE BUT NOT
GENERATING A TON OF PROFIT.
UNDER THOSE WE THINK THAT THAT
THAT WE WILL BE ABLE TO MAINTAIN
A LOT THESE PROPERTIES OVER TIME
WHEN THERE'S ACTUALLY A
COMMITMENT TO DO THAT IS THERE
ANY WAY TO GUARANTEE THAT THE
NONPROFIT DOES THAT WELL. I MEAN
H. ET WILL BE MONITORING WELL
THE TICKET I'M SORRY T. CAT
COULD'VE MISTER THIS PROGRAM
WOULD BE MONITORING THESE
DEVELOPMENTS AND I USED TO RUN
THAT ORGANIZATION AND EVERY
THREE YEARS WE WENT OUT TO EVERY
SITE IN THE STATE AND MAKE SURE
THAT THEY WE DID A PHYSICAL
INSPECTION OF. SO TO THE EXTENT
THAT. THAT WERE NOT OCCURRING-
YOU KNOW THERE WOULD BE
CONSEQUENCES. TO THE OWNER AND-
IN ADDITION- IN THE MOBILE HOME
CONTACTS THERE ARE BOTH THE
STATE AND- SOMETIMES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. THEY HAVE
INSPECTION PROGRAMS THAT ARE
INDEPENDENT OF THAT THAT'S JUST
THEY DO IT OF ALL PARTS. OF
STATE FINANCED OR NOT SO- WE DO
HAVE QUITE A BIT OF. WE HAVE
QUITE A FEW TOOLS TO SORT OF
DEAL WITH THAT BUT IN TERMS OF A
GUARANTEED I MEAN IT'S HARD TO
SAY THAT. NOTHING WILL FALL
THROUGH THE CRACKS EVER BUT WE
HAVE QUITE A FEW SAFEGUARDS IN
PLACE TO TRY AND MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE PARTS ARE MAINTAINED OVER
TIME. AND THE OTHER THING AGAIN
FROM THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
PERSPECTIVE A LOT OF THESE
MOBILE HOME PARKS ARE NOT I MEAN
MOBILE HOMES ARE NOT COULD BE
LASTING FIFTY FIVE YEARS. I
MEAN. IF YOU'RE A LOT OF THE
PARKS READY HAVE MOBILE HOMES
THAT ARE. YOU KNOW HAVE HAD
DECADES OLD. AND IT SEEMS THAT
IN THE LONG RUN YOU MIGHT
POTENTIALLY DISINCENTIVE ISING
PUTTING PERMANENT. LOW INCOME
HOUSING ON THESE LOTS. IF YOU IF
YOU'VE LOCKED UP FOR FIFTY YEARS
HOW WOULD YOU DEAL WITH THAT
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT THAT IN. THE
CITY THAT I WAS AND- YOU KNOW
THERE WAS ALWAYS THE HOPE. THAT
YOU COULD TRANSITION PEOPLE INTO
MORE PERMANENT- SAY FOR HOUSING.
AND IF YOU'RE LOCKING UP THESE
OLD MOBILE HOME PARKS FOR FIFTY
FIVE YEARS. MIGHT NOT GET THERE
WELL SO THE OWNERS ROLE IN THIS
IS TO PROVIDE THE SPACES RIGHT
AND THEN THE INFRASTRUCTURE IN
THE PARK IN THE COMMON
FACILITIES IT IS THE HOMEOWNERS
THE RESIDENTS ACTUALLY BRING THE
HOME TO THE SITE AND SO- WE
WOULD WE'D BE RELYING ON THE
HOMEOWNERS TO. YOU KNOW MAINTAIN
THEIR HOME AND OR UPGRADE THEIR
HOME OVER TIME THAT DOES OCCUR
BUT IT'S ALSO TRUE THAT THIS M.
PROP PROGRAM ANY CD THAT I
MENTIONED BRIEFLY THEY DO HAVE
FUNDS AS WELL FOR HOMEOWNERS IN
THESE LOWER INCOME PARKS TO BE
ABLE TO REPLACE THE HOMES ON
OCCASION SO- I THINK THAT. THAT
WOULD BE THE WAY THAT WE WERE
TRYING TO THAT IS THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO KEEP THE MOBILE HOME
PARKS OVER THE LONG TERM BUT
UPGRADE THE HOUSING IN THE
MEANTIME BUT YOU DON'T SEE AT
SOME POINT THAT IT MIGHT BE
ADVANTAGEOUS IF THERE IS VERY
LITTLE LAND LEFT IN A CERTAIN
AREA THAT THIS MIGHT BE A PLACE
TO BUILD A MORE PERMANENT-
STRUCTURE. THAT THAT DOES
HAPPEN- OPEN TO. HOW YOU WOULD
LIKE TO ADDRESS THAT- YOU KNOW
THAT GENERALLY MEANS IS
DISLOCATION AND IT GENERALLY A
DIFFERENT GROUP OF PEOPLE COMES
AND OCCUPIES THE SITE AND THE
ONES WHO LIVED THERE BEFORE SO
THAT WAS KIND OF IT. DOESN'T
HAVE TO HAPPEN THAT WAY IS NOT
HAPPENS WE GO HAPPY TO SORT OF.
WORK WITH YOU ON THAT IF THERE'S
A IF YOU HAVE AN ITEM THAT YEAH
CAN I DO MY MANAGER IF I JUMP IN
THEREAS WELL. OF COURSE WELL I
WOULD CERTAINLY BE OPEN TO. YOU
KNOW YOUR IDEAS AND THOUGHTS
ABOUT HOW TO ADDRESS THAT I
GUESS WHAT I WOULD OFFER HERE AS
WELL IS THAT- YOU KNOW I THINK
THE PRIMARY SUSPECT THRUST OF
THIS BILL- AT LEAST AS I'VE
ALWAYS IMAGINED IT IS SORT OF
MULTI FAMILY UNITS AND- IN URBAN
AREAS AND WE BROUGHT IN. THE
CONCEPT OF MOBILE HOMES BECAUSE
IN CERTAIN PARTS OF THE STATES
THAT THAT MIGHT BE THE ONLY
NATURAL. OCCURRING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. BUT I SUSPECT KNOWING A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHO THESE
MISSION DRIVEN NONPROFITS ARE
THAT ARE GOING TO GO GET THE TAX
CREDITS FROM THE STATE. THE MOST
OF THEM ARE OPERATING IN LARGE
URBAN AREAS. FOCUSED ON THESE
TYPE OF MULTI FAMILY UNITS I
WOULD SUSPECT THAT THE
OVERWHELMING THRUST OF THIS
PROGRAM IS GOING TO BE YOU KNOW.
HOLLYWOOD COMMUNITY HOUSING
CORPORATION THAT'S GOING TO GO.
YOU KNOW WHAT PURCHASE A
BUILDING IN HOLLYWOOD TO KEEP A
HUNDRED TWENTY UNITS AFFORDABLE
OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT SO. IF
THERE IS CONCERN ABOUT THE
MOBILE HOME PIECE OF IT
CERTAINLY HAPPY TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION BECAUSE WHO
WOULDN'T WANT THAT TO. YOU KNOW
ANYWHERE INTERFERE WITH WITH
WHAT I THINK IS SORT OF THE
BROADER SUCH TO THE BILL HERE.
GREAT WELL. ANY OTHER. QUESTIONS
SO. FROM THE POINT OF VIEW OF
THE SELLER OF THE PROPERTY-
TYPICALLY IF YOU'RE AN INVESTOR
YOU WOULD TRY TO ROLL THAT INTO
A FUTURE INVESTMENT- TO AVOID
TAX IMPLICATIONS SO WITH THIS
ESSENTIALLY MEANS THAT THEY CAN
STILL KEEP SOME OF THAT MONEY
OUT OF THAT THAT- NEW INVESTMENT
SO THAT THEY WOULD PAY A COUPLE
GAINES ON WHAT PORTION THEY
DIDN'T CHOOSE TO INVEST THEY
WANNA SHOUT. THAT'S THAT THAT'S
EXACTLY RIGHT AND SORT OF
LISTENING IN ON THE CONVERSATION
HE PREVIOUSLY HAD ABOUT WHY IS A
TAX CREDIT EFFECTIVE TOOL TO USE
HERE WE THINK IT'S THE PERFECT
TOOL TO USE HERE BECAUSE A LOT
OF TIMES WHEN YOU HAVE A SELLER
WHO'S GONNA SELL THAT BUILDING
THEY'RE GONNA DO A TEN THIRTY
ONE RIGHT THEY'RE GONNA FLIP
THAT TO AVOID TAX CONSEQUENCES
INTO SOMETHING ELSE HERE AS MR
SHRIVER SAID THEY CAN CASH OUT A
LITTLE BIT OF ADEQUATE RIGHT AND
SO BECOMES VERY VERY ATTRACTIVE
AND IT ACTUALLY GIVES THE
NONPROFIT A LEG UP OVER SOMEONE
IN THE PRIVATE MARKET. TO
ACQUIRE THAT PROPERTY. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
WOULD YOU. LIKE TO GIVE US ANY
CLOSING THOUGHTS NO I APPRECIATE
THE- THE ROBUST CONVERSATION AND
CERTAINLY OPEN TO ANY AND ALL
FEEDBACK AND- YOU KNOW WE FEEL
REALLY GOOD ABOUT THIS PROPOSAL
WE THINK IT'S AN IMPORTANT
THING. YEAH I THINK IT WOULD
JUST BE EXCEPTIONALLY NEGLIGENT
FOR THE STATE TO IGNORE. THE
FACT THAT WE ARE GOING TO LOSE
TENS OF THOUSANDS UNITS OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE THINK THIS
IS A- A MARKET DRIVEN TARGETED
WAY TO. TO GET AT THE PROBLEM
AND WOOD- I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. ALL RIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL AND- YOU WILL NOW BE
PRESENTING TWENTY ONE FORTY TWO
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- ALSO PLEASE TODAY TO
PERCENT. AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
TWO. THIS WOULD RE ESTABLISH
CALIFORNIA'S EXEMPTION FOR
CURSOR. REPLACEMENT REBATES.
FROM GROSS INCOME. AND WILL
CREATE PARITY FOR TURF
REPLACEMENT REBATES WITH OTHER
SIMILAR PERMANENT TAX EXEMPTIONS
IN CALIFORNIA. FOR WATER
EFFICIENCY AND- ENERGY
CONFERENCE A- CONSERVATION THE
IDEA BEING HERE- THAT WE A LOT
OF. WATER DISTRICTS AROUND THE
STATE HAVE CREATED INCENTIVES
FOR PEOPLE TO CONSERVE WATER.
AND THEN WE GO AHEAD AND WE TAX
THE MONEY THAT THEY GET. IN
THOSE REBATES SO WE ADDED A
DISINCENTIVE ON TOP OF THE
INCENTIVE SO WE ARE WORKING AT
CROSS PURPOSES HERE. HI SUE SO
KNOWING THAT THE STATE
PREVIOUSLY HAD A GROSS INCOME
TAX EXEMPTION HERE. KNOWING THAT
A LOT OF OTHER TYPES OF WATER
CONSERVATION. WE PROVIDE AN
EXEMPTION FROM GROSS INCOME.
THAT WE THINK THIS IS A GOOD WAY
TO. FURTHER THOSE POLICY GOALS
WHICH I THINK ARE AN EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT WE KNOW THAT. A 100%
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA RIGHT
NOW IS IN A MODERATE DROUGHT.
ALMOST 90% OF IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS IN A SEVERE
DROUGHT. SO ANYTHING THAT WE CAN
DO TO. INCREASE THE INCENTIVE
THAT WE'RE PROVIDING TO FOLKS TO
TAKE STEPS TO CONSERVE WATER USE
WE'VE SEEN THESE PROGRAMS WORK.
A LOT UP AND DOWN THE STATE-
THIS SEEMS LIKE A MODEST WAY TO.
BRING SOME PARITY TO THE LAW-
AND ALSO TO FOR HOPEFULLY FOR
THOSE PURPOSES SO THAT WE CAN
CONSERVE WATER AND ADDRESS THE
DROUGHT. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU AND
YOU HAVE- TWO WITNESSES I DO I
DO WITH THIS IS- BY PHONE WE
HAVE ACT KATHY VIA TELE WITH THE
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. IN JULIA
BISHOP HALL FROM THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES.
ALL RIGHT. CAN THE MODERATOR
PLEASE CONNECT THIS IS THAT
CATHY FIRST STORER- JULIA FIRST
KATHY PLEASE RIGHT. IS CAPITAL
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAE IS
KATHY DID HELEN IN THE
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA- WE WISH TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL
FOR OFFERING. OFFERING AB TWENTY
FORTY TWO AND RECOGNIZING THAT
TOOK THE BAIT AN IMPORTANT TOOL
THAT WE USE TO ENCOURAGE
CONSERVATION. HELP METROPOLITAN
HOTEL WATER TO TWENTY SIX MEMBER
AGENCIES WHO IN TURN PROVIDE
HIGH QUALITY RELIABLE WATER TO
NINETEEN MILLION PEOPLE AND
BUSINESSES. AND NINETEEN NINETY
WE'VE INVESTED EIGHT HUNDRED AND
FORTY MILLION CONSERVATION
PROGRAM. RESULTING IN AN
ESTIMATED WATER SAVINGS OF THREE
MILLION ACRE FEET AND THAT'S
ENOUGH TO PROVIDE WATER FOR
NEARLY TEN MILLION HOMES. ACROSS
OUR ENTIRE SERVICE AREA ABOUT
68% OF THE TRIP REPLACEMENT
REBATE RECIPIENTS ARE MEDIUM TO
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS. IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE LEGISLATURE PASSED
AB SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN AND SB SIX OH
SIX. RIGHT HANDER HERTZBERG
WHICH LAUNCHED THE STATE ON THE
PATH TO MAKING CONSERVATION A
WAY OF LIFE. AND INTERNET STRONG
COURAGE GREATER WATER USE
EFFICIENCY IN HOMES AND
BUSINESSES WILL BE KEY TO ENSURE
THE SUCCESSFUL IMPLEMENTATION OF
THESE LAWS. YOUR REQUIREMENT
REBATES ONCE BENEFITTED FROM A
TAX EXEMPTION FROM THAT JANUARY
ONE TWENTY NINETEEN UNLIKE THE
PERMANENT TAX EXEMPTIONS IN
PLACE A WATER SAVING TOILETS AND
CLOTHES WASHERS. RESIDENTS AND
BUSINESSES THAT PARTICIPATE IN A
CONSERVATION PROGRAM SHOULDN'T
BE TAXED ON TURKEY DAY THEY
MIGHT OTHER CONSERVATION REBATES
AND ENERGY EFFICIENCY INCENTIVES
PROVIDED PUBLIC BENEFIT.
CONSERVATION GROUPS WATER SUPPLY
RELIABILITY AND IT HELPS
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA REDUCE ITS
RELIANCE ON IMPORTED SUPPLIES.
WE KNOW SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA TO
CONSERVE MORE WATER BY FOCUSING
ON OUTDOOR WATER USE WHICH HAS
BEEN CRITICALLY IMPORTANT NOW
THAT WE'RE IN THE THIRD YEAR OF
WHAT IS SHAPING UP TO BE A
HISTORIC DROUGHT. REINSTATING
THE TAX EXCLUSION FOR TURF
REPLACEMENT WILL FOSTER GREATER
PARTICIPATION IN OUR
CONSERVATION PROGRAMS ENSURE
CONSISTENCY AND HOW WE MANAGE
OUR PROGRAMS AND AVOID CONFUSION
AMONG THE PUBLIC WHY SOME
REBATES OR TAX THAN OTHERS NOT.
FOR THESE REASONS. METROPOLITAN
SUPPORT EIGHTY TWENTY ONE FORTY
TWO AM MEETING THE COMMITTEE TO
LOOK FOR. UPON THAT THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT AND WE HAVE A- JULIA
BISHOP. ON NEXT. YEAH GOOD
AFTERNOON KAREN MEMBERS MY NAME
IS JULIE BISHOP PAUL AT THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES AND WE'RE ONE OF THE
SPONSORS OF AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
TWO AND THIS BILL WOULD
REINSTATE CALIFORNIA TAX
EXEMPTION FOR TURF REPLACEMENT
REBATE IN CALIFORNIA WHICH IS
ALLOWED TO SUNSET IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. THESE REBATE PROGRAMS
ARE MORE CRITICAL THAN EVER THE
STATE IS IN ITS SECOND DROUGHT
WITHIN A DECADE AND EXPERIENCED
THE DRIEST JANUARY IN FEBRUARY
ON RECORD THIS YEAR AB TWENTY
ONE FORTY TWO RECOGNIZES THAT
CLIMATE CHANGE IS INCREASING THE
FREQUENCY AND SEVERITY DROUGHT
ADAPTATION IS A NECESSARY AND
CRITICAL LONG TERM GOAL. FURTHER
THE STATE HAS MADE A COMMITMENT
TO MAKE MAKING CONSERVATION A
CALIFORNIA WAY OF LIFE AS PART
OF THAT COMMITMENT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS IN THE PROCESS
OF ESTABLISHING A ARE YOU
SUBJECTED TO CREATE NUMERICAL
THAT AGENCIES MUST MEET. AB
TWENTY ONE FORTY TWO ADELINE
TURF REBATE PROGRAMS AND OTHER
PERMANENTLY EXEMPTED WATER
EFFICIENCY REBATES FOR TOILETS
AND WASHING MACHINE- REPLACEMENT
PROGRAMS LIKE THESE OTHER
REBATES PLAN IMPORTANT ROLE
CONTINUED. WATER EFFICIENCY AND
CONSERVATION EFFORT. FOR READING
PROVIDE A MUCH NEEDED FINANCIAL
INCENTIVE TO BE MORE EFFICIENT
YEAR ROUND. EVEN WITH INCENTIVES
MANY HOUSEHOLD WOULD NEED TO
INVEST THEIR OWN INCOME TO
REPLACE LAWNS. WITH DROUGHT
TOLERANT LANDSCAPING. IMPACTING
THESE REBATES IN THE SPECIAL
SIGNIFICANT BARRIER FOR LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS TO PARTICIPATE
. APPLE ONE OF OUR MEMBER
AGENCIES HAD A PROGRAM THAT WAS
DESIGNED SPECIFICALLY FOR LOW
pMANY HOUSEHOLD WITHDRAW FROM THE
PROGRAM WHEN THEY REALLY BEACH
REBATES WOULD BE CONSIDERED
TAXABLE INCOME. PRETTY DREAMLAND
AQUA SUPPORT AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
TWO AND WE ENCOURAGE THE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT THE
BILL AS WELL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. RIGHT
WITNESSES ON THE PHONE. AND I'LL
JUST REMIND YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION. THANK
YOU FEEL LIKE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR
OF AB TWENTY ONE FORTY TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE
ABOUT SIX IN QUEUE TO START
WE'LL START WITH LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE THAT'S
ONE THREE FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. DID YOU KNOW ABOUT STEINORTH
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANKS
LEVINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
FORTY THAT'S ONE FOUR ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MEDICARE AND
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE ANDREW
ANTS WE ON BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES
MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI IN SUPPORT.
X. LEVINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THREE THAT'S ONE THREE
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. JOLENE
MALINOVSKY BALL AND THEY HAVE
THE CONTRA COSTA WATER DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT. GROWING NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE THAT'S
ONE FOUR FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. HI THIS IS BETH A LOT SO ON
BEHALF OF INLAND EMPIRE
UTILITIES AGENCY AND CUCAMONGA
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANKS WELL I NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY NINE
THAT'S ONE FIVE NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
INTO THE MILLION ON BEHALF OF
MESA WATER DISTRICT IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY ONE FORTY TWO THANK
YOU. SUCH AS MY NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED INTO THAT'S ONE ZERO TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS ERIC
TURNER WOULD MEAN LET PATTERSON
ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF EASTERN
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT AND
SANTA MARGARITA WATER DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. ACTIONS BY
NUMBER SIXTY FOUR THAT SIX FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MADISON DIE
WITH POLITICAL SOLUTIONS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA WATER
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THIS IS
MY NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN THAT'S
TWO SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SH
GOOD AFTERNOON SIR MEMBERS
NOVOMATIC WITH THE CITY OF RED
CELL IN SUPPORT. NEXUS LINE
NUMBER SIXTY THREE THAT SIX
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
LINDA AND I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIA WATER EFFICIENCY
PARTNERSHIP FOR APOCALYPSE. AB
TWENTY ONE FORTY TWO- TRUST
SUPPORT CRITICAL THINKING.
EXHORT A LINE NUMBER TWENTY TWO
ZERO NINE ONE IS OPEN HEY. BIG
MORNING DOESN'T VIEW WATER
AGENCY ANTON ARE YOUNG COUNTY IN
SUPPORT. TEXAS MY NUMBER SIXTY
NINE THAT SIX NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
JIM WORLE WITH THE CAP
COMMUNITY WATER SYSTEMS ALLIANCE
IN SUPPORT. WELL NOT A LINE
NUMBER THIRTY TWO THAT'S THREE
TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS IS BRIAN SANDERS
WITH THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
TWO THANK YOU. TEXAS LINE NUMBER
FORTY THAT'S FOUR ZERO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK FORTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YES THIS IS OUR CALVET
LOUIS WITH THE JAVELIN WATER
DISTRICT ON THE GENERAL MANAGER
AND I LIKE TO EXPRESS THAT- WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THAT'S WHAT THAT
MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE EXHAUSTED
THE QUEUE IN SUPPORT. I DID NOT
HEAR WHAT HE SAID IS BECAUSE OF
HIS EXHAUSTED THE EXHAUSTED THE
SUPPORT. HE'S EXHAUSTED ANYONE
IN THE ROOM WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. ANYBODY ON THE PHONE
LINES IN OPPOSITION. QUESTIONS
FROM A SHORTAGE OF WHICH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY
ONE FORTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. MADAM
CHAIR AT THIS TIME NO ONE IS
SECURING UP IN OPPOSITION OF A.
B. TWO ONE FOUR TWO THANK YOU DR
COURT. YES AS WE DISCUSSED
EARLIER TODAY I HAVE PROBLEMS
WITH ANY PROGRAM INCLUDING THE
OTHER WATER PROGRAMS. THAT ARE
BASED UPON EXCLUSION GROSS
INCOME AND THE REASON FOR THAT
IS MAJORITY OF PEOPLE IN THE
STATE PAY VERY LITTLE IN STATE
TAXES AND THOSE MAKING A MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR PAID A 13% RATE.
SO ALMOST ALL OF THE BREAK BUT
YOU GET THE MONEY THAT YOU SPEND
GOES TO THE WEALTHIEST PEOPLE IN
THE STATE. AND I PREFER PROGRAM
FOR EXAMPLE- ON THE REBATES FOR
ELECTRIC VEHICLES WHERE IT'S YOU
LIMIT THE AMOUNT AND AS YOUR
INCOME GOES UP YOU GET LASSEN AS
YOUR INCOME GOES DOWN YOU GET
MORE. I PREFER PROGRAM THAT
WORKED THAT WAY I DON'T KNOW
THAT IT'S FEASIBLE BUT- I JUST
DON'T VOTE FOR BILLS LIKE THIS.
IN RESPONSE YEAH THANK YOU THANK
YOU DR CARSON I KNOW WE GOT IT
OPPORTUNITY TO CHAT A LITTLE
ABOUT THIS. EARLIER TODAY- JUST
FOR THE BENEFIT OF THE
COMMUNITY. YOU KNOW PART OF THE
REASON THAT THE REBATE IS
TARGETED THE WAY IT IS AS IF YOU
THINK ABOUT WHO ARE THE FOLKS
THAT HAVE THESE MASSIVE LAWNS OR
YOU KNOW HAVE THESE BIG WATER
BILLS IT'S NOT ALL IT'S NOT A
LOT OF LOW INCOME FOLKS RIGHT
AND I APPRECIATE THE EQUITY
CONCERNS BUT IF WE WANT TO.
INCENTIVIZE THOSE WHO WHERE
WHERE THE GREATEST SAVINGS AS
POSSIBLE IT'S LIKELY TO BE
TARGETED AT THOSE YOU KNOW FOLKS
WHO HAVE REALLY BAG. REALLY BIG
HOMES WITH BIG LAWNS AND THEY'RE
THEY'RE USING A LOT OF WATER
THERE. YEAH I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT THE FEW HUNDRED DOLLARS
THEY GET BACK IS PROBABLY. NOT
THAT MUCH OF AN INCENTIVE TO
THESE REALLY HIGH INCOME EARNERS
ANYWAY. WELL I APPRECIATE THAT I
GUESS WE'LL ALL IT WOULD OFFER
THERE'S I THINK YOU'VE HEARD A
LOT OF WATER DISTRICTS. TESIFY
HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THEY'VE TESTIFIED THAT
THEIR EXPERIENCES THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT HAS WORKED AND
HELP TO. HELP TO SAVE WATER AND
SO- YOU KNOW I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT- FROM FROM FROM THAT
PERSPECTIVE AND IT ALSO JUST
OFFER HERE IN TERMS OF THE
PUBLIC BENEFIT HERE. SAVING THE
WATER BENEFITS EVERYBODY RIGHT
THIS IS THE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL
IS NOT TO PROVIDE A TAX REBATE
TO- SOME HIGH INCOME FOLKS IT'S
TO HELP EVERYBODY IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. AS WERE
ADDRESSING OUR WATER ISSUE AND
SO EVEN THOUGH IT'S TARGETED TO
A SPECIFIC GROUP OF PEOPLE. THE
BENEFIT OF THIS BILL I THINK IS
VERY. IS VERY BROADLY TARGETED
THANK YOU. I'M SO. HAPPY TO BE A
CHARACTER THAT I. COULD I MAKE
A- GOOD I REPLIED TO DOCTOR
BURKE THIS IS KATHY. WELL I'M-
pIS THIS ONE OF YOUR WITNESSES O.
OKAY. PLEASE I'M I JUST WANTED
TO RESPOND TO DR PARK QUESTION
BECAUSE I THOUGHT IT MIGHT BE
HELPFUL TO EXPLAIN HOW THE
METROPOLITAN PROGRAM WORK AND WE
CURRENTLY HAVE A CAP ON THE
AMOUNT OF THE REBATE SO IT'S
CURRENTLY TWO DOLLARS AFTER
SQUARE BUT AFTER FIVE THOUSAND
SQUARE FEET FOR RESIDENTIAL I'M
HOME SO THAT IS THE MAXIMUM-
REBATES WOULD BE TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS WE USED IN THE PAST IN
THE PREVIOUS DROUGHT WE DIDN'T
HAVE A CAT AND SO THERE WILL
REPORT YOU KNOW THAT- WEALTHY
HOUSEHOLDS WITH LARGE LARGE
AREAS WERE BENEFITING FROM THE
PROGRAM BUT THAT'S NOT REALLY
THE CASE ANY LONGER THE AVERAGE
SIZE. OF THE TRUCK REPLACEMENT
REBATES THAT PARTICIPATE IN OUR
PROGRAM IS ABOUT TWELVE HUNDRED
TO THIRTEEN HUNDRED SQUARE FEET
AND SO THE MAJORITY OF THE
PARTICIPANTS IN OUR PROGRAM ARE
USUALLY AND I THINK I SHARED A
STATISTIC WE SAID ABOUT 68% OF
THOSE INVOLVED IN THE PROGRAM
FOR SORT OF LOW TO MEDIAN INCOME
HELPFUL FOR THAT. THAT'S WHO WE
ARE TARGETING RIGHT NOW. BUT
THEN THEY GET LITTLE TOO BY AS
WELL THAT. LOOK THIS IS JUST
SOMETHING I'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT FOR THE- SIX ZERO EIGHT
YEARS I'VE BEEN ON THIS
COMMITTEE BUT THANK YOU. I I'M
JUST CURIOUS THAT PRICE TAG ON
THIS IS ACTUALLY PRETTY LOW SO I
ASSUME THAT'S BECAUSE- MOST OF
THESE REBATES ARE NOT REPORTED
TO THE IRS WITHOUT THE CORRECT.
IT THAT'S PROBABLY RIGHT. AND
DID YOU THINK THEY KNOW THAT
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO ARE THEY
ISSUE TEN NINETY NINES BY ANY OF
THE WATER AGENCIES YOU KNOW I'D
HAVE TO LET THE WATER AGENCIES
SPEAK TO THAT BUT I THINK PART
OF THE PROBLEM HERE IS THAT
FOLKS PROBABLY GET CONSERVE
CONFUSED RIGHT I MEAN THEY'VE
THEY'VE- PUT IN. A WATER
EFFICIENT TOILET THEY PUT IN A
WATER EFFICIENT WASHING MACHINE
THAT'S EXCLUDED FROM GROSS
INCOME SO THEY MAY NOT KNOW SO
PART OF THIS IS JUST ABOUT
CREATING YOU KNOW UNIFORMITY AND
CONSISTENCY WITH THE WAY THAT WE
TREAT THESE ROAD REPAIRS BUT I
DON'T KNOW IF ANY OF THE
WITNESSES WANT TO. WANT TO SPEAK
TO THAT. YES NATALIE ALL THOSE
ISSUES. ALL RIGHT JOINT KATHY.
WHAT DOES IT ALL OF OUR MEMBERS. THIS IS SOMEBODY SPEAKING OR
DID I. DO WE ARE ABDUCTED HELD
FOR METROPOLITAN WE DO ISSUE A
TEN NINETY NINE AND THEY'RE ALSO
NOTIFIED THAT THEY'LL BE
RECEIVING A TEN NINETY NINE WHEN
THEY ENROLL IN THE PROGRAM.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE. YEAH
I THINK YOU MANAGER I GUESS WE
JUST WANT TO- MAYBE CLARIFY TWO
THINGS ONE IS THAT. I KNOW WE'VE
BEEN TALKING A LOT ABOUT TURF
REBATES WHICH IS TO MAKE CLEAR
THIS IS NOT. JUST A REBATE AND
OFTEN IS. IN IN IN MANY CASES
NOT A REBATE FOR INSTALLING
PLASTIC TURF THIS IS ABOUT
RIPPING UP GRASS OR SOMETHING
ELSE AND PUTTING IN. DROUGHT
TOLERANT LANDSCAPING OR TRICKY
DRIP IRRIGATION SYSTEMS OR
SOMETHING ELSE I KNOW WHEN
PEOPLE HEAR TURF THEY MAY BE
THINKING ONE THING- BUT I JUST
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT WAS
CLEAR FOR FOLKS. AND THEN I
GUESS THE FINAL THING I WOULD
ADD IS THAT YOU KNOW. I'M IN
CONVERSATIONS THAT I'VE HAD WITH
FOLKS WHO'VE MADE THIS DECISION
PEOPLE REALLY LIKE THE NOTION
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO SAVE MONEY
PEOPLE LIKE THE NOTION THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO DO GOOD AND DO
WELL AT THE SAME TIME. AND I
THINK THAT IS A POWERFUL
MOTIVATOR FOR PEOPLE'S BEHAVIOR
AND THAT THEY CAN FEEL REALLY
GOOD LIKE THEY'RE DOING
SOMETHING THAT'S GOOD FOR THE
STATE AND GOOD FOR THE FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT ALSO SAVING. A FEW
BUCKS IN THE PROCESS SO WITHOUT.
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION
WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
AYE VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
GABRIEL. ALL RIGHT OUR NEXT ITEM
IS AGENDA ITEM FIVE AB SEVENTEEN
OH TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
I EXPECTED TO STAY HERE UNTIL
THE VERY END SO- GRATEFUL TO GET
THIS GONNA MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
I'D LIKE TO START BY- WHENEVER
THIS DOES COME UP FOR A VOTE-
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS WILL WILL TAKE THEM
AB SEVEN ZERO TWO WOULD SUSPEND
SALES TAXES ON RETAIL PURCHASES
OF COBIT NINETEEN HOME TEST KITS
IN HIGH QUALITY FACE MASKS.
THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY FIVE THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF COVERED NINETEEN
CASES IN CALIFORNIA HAS REACHED
NEARLY EIGHT POINT FIVE MILLION
WHILE THE STATE WIDE MASK
MANDATE HAS RECENTLY BEEN LIFTED
MASTER STORE REQUIRED IN MANY
PLACES SUCH AS ON PUBLIC TRANSIT
AIRPORTS IN HEALTH CARE SETTINGS
OF COURSE WE'VE ALSO HEARD OF
NEW VARIANTS THAT MAY REQUIRE US
TO MASK UP YET AGAIN WARY MASKS
AND USING AT HOME TEST KITS IS
ESSENTIAL TO STOPPING THE SPREAD
OF CODED. CALIFORNIA SHOULD
PRIORITIZE REDUCING ECONOMIC
BARRIERS THAT PREVENT RESIDENTS
FROM PURCHASING PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT THIS BILL SEEKS TO
HELP ELIMINATE A FINANCIAL
BURDEN ON THOSE WHO ARE ALREADY
STRUGGLING DURING THE PANDEMIC
TAX EXEMPTIONS FOR MEDICAL
EQUIPMENT IS SOMETHING
CALIFORNIA HAS A LONG HISTORY OF
DOING TO FURTHER SUPPORT
RESIDENTS HEALTH. CALIFORNIA
EXEMPTS A LARGE NUMBER OF
MEDICAL RELATED EQUIPMENT FROM
STEALTH SALES TAX SUCH AS
CRUTCHES CANES FIRST AID KITS
WHEELCHAIRS AND MORE AND WE
SHOULD NOT CREATE ANY MORE
RESTRICTIONS FOR THOSE LOOKING
PROTECT THEMSELVES AND OTHERS
AGAINST COVE I PROVIDING A
TEMPORARY TAX EXEMPTION FACE
MASKS AND AT HOME TEST KITS IS A
SMALL WAY WE CAN HELP
CALIFORNIANS BETTER PROTECT
THEMSELVES AND OTHERS. AGAINST
RATKO IT. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER A LEVINE THAT-
YOU HAVE AS YOUR PRIMARY WITNESS
SAID BENJAMIN LEE WITH THE CAST
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION
SECRETARY. YEAH ALRIGHT THIS
MODERATOR. CAN YOU PLEASE
CONNECT US WITH MISTER LEE. GOOD
AFTERNOON CARE MEMBERS AND
COMPETE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
TODAY THE COMPANY TAXPAYERS THE
INDUSTRY CAN YOU TRY TO. GET A
LITTLE CLOSER TO THE MICROPHONE
OR SPEAK A LITTLE LOUDER. SURE
NOT A PROBLEM IT IS WELL BETTER
YES. GOT IT THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY THE
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION
IS PLEASED TO SUPPORT AB
SEVENTEEN OH TWO WHICH WILL
PROVIDE A TEMPORARY SALES AND
USE TAX EXEMPTION FOR COVERT
NINETEEN PREVENTION AND RESPONSE
GOOD AT BOTH THE STATE AND LOCAL
LEVEL CALIFORNIA HAS A LONG
HISTORY OF SUPPORTING RESIDENTS
HEALTH BIKE SOMETHING MOST
PURCHASES OF MEDICINE AND
MEDICINAL PRODUCTS UNTIL THE
NEEDS TAX. EXAMPLES INCLUDE
SYRINGES CATHETERS WHEELCHAIRS
CRUTCHES CANES METAL KITS AND
MUCH MORE SINCE TWENTY TWENTY
CALIFORNIA HAS URGED RESIDENTS
TO DO THEIR PART TO SLOW THE
SPREAD OF COVER NINETEEN AND
THAT MEANS AMONG OTHER THINGS
BUYING AND WEARING HIGH QUALITY
PROPERLY FITTING MASK AND
GETTING TESTED. DURING THE
PANDEMIC FACE COVERINGS AND
TESTS ARE MEDICAL NECESSITIES AS
CALIFORNIA BEGINS TO TRANSITION
FROM PANDEMIC TO ENDEMIC THESE
TOOLS REMAIN VITAL FOR
CONTROLLING OUTBREAKS AND
ENSURING THAT CODE NINETEEN
REMAINS A MEDICAL. LOCAL TO
MICROPHONE SPEAKER LONGER. SURE
WELL BETTER YEAH. CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TODAY THE COMPANY TECH
PRECIPITATION APRIL ECHO- THAT
YOU THE OKAY. HI HI OKAY OKAY
BEGINS FROM PANDEMIC TO AND THAT
MAKE THESE TOOLS REMAIN VITAL
FOR CONTROLLING OUTBREAKS
ENSURING THAT CODE NINETEEN
REMAINS A MEDICAL DISEASE FOR
HOSPITALS AND HEALTH SYSTEMS BYE
EXEMPTING MATHESON AT HOME TESTS
FROM TAXATION CALIFORNIA WILL
SUPPORT PUBLIC HEALTH AND
PROVIDE EQUAL TAX TREATMENT WITH
OTHER HEALTH CARE PRODUCTS.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT ANY OTHER
OF ANY WITNESSES IN THE ROOM
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT- OF
WHAT THE MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THE MAIN LINE FOR SUPPORTING
TESTIMONY
-
DO WE HAVE ANYBODY ON THE LINE.
WE APOLOGIES MADAM CHAIR I HAD
MYSELF MUTED AND WAS UNAWARE IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF
AB SEVENTEEN OH TO PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
DOES NOT KERRY OF ANYONE QUEUING
UP AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WE
HAVE PLAN- A SPEAKER IN
OPPOSITION- CAN YOU PLEASE
CONNECT US WITH- MISS CORBIN
FROM THE CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION. BY MADAM CHAIR
MEMBER CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE
CAN. ASSEMBLY MEMBER CORBIN WITH
THE CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
HOUSTON- HAVE TO SAY FOR A FIRST
LADY MADAM CHAIR VERY HEARTENED
BY THE CONVERSATION TODAY AND
REALLY APPRECIATE A LOT OF THE
DISCOURSE AROUND. STATES
PRIORITIES AND VALUING- TARGETED
PROGRAMS AND IT IS FOR THOSE
VERY REASONS BUT AT THE TIME WE
DO HAVE AN OPPOSED TO AN ON THAT
MEASURE- BAND- I AS HAS STATED A
NUMBER OF MEDICAL AND
PHARMACEUTICAL- ISSUES THAT DO
RECEIVE. A TAX INCENTIVE FOR
CONSUMERS HOWEVER THERE ARE
OTHER EXAMPLE HERE THAT DON'T
KEEP AND POINT YOU KNOW SO-
THERE ARE JUST SOME BEHAVIORS
THAT FOLKS. ARE GOING TO DO
REGARDLESS AND OTHERS ARE NOT
AND CERTAINLY THE STATE IS THEN
HEATED CONVERSATION AMONG VOTERS
ABOUT- CODE NINETEEN AND HOW TO
MOVE FORWARD IN IN TERMS OF
THEIR RESPONSE AND SO IF THE
AUTHOR CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD
ON THE PATHWAY WE WOULD SIMPLY
ASK THAT HE WHO ARE LOOKING AT
SOMETHING THAT'S A LITTLE MORE
TARGETED- PERHAPS LOOKING INTO
AND YOU. BRING THAT AS MR
PERKINS MENTIONED A VARIETY OF
TIME TODAY THERE'S A GRANT
PROGRAM OR SOMETHING THAT'S
REALLY NARROW DOWN TO THAT
CALIFORNIANS THAT NEED BE
PRODUCT AND ARE FOR OTHER
REASONS UNABLE TO ACCESS THEM-
RATHER THAN SIMPLY DROPPED. A
SIXTY MILLION DOLLAR A YEAR HAND
OUT TO A LOT OF FOLKS WHO
OTHERWISE WOULD ALREADY BE
PURCHASING KNOWS THESE PRODUCTS
HELP I HAVEN'T HAD THE CHANCE TO
SPEAK WITH THE OFFICE OFFICE
LOOK FORWARD TO DOING SO AS AS
WE MOVE FORWARD- BUT FOR THOSE.
REASONS REMAIN IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. RIGHT HIS CAR ANYBODY
THE ROOM WHICH TO SPEAK. IS
THERE ANYBODY ON THE LINE IN
OFFICE. MISTER CAN I HAVE THE-
MODERATOR PLEASE CHECK FOR
OPPOSITION. ON YES IF YOU WHICH
IS. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO A. B. ONE SEVEN
ZERO TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I'M SURE
WE DO HAVE ONE THAT IS LATE
QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
AND WATER LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN THAT'S ONE
ONE FIVE YEAR ONE IS OPEN.
TRANSAMINASE THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES YEAH I
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED TO PROTECT. THE LOCAL
RAGE WE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO POINT OUT AND
LEADERSHIP ON THE MATTER- WE-
ARE ALL OF OUR- THANK YOU BANG
OCTOBER THE LAST COMMENT OPEN AT
THE OUT THERE CAN FIND MORE
TARGETED- WAY TO SUPPORT THOSE
WHO NEED THE SUPPORT THANK YOU
SO MUCH. RIGHT THANK YOU A
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. MISTER CLARK. SO MY
CONCERNS ARE PRETTY MUCH THE
SAME ISSUE TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION I PREFER A MORE
TARGETED PROGRAM I THINK THE
BEST EXAMPLE OF THIS IS THE
SPEAKER IN PRO TEM THEY
BASICALLY SAID LOOK WE'RE NOT
GOING TO GIVE WE'RE NOT GOING TO
JUST TAKE. THE GAS TAX AND GIVE
PEOPLE A REBATE ON THAT WE'RE
NOT EVEN SURE WILL ACTUALLY
DECREASE THE PRICE. STEP WE'RE
GOING TO GIVE ALL THOSE FOLKS
YOU LOWER INCOMES MONEY AND
PHASE OUT THE PROGRAM OVER.
INCOME SO THAT'S THE KIND OF
APPROACH I PREFER IN THIS CASE
THANK YOU. YEAH IT THANK YOU
DOCTOR CREEK I APPRECIATE THAT I
THINK THE ISSUE- WITH THE GAS
TAX ARE FOR SO I THINK IT WAS A
- A POORLY WORDED WAY TO PROVIDE
SOME. COST OF LIVING RELIEF FOR
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA- THAT
REALLY ISN'T JUST ABOUT GAS IS
JUST THE COST OF LIVING AND
INFLATION IS UP AND- PEOPLE NEED
RELIEF AND YOU REALLY NEED TO
TARGET THAT. BUT THE ISSUE ON
THE GAS TAX ITSELF WAS BECAUSE
FOR OVER A DECADE THERE HAVE
BEEN SURCHARGES THAT GAS
STATIONS AND OIL REFINERIES
CANNOT JUSTIFY. AND THAT IF WE
WERE TO NOT CHARGE- YOU TARGET
OUR GAS TAX THAT WE HAVE THAT'S
THE ONE. THAT THERE IS NO PROOF
THAT THAT SAVINGS WOULD GET
PASSED ON TO ANYONE AT THE GAS
PUMP THEY WOULD JUST MAINTAIN-
THE SURREAL HIGH GAS PRICES
THAT- THAT WE CAN'T ACTUALLY
RATIONALIZE. UN ON THIS ISSUE
THOUGH I WOULD I WOULD ARGUE-
DIFFERENTLY- BECAUSE I RESPECT
YOUR APPROACH PARTICULARLY ON ON
THE ITEMS TODAY IS THAT THESE
ARE NOT LUXURY GOODS WERE EARLY
ADOPTERS ARE THE ONES WITH
MONEY. THIS IS TO USE THE TERM
SURREAL. A NECESSITY FOR
EVERYBODY IN CALIFORNIA THAT NO
ONE HAD TWO YEARS AGO. AND SALES
TAXES THE MILK BOWL THE PROBABLY
THE MOST REGRESSIVE TAX THAT WE
HAVE AND SO THIS IS PROBABLY THE
BIG EASIEST WAY TO TARGET I
ACTUAL SAVINGS AT THE TILL. FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE BUYING THINGS
THAT PERHAPS IT OTHERWISE RATHER
HAVE THAT TEN CENTS ON THE
DOLLAR FOR SOMETHING THAT IS NOT
MORE IMPORTANT BUT IS ALSO
IMPORTANT- AND SO THIS IS A WAY
TO SAY LOOK AN EEVEE CHARGER-
MAYBE FOR GONNA TALK ABOUT
CLIMATE CHANGE COULD PROTECT
LIFE- BUT THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH EVERYONE
SHOULD HAVE THIS AND WE AND THIS
IS A REASON TO- MAKE SURE THAT
THIS IS THE EASIEST WAY TO PASS
THOSE SAVINGS ON- AND- AND SO I
RESPECT THE- POINT THAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO MAKE. BUT I WOULDN'T I
WOULDN'T USE THE GAS TAX AS THE
EXAMPLE FOR THE SIGN I ENJOYED
HAVING THAT TYPE OF A- ABILITY
TO ARGUE WITH YOU ON- THE
SEMANTICS OF THAT SO THANK YOU
OKAY. THANK YOU- I WOULD JUST
SAY IF YOU'RE GIVING LOW INCOME
PEOPLE MONEY THEY CAN DECIDE
WHAT'S BEST FOR THEIR HEALTH
WHICH MIGHT BE MORE FOOD OR PAY
THE RENT WHATEVER BUT IN AND
WILL AGREE TO DISAGREE YEAH YOU
KNOW BUT I ACTUALLY AGREE WITH
YOU LIKE YOU KNOW WHATEVER THIS
GAS FAKE A GAS TAX REBATE THING
IS GOING TO BE THAT IT'S
ESSENTIALLY UPI AND WE'RE WE'RE
GONNA BE GIVING MONEY TO PEOPLE.
AND HELP THEM MAKE THOSE GOOD
CHOICES BUT THIS IDEA I LIKE THE
LAST OPPOSITION HAD THIS TAX
WINDFALL SALES TAX WINDFALL ON
THESE ITEMS DID NOT EXIST IN
FEBRUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY- AND
SO TO SAY- MORE OR SOMEHOW
TAKING MONEY OUT OF THE POCKETS
OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT BECAUSE THE
SALES TAX I THINK IS A MISTAKEN
BUT THANK YOU. AND WE WILL
CONTINUE DISAGREE ON. OF THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF MR LEVINE WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE. YEAH THIS WAS A
LOT OF FUN I DO APPRECIATE THE
DEBATE AND THE IMPORTANCE OF
THIS ISSUE AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE WHEN THAT
MOMENT IN TIME COMES UP FOR ALL
OF US THANK YOU SO MUCH
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU. LEVINE WE
ARE GOING TO TAKE A PAUSE FOR A
MOMENT AND OPEN THE VOTE ON OPEN
THE ROLE ON THAT AB SEVENTEEN OH
SEVEN- FOR THE PEOPLE THAT WERE
ABSENT INITIALLY. GRAYSON.
GRAYSON I WALLAN. MULLIN I RIVAS
RIVERSIDE RIGHT NOW WE HAVE THE-
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS SO WHERE TO GO
NEEDS TO- LEAVE SO WE ARE GOING
TO LET HIM VERY I APOLOGIZE FOR
EVERYBODY THAT'S BEEN WAITING.
WE'RE GOING TO PULL- WE'RE
PULLING IT REMOVING IT- I CATCH
REPRESENTING- OKAY. THAT WORKED
OUT WELL I DID WANT TO BUT OKAY
NO- THAT SO THEN- MR MACDONELL
WILL BE- MAD AT YOU SO THAT'S
GREAT. SO ITEM ELEVEN SIXTEEN
TWENTY NINE IS REMOVED ALL BY
THE AUTHOR OF MOVED BY THE
AUTHOR ALL RIGHT. THIS ROAD ON.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY SEVEN.
INSTEAD OF IS THE PRODUCTION OF
CRUCIAL EQUIPMENT TO ARTS
SUPPORTER SUPPLY CHAIN BY
ESTABLISHING A 6% TAX CREDIT FOR
MACHINERY USED TO MANUFACTURE.
INTERMODAL EQUIPMENT AND ITS
COMPONENT PARTS. WITH THE
IMPACTS OF COVERT NINETEEN WITH
THE INCREASING CONSUMER DEMAND
DURING THE ECONOMIC RECOVERY
CALIFORNIA'S PORTS ARE SEEING
UNPRECEDENTED LEVELS OF CARGO
CONGESTION YOU ARE FAMILIAR WITH
THIS. WITH CONTAINERS PILING UP
AT OUR PORTS AND AN
UNPREDICTABLE SHE AND
UNPREDICTABLE SHIPPING TIME SHE
COME IN MORE COMMON WE ARE
FEELING THE EFFECTS OF A GLOBAL
SUPPLY CHAIN CRISIS. THIS ISN'T
UNIQUE TO SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IT
IS GLOBAL ONE FACTOR THAT HAS
CONTRIBUTED THIS CRISIS HAS BEEN
THE LACK OF SUFFICIENT
INTERMODAL EQUIPMENT CHASSIS IS
C. OF THE BOX THE CONTAINER THAT
GOES ON TOP OF THE CHASSIS. AND
THE CHANCES OF THE WILL WITH THE
FRAME ON THEM. AND A LOT OF
TIMES PEOPLE SO WE DON'T OF
TRUCK DRIVERS THAT MAY BE THE
CASE IN SOME INSTANCES BUT OFTEN
IT IS REALLY THAT WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH CHASSIS IS TO PUT THE
CONTAINERS ON AND GET THEM OUT
OF THE PORT OR MOVE THEM
SOMEWHERE ELSE. THIS EQUIPMENT
HELPS TAKES GOODS FROM OUR PORTS
AND MOVES THEM FURTHER DOWN THE
SUPPLY CHAIN TOWARD THEIR
ULTIMATE DESTINATION. THE DEMAND
FOR THIS COMMITMENT AS A
OUTPACED SUPPLY WORLDWIDE MAKING
IT MUCH MORE DIFFICULT FOR OUR
PORTS TO GET THE CHASSIS IS THEY
NEED WHEN THEY NEED THEM. BUT
MAJORITY AN OVERWHELMING
MAJORITY OF THE CHASSIS IS ARE
MANUFACTURED. OVERSEAS AND
THAT'S NOT A GOOD THING FOR OUR
ECONOMY OR REALLY OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY. IN ORDER TO AVOID
FUTURE EQUIPMENT SHORTAGES AND
DROUGHT AND DR JOB JOB CREATION
WE TO HELP FOSTER INCENTIVIZE
DOMESTIC MANUFACTURER OF THIS
EQUIPMENT. AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY
SEVEN WILL HELP OUR CHASSIS
DOMESTIC MANUFACTURE IT WILL
HELP CHECK- DOMESTIC CHASSIS
MANUFACTURING BY PROVIDING A TAX
CREDIT ON THE MACHINES NEEDED TO
PRODUCE THIS CRITICAL PIECE OF
EQUIPMENT. AND JOINING ME TODAY
TO TESTIFY IS MIKE JACOB VICE
PRESIDENT AND GENERAL COUNSEL
FOR THE PACIFIC MERCHANT
SHIPPING ASSOCIATION AND I
BELIEVE LIKELY ON FOR ON THE
PHONE IS MARTHA MILLER EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
SOURCES ASSOCIATION OF PORT
AUTHORITIES. HI BUT GOOD
AFTERNOON MIKE JACOB PMSA- AND-
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FOR A LONG **** COME IN
SUPPORT. MISTER DOLLARS MEASURE
TODAY- AS HE SAID WE'RE IN THE
MIDST OF A SPY CHEN CRISIS
EVERYONE. IS QUITE A LETTER
WHERE OF ALL THOSE ISSUES- BUT
CERTAINLY ONE OF THEIR- MAJOR
COMPLICATING FACTORS IS THE LACK
OF INTERMODAL EQUIPMENT
ACCESSIBILITY- OUR CONTAINERS
FRANKLY JUST DON'T MOVE UNLESS
WE HAVE WILL SITES- THOSE. REAL
SETS ARE NOT PRIMARILY
MANUFACTURED IN THE UNITED
STATES AND- THE IRONIC OUTCOME
MOST OF WHERE WE ARE TODAY IS
THAT IN ORDER TO MOVE.
INTERNATIONALLY PRODUCED
MANUFACTURED GOODS WE NEED MORE
DOMESTIC MANUFACTURING AND
PRODUCTION- WE'RE LEFT WITH A- A
SITUATION WHERE WE'RE ASKING
THIS BODY- TO CONSIDER LOTS OF
DIFFERENT WAYS TO ADDRESS THE
SUPPLY CHAIN CRISIS BUT ONE OF
THEM. IS TO ACCELERATE
MANUFACTURING AT HOME OF THIS
TYPE OF EQUIPMENT. MANUFACTURERS
INVESTMENT CREDIT IS A WELL
KNOWN WELL UNDERSTOOD MECHANISM
FOR ADDRESSING THAT ISSUE- AND
WE APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT
MOVING FORWARD WHEN IT'S TIME TO
DO SO. THANK AND THEN YOU CAN
WITH THE MODERATOR PLEASE
CONNECT US WITH MARTHA MILLER.
THANK YOU MARTHA. IF YOU COULD
SPEAK A LITTLE LOUDER THAT WOULD
BE HELPFUL. OR MOVE A LITTLE.
BACK. ONE SECOND I'M COMING UPON
COMPLEMENT OF. OUR THAT. LITTLE
BETTER. VERY OUTRAGEOUS PEOPLE
OUT- I'M AS YOU KNOW I MARTHA
MILLER THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE COMPANY'S ADDITIONAL COURT
ATTORNEYS IN HERE TODAY I DID
ARE STRONG SUPPORT FOR A BI TWO
TWO TWO SEVEN WHICH ADDRESSES
ONE OF THE MOST CRITICAL ISSUE
FACING THE GLOBAL SUPPLY CHAIN
BY INCENTIVIZING MANUFACTURERS
TO PRODUCE CHASSIS THAN THE
OTHER KEY INTERMODAL EQUIPMENT
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. HOME TO THE
MOST PRODUCTIVE SYSTEM OF PARTS
NATION OUR PORTS OUR SPONSOR FOR
HANDLING ABOUT 38% OF ALL
CONTAINERIZED IMPORTS IN 20% OF
ALL EXPORTS THE COVETED NINETEEN
PANDEMIC CREATED A SURGE IN
CONSUMER DEMAND FOR CENTRAL CUTS
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND AND TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY CONTAINERIZED
CARGO VOLUMES GREW ABOUT EIGHTY
PERCENT. SPECIFICALLY OUR NATION
INSPIRED CHASSIS THAN OTHER KEY
INTERMODAL EQUIPMENT STRUGGLE TO
KEEP UP WITH RISING CONSUMER
DEMAND DURING THE CALL THE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC FOR DECADES
AMERICAN TRACKING MANUFACTURERS
AND THEIR WORKERS WERE FORCED TO
COMPETE AGAINST FOREIGN
MANUFACTURERS THAT WERE HEAVILY
SUBSIDIZED BY THEIR GOVERNMENTS
IN TURN TERRORISTS IMPOSED BY
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION CAUSE A
SIGNIFICANT DECLINE IN THE.
AVAILABILITY OF INTERMODAL
EQUIPMENT FROM CHINA. FOR OUR
PART BECAUSE- SPECIFICALLY- CAL
AGAR. EXPORTERS ACCESS TO
INTERMODAL EQUIPMENT IS CRITICAL
WITHOUT AVAILABLE CHASSIS TO
MOVECARGO FOR MURDOCH'S MARC
STERN CAN CONGESTION AND DELAY.
AND IMPEDING CALIFORNIA'S EXPORT
CAPACITY. THAT IS WHY OUR
STREETS PUBLIC PARKS STRONGLY
SUPPORT INCREASING THE SUPPLY OF
CALIFORNIA MAY TRY TO THE
MARKETPLACE INCENTIVES LIKE
TENTS ARE NEEDED. HAVING ACROSS
THE NATION CAPA ALONG WITH OTHER
KEY STAKEHOLDERS IN THE GOODS
MOVEMENT SECTOR AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF ECONOMIC
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT CAL
STYLE. AND I'M CDFA PARTICIPATE
IN THE CALIFORNIA SUPPLY CHAIN
THE CUSTOMER WHICH IS HOW TO
IDENTIFY SOLUTIONS TO ADDRESS
THE CONGESTION IN THE FALL I'M
ONE OF THE KEY OUTCOMES OF THE
SUMMIT WAS TO FIND WAYS TO SOLVE
FOR THE CURRENT EQUIPMENT
SHORTAGE THAT WE'RE
EXPERIENCING. THERE'S NO SILVER
BULLET TO SOLVING THE SUPPLY
CHAIN AS MIKE MENTIONED WE'RE
LOOKING FOR POSITIVE SOLUTIONS
THAT WE CAN DO TO KIND OF TACKLE
A LOT OF THE COMPLEX ISSUES HERE
AND WE BELIEVE THAT AB TWO TWO
TWO SEVEN DOES THAT- THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP- THE
PHONE BROKE DOWN ON THIS ISSUE
AND HAPPY ANSWER ANY QUESTION.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU ARE THERE
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN THE
ROOM WISHING TO SPEAK UP. SPEAK
IN SUPPORT. OF ALL THE MODERATOR
NOW PLEASE OPEN THE MAIN LINE
FOR SUPPORTING TESTIMONY. I'M
SURE IF YOU WHICH SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO TWO TWO SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND WE'RE GONNA GO TO
LINE NUMBER THANK. I'M GONNA GO
TO LINE NUMBER FIFTY SEVEN FIVE
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU PRESS. PRESS UNION FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
HERE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU OVER
LINE NUMBER NINETY EIGHT THAT'S
NINE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AFTER MANAGER MEMBERS BURNING
MINISTRY GABI HAVE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA TRUCKING ASSOCIATION
I WANT TO THANK OUR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DONALD FOR THIS CRITICAL
BILL AND WE ARE HERE IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY SEVEN.
AND MADAM CHAIR THERE IS NO ONE
ELSE IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT ANYBODY IN THE ROOM
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
AND IT IS ANYBODY ON THE PHONE
LINES THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWO TWO TWO
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. MADAM CHAIR AT
THIS TIME NO ONE ON THE PHONE IN
OPPOSITION ALL RIGHT QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CORK SO IN
READING THE ANALYSIS. FOR MANY
REASONS THEY GIVE WHY THEY THINK
THIS WOULD BE A- NOT BE
EFFECTIVE IN BRINGING ON MORE
MANUFACTURING CALIFORNIANS
SIMPLY RESULT. IN A TAX BREAK
FOR THE MANUFACTURING THAT'S
ALREADY HERE WHICH MIGHT NOT BE
A BAD THING BUT- DO YOU WANT TO
RESPOND TO THAT AS TO HOW
EFFECTIVE YOU THINK THIS BILL
WOULD BE- GIVEN THE ACTIONS BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN TERMS
OF RAISING THE TAXES IMPORT TAX
ON THE- CHINESE CHASSIS IS IT
CENTER. WELL ALTERNATES ORDER MR
JAGAN JUST A MOMENT BUT I THINK
THE SITUATION THAT WE'RE IN
RIGHT NOW IS WERE BEHOLDEN. TO
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT TO EVEN
MOVE OUR GOODS IN NORTH AMERICA
. AND THAT'S A PRETTY TRAGIC AND
SAD SITUATION THAT FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED IN THIS IS JUST ONE
WAY. TO ADDRESS IT BUT MAYBE
MISTER JACOB WHICH TO COME
FURTHER YEAH THANK YOU MISTER
KIRK A CORK FOR THE- QUESTION
WE'RE WE'RE REALLY LEFT WITH NO
ALTERNATIVE BUT TO ASK US
MANUFACTURERS TO STEP UP
PRODUCTION AND I. I GET THAT
THAT'S THE HEART OF YOUR
QUESTION- WE REALLY WANT TO
FOCUS THAT INVESTMENT AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE IN CALIFORNIA- WE
BELIEVE THAT- NOT JUST THE
ACTUAL- CHASSIS. ASSEMBLER BUT
THE ACTUAL COMPONENT
MANUFACTURERS NEED TO BE
STEPPING UP FOR THIS WE ARE AT A
CRITICAL DEFICIENCY IN THE
NUMBER OF CHOICES WE HAVE IN THE
MARKETPLACE RIGHT NOW- AND
ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO SPUR THAT
ALONG AS WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR
SO. IT MAY NOT BE A PERFECT
SOLUTION- AND THE LONG TERM- WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THEIR- ARE
CRITICAL COMPONENTS THAT ARE
GOING TO NEED TO BE MANUFACTURED
WHETHER YOU HAVE TERRORISTS OR
NOT OR WHETHER NOT YOU HAVE
THIS. THIS TAX CREDIT OR NOT-
BUT WE ARE ARE. REALLY GRASPING
AT STRAWS- WE HAVE A CRISIS WE
HAVE. NOT ENOUGH PIECES OF
EQUIPMENT TO MOVE THE AMOUNT OF
CARGO WE HAVE SITTING ON OUR
DOCKS RIGHT NOW- WE HAVE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF CHASSIS THAT ARE
OCCUPIED. BY EMPTY CONTAINERS
BECAUSE LOADED CONTAINERS DON'T
HAVE THE EQUIPMENT TO MOVE THEM
OFF THE DOCK- SO WE ARE ASKING
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO HELP US.
GET TO A PLACE WHERE THAT'S A
LEVY ADDED IN A NORMAL SITUATION
WITHOUT- THE PANDEMIC. I DON'T
THINK WE'LL BE ASKING FOR THIS
BILL. WE'RE IN A POSITION WHERE
WE HAVE NO OTHER PLACE TO TURN
EXCEPT THE U. S. DOMESTIC
MANUFACTURERS WE NEED THEM TO
RAMP UP AS SOON AS I CAN. THAT
IS BUT IS THIS THE BEST APPROACH
TO DO THAT IS JUST THE BEST WAY
TO SPEND THE MONEY IS REALLY THE
QUESTION. AND I CAN'T ANSWER
THAT BUT PERHAPS YOU COULD. IT
THAT IS THE THAT IS DEFINITELY
THE QUESTION WE'RE GOING TO-
ASK- YOUR LAST ANSWER THAT IN
THE- IF FOR NO OTHER REASON
THAN- THIS IS THE TOOL THAT
WE'VE USED IN THE PAST TO SPUR
MANUFACTURING INVESTMENT. AND
HAS IT WORKED. I BELIEVE SO OKAY
BUT I THINK IF YOU LOOK AT THE
FILM INDUSTRY ALONE. IN LA
THERE'S A TAX CREDIT FOR FILMING
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA- FROM
MY PERSPECTIVE THAT'S BEEN A
TREMENDOUSLY SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM.
AND THE PROOF WILL BE IN THE
CHASSIS IS PRODUCED. A THIS IS.
JUST KIND OF PICKING UP ON THAT
AND AGAIN IN THE FALL WITH ANY
THE BILL ANALYSIS SO THERE'S
FIVE CHASSIS MANY CORRECT ME IF
ANY OF THIS IS INVESTORS FIVE
CHASSIS MANUFACTURERS IN THE
UNITED STATES THERE'S ONE
CURRENTLY OPERATING IN
CALIFORNIA THIS BILL WOULD ONLY
APPLY TO MANUFACTURERS THAT USED
TO OPERATE IN CALIFORNIA SO IS
THE GOAL OF THIS BILL TO
INCENTIVIZE THE ONE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURER TO AFTER PRES MORE
STUFF HERE OR IS IT TO
INCENTIVIZE THESE OTHER FOR
OPERATORS TO ESTABLISH A
PRESENCE IN CALIFORNIA YEAH IT'S
BOTH- AND IT'S- SPECIFICALLY TO
INCLUDE BOTH OF THOSE FOLKS WHO
DO THE FINAL ASSEMBLY AND
COMPONENT MANUFACTURERS- SO
THAT'S EVERYTHING TIRES BRAKES
AXLES- WHEEL SETS ALL THOSE
THINGS ARE GOING TO IT- AND- ALL
OF THESE FOLKS- WHETHER YOU'RE
ONE OF THOSE. THOSE FIVE
ORIGINAL FOLKS FROM OUT OF STATE
OR THE CALIFORNIA- COMPONENT
ASSEMBLER- NEED TO PRODUCE MORE-
WHAT WE'RE REALLY ASKING FOR
WITH RESPECT TO CALIFORNIA'S
THAT'S A NEW ENTRANT- THEY JUST
SET UP SHOP POST TARIFF- AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC. WE'RE
ASKING EVERYONE RAMP UP- AND DO
THAT BY INVESTING IN MORE
EQUIPMENT HERE- SO. WHAT WE
DON'T KNOW AND ONE OF THE THINGS
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH COMMITTEE STAFF OF THIS IS
SITTING ON SUSPENSE AND WE'RE
WORKING THROUGH THAT PROCESS IS
IDENTIFYING EXACTLY HOW MANY
COMPONENT MANUFACTURERS ARE
ALREADY OPERATING IN THE STATE
WE DON'T KNOW THAT- BUT WE DO
KNOW THERE'S ONLY ONE S.
ASSEMBLER WHO'S BEEN SET UP IN
CALIFORNIA AND I WAS IN TWENTY
TWENTY AFTER THE- THE- TARIFFS-
SO. IT'S A IT'S A MARKET THAT WE
HAVE TO HAVE GROW WE HAVE TO
INCENTIVIZE GROW. THANK YOU.
JUST LIKE FOLLOW UP ON THAT AS
SETTING UP A BRAND NEW
MANUFACTURING IN CALIFORNIA
WOULD BE EXTREMELY EXPENSIVE DO
YOU THINK THIS IS ENOUGH TO
ACTUALLY INCENTIVIZE THE COMPANY
TO SET UP HERE- WELL WE HOPE SO
I THINK THAT TO DOCTOR QUIRKS
QUESTION- THE REAL INCENTIVE IT
IS A COMBINATION OF THE SAND AND
THE TARIFFS- UP UNTIL THE
IMPOSITION OF THE TARIFFS.
RELATIVELY SPEAKING DOMESTIC
PRODUCTION IS VERY VERY VERY
SMALL AND WE DID NOT HAVE ANY
DOMESTIC PRODUCTION IN
CALIFORNIA- SO. THE ANSWER IS WE
DON'T KNOW- BUT WE HOPE SO AND
WHAT WILL BE WORKING WITH WITH
FOLKS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
SOME NUMBERS TO GIVE- TO
EVERYONE ON THIS COMMITTEE AND-
IN THE LEGISLATURE MOVING
FORWARD. AND AGAIN I WOULD WE
WANT TO THE MANUFACTURER DOESN'T
CREDIT PATH BECAUSE THAT'S
EXACTLY WE WANT PEOPLE TO DO WE
WANT PEOPLE ARE MANUFACTURING
THIS PEOPLE QUITMAN TO INVEST IN
THE EQUIPMENT NECESSARY- TO THE
PRODUCER. IS THE COMPANY THAT'S
HEARING WHAT COMPANY IS IT IS AN
AMERICAN COMPANY IT IS A- ASCENT
IT'S A NEW SUBSIDIARY COMPANY OF
ONE OF THE FOREIGN-
MANUFACTURERS FROM ASIA. THANK A
BLOCK FROM THE MARKET IN CHINA
SO WHETHER YOU LIKE THAT THE
TERRORISTS ARE NOT- DALY CITY
THE PURPOSE OF PROTECTING
DOMESTIC MANUFACTURERS AND
RESHORING. SOME MANUFACTURING
FROM OFFSHORE TO THE UNITED
STATES OF THAT COMPANY DECIDED
TO STAND UP TO ASSEMBLY PLANTS
ONE IN CALIFORNIA ONE IN
VIRGINIA. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION OF.
MISSED I THINK I CALLED YOU
MCDONALD AT THE BEGINNING I
DIDN'T MEAN TO DO THAT MISTER
ODUM AND I'VE KNOWN YOU FOR
SEVEN YEARS I APOLOGIZE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. RIGHT NOW I
JUST LIKE TO THINK OF A FIRST
ALL THE MODERATOR AND ALSO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SO THAT'S WHEN
I VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
WE ARE GOING TO MOVE ON FROM.
YOUR PRESENTATION AND I THINK WE
HAVE. OF MR PATTERSON- NEXT
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY WITH AB.
SIXTEEN NINETY SEVEN. WELL THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT MEMBERS
OF THE- OF THE COMMITTEE- FIRST
AYE AYE I WANT TO. YOU TO KNOW
THAT I'VE READ THE IN THE-
DRAFTING CONCERN ON PAGE THREE
OF THE ANALYSIS WE'RE WORKING TO
AMEND THAT AND MAKE IT VERY VERY
CLEAR THE INTENT TO. TO FIX THAT
THIS BILL AB SIXTEEN NINETY
SEVEN WILL PROVIDE PARENTS
WHO'VE EXPERIENCED A STILLBIRTH
WITH A TAX CREDIT OF UP TO TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO ASSIST WITH
ASSOCIATED MEDICAL AND BURIAL
AND OTHER COSTS- IT'S ESTIMATED
THAT EVERY YEAR THERE'S ABOUT
TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND STILL
BIRTHS IN THE UNITED STATES. IN
CALIFORNIA SOMEWHERE IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD OF TWENTY FOUR
HUNDRED STILLBIRTHS- WHICH
MEANS- TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED
FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA. A
PREPARE TO HAVE A CHILD AND
BOUGHT CRIBS AND DIAPERS. LOWS
MAYBE AND MAYBE SET UP.
NURSERIES THERE MAY HAVE- EVEN
CARRIED THE OTHER BABY PASSED TO
DO THE DUE DATE- BUT DID. FIND
OUT THAT THE BABY WAS BORN
WITHOUT A HEARTBEAT. THESE
PARENTS DID HAVE TO- INDOOR
CONSIDERABLE FINANCIAL HARDSHIP
WITH RESPECT TO MEDICAL EXPENSES
A FUNERAL ARRANGEMENTS- THE COST
OF GRIEF- SB SIXTY NINETY SEVEN
WE HOPE IF YOU CAN PROVE IT WILL
HELP SHOULDER SOME OF THESE.
COSTS DURING A DIFFICULT- AND
DEVASTATING CRIME. TO PUT IT
INTO A BIT OF- PRIORITY CONTEXT
. WE THINK THAT THIS IS FOR THE
END UP TO THE CAP OF TWO
THOUSAND WERE TAKEN BY THE- NINO
SOMEWHERE IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD
OF- THE TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED-
STILL BIRTHS ON AVERAGE THIS IS
MAYBE FOUR AND A HALF MILLION
DOLLARS- I JUST LIKE TO COUNTER
POSE THE HEAD WITH THE PROJECTED
FORTY FIVE. BILLION DOLLAR
SURPLUS WE PRESENTLY HAVE-
OBVIOUSLY THIS BILL CANNOT TAKE
AWAY FROM THAT LOSS THAT THESE
FAMILIES HAVE EXPERIENCE BUT IT
CAN PROVIDE SOME RELIEF FOR
FAMILIES. IN NEED- I HAVE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT DANIELLE
OAKLAND WITH THE- STAR LEGACY
FOUNDATION AND GAVIN FERGUSON
WHO FOUNDED THE NONPROFIT
PHOEBE'S FUND WITH HIS WIFE FOR
A SUPPORT TESTIMONY. AT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WITH MODERATOR FIRST CONNECT US
TO MR FERGUSON. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. MR FERGUSON YOUR LINE IS
ON ME TO GO AHEAD. HI CAN YOU
HEAR ME OK. YES WE CAN THANK YOU. THANK YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
FOR ALLOWING ME TO- BE HERE
TODAY TO TELL YOU ABOUT WHY I
SUPPORT A. B. SIXTEEN NINETY
SEVEN THANK YOU ALSO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PATTERSON FOR GIVING ME
THIS OPPORTUNITY. AND THAT
BRINGING- SUCH AN NEEDED BILL TO
CALIFORNIA- AGAIN MY NAME IS
GAVIN FERGUSON AND I'M ALL
MORNING RADIO SHOW HOST HERE IN
SACRAMENTO ON ONE OF SIX FIVE
THE ACT. MY DAUGHTER PHOEBE WAS
DUE ON AUGUST SIXTH TWENTY
FIFTEEN PHOEBE HAD A TOTALLY
NORMAL PREGANCY. OUR DOCTOR
EVEN JOKED- QUOTE SHE'S READING
THE TEXTBOOK AND THEIR NEEDS TO
FAIL THE TIME. THEY DO DATE CAME
AND WENT AND WE ANXIOUSLY WAITED
FOR HER TO SHOW SIGNS THAT SHE
WAS READY TO COME OUT. AND ON
AUGUST ELEVENTH WE WENT IN FOR A
ROUTINE APPOINTMENT AND TO
DISCUSS WHEN WE WOULDN'T DO
THIS. WE JOKED WITH THE DOCTOR
WHEN HE CAME AND SPOKE WHEN THE
DOCTOR HAD TROUBLE FINDING
PHOEBE'S HEART BEAT. ALL THE
JOKING STOPPED. AFTER SEARCHING
FOR ALMOST A MINUTE HE FINALLY
HEARD A HEART BEAT EVERYONE IN
THE ROOM TO REDUCE THE SIZE OF
RELIEF. THAT THE DOCTOR STILL
LOOKED NERVOUS. YOU TOOK MY
WIFE'S WRIST ENCOUNTERED HER
HOLES AND SAID THAT HE WAS
PICKING UP HER HEART BEAT AND
NOT OUR BABIES. HE QUICKLY
PULLED HER OVER TO ANOTHER ROOM
THAT CAN ALTER FOUNDED STARTED
TO LOOK AT OUR DAUGHTER SHE SOON
AS HE HAD HER ON THE SCREEN WE
CAN ALL SEE THAT HER LITTLE
HEART WAS NO LONGER FEED. HE
THEN LOOKED AT US AND SAID THE
WORST WORD THAT ANYONE COULD SAY
TO A PERSON. I'M SORRY BUT YOUR
BABY HAS DIED. WE WERE AT FORTY
WEEKS WERE ACTUALLY PAST FORTY
WEEKS. EVERYTHING WAS FINE UP TO
THAT POINT THERE WAS SCREAMING
AND CRYING FROM MY WIFE AND I
FOR MONTHS. I'LL SPARE YOU THE
DETAILS BUT NO THAT THAT LEVEL
OF GRIEF FELT FROM PARENTS WHO
HAVE NEVER NEVER GET TO HOLD
THEIR BABY. HAVE TO LEAVE THE
HOSPITAL WITH NOTHING IN THEIR
ARMS LIVE IN A HOUSE WITH AN
EMPTY NURSERY THAT THEY BUILT IS
A PAIN THAT NO ONE IS EQUIPPED
TO HANDLE. AND OFTEN SWALLOWS
COUPLES HOLD. THIS IS WHY AB
SIXTEEN NINETY SEVEN IS SO
IMPORTANT I THINK IT'S NOT BAD
ENOUGH THAT PARENTS HAVE TO SURF
THE WAVES OF GRIEF AND FOR THE
REST OF THEIR LIVES MORNING IS
CHILD BUT THEY NEVER GET TO
WATCH GROW UP. THEY ALSO HAVE TO
DEAL WITH UNEXPECTED EXPENSES
THAT ADD INSULT TO INJURY. LIKE
FUNERAL COSTS BURIAL OR
CREMATION COSTS. WORKING AFTER
SOMETHING LIKE THAT IS
IMPOSSIBLE SO THERE'S A LACK OF
INCOME IN SOME CASES. SOME
COUPLES NEED TO LEAVE THEIR
HOUSE OR TOWN FOR A BIT IN ORDER
TO COLLECT THEIR THOUGHTS TO BE
ALONE. ARABY IS ESSENTIAL IN MY
OPINION WHEN IT COMES TO
MANAGING NOT ONLY GRIEF BUT
POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS. AND IT IS
OFTEN NOT COVERED BY INSURANCE.
AND FINALLY THE MOST ROBUST
MEDICAL EXPENSES TO PAY FOR THE
BIRTH OF A BABY THAT YOU NOW
HAVE TO BURY. OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL DECADES INFANT MORTALITY
HAS SUCCESSFULLY DECLINE HOWEVER
STILL BIRTH HAVE YOU KNOW. THEIR
MYSTERIOUS AND WHAT CAUSES THEM
AND THE NUMBER OF HIDDEN DANGERS
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN OUR DAUGHTER
PHOEBE LAINGSBURG THEN WAS ONE
OF TWENTY SIX THOUSAND
STILLBIRTHS IN AMERICA. IT'S FAR
MORE COMMON THAN PEOPLE REALIZE
AND THE PARENTS OF THOSE TWENTY
SIX THOUSAND. BORN STILL EVERY
YEAR NEED HELP. MY WIFE AND I
ARE VERY LUCKY PEOPLE WE WERE
ABLE TO HANDLE ALL THOSE
EXPENSES BUT WE KNOW MANY PEOPLE
WHO COULDN'T AND HAD TO CHOOSE
WHICH CRUCIAL HEALING EXPERIENCE
THEY WERE GOING TO BUY PASSED.
BECAUSE THEY COULDN'T AFFORD IT
. DEALING WITH THE LOSS OF A
CHILD THE WAY THAT WE AND SO
MANY OTHERS HAVE HAD TO DO IS
THE WORST THING A PERSON CAN GO
THROUGH SO WHATEVER ANYONE CAN
DO TO MAKE IT LESS TERRIBLE IT'S
TRULY A BLACK. YOU ALL HAVE THE-POWER TO DO THAT. PEOPLE LIKE US
NO THAT NOTHING WILL EVER BRING
OUR FEEDBACK BUT KNOWING THAT
PEOPLE WANT TO HELP AND WILL
NEVER FORGET HER IS MORE HEALING
THAN MOST REALIZE. NO GRIEVING
PARENT SHOULD HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT MONEY AFTER LOSING THEIR
CHILD. I'M WHILE TRYING HARD TO
NOT LOSE THEMSELVES SO I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO PLEASE APPROVED
AB SIXTEEN NINETY SEVEN DO WHAT
YOU CAN FOR PEOPLE LIKE ME AND
MY WIFE. AND AFTER LIKE THIS
GOES MUCH MUCH FURTHER THAN YOU
THINK AND CAN FROM. THANK YOU BE
SOMETHING THAT HELPS IN A TIME
WHEN THESE PEOPLE FEEL HELPLESS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I'M VERY
SORRY FOR YOUR LOSS MR FERGUSON
. THE MODERATOR NOW CONNECT US
WITH A- DANIELLE DANIELLE
OAKLAND PLEASE. HELLO. CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN HEAR YOU.
OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
THINK YOU'RE SOME WOMEN
PATTERSON OR GET IT BILL IN
ACTION THANK YOU FOR THE HONOR
TO SHARE MY TESTIMONY MY NAME IS
DANIEL AUCKLAND AND I'M A MOTHER
AND LIKE ANY OTHER PARENT MY
HUSBAND AND I COMPARED FOR OUR
SON JUDE ARRIVAL WITH SUCH
LOVING DETAIL WE PLANNED IN
GATHERED EVERYTHING DUDE MIGHT
NEED WE FOLLOWED ALL THE STEPS.
WE TOOK ALL THE CLASSES. WE WERE
EXCITED WELCOME OUR BEAUTIFUL
BOY INTO THE WORLD. WHAT WE
WEREN'T PREPARED HAVING
TO MAKE ARRANGEMENTS FOR THINGS
LIKE TO THE AUTOPSY CREMATION
AND FUNERAL. ON NOVEMBER TWENTY
THIRD TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN JUDE
AND EXPLICABLE YOU DIED AND WAS
BORN IN THAT ORDER. I GAVE BIRTH
TO DEATH. BECAUSE OF THAT SO
MUCH WAS TAKEN AWAY FROM US. IT
WASN'T GIVEN AND ID BAND OR AN
ANKLE MONITOR TO CONFRONT AN
OBJECTION. IT'LL FIND THE
HOSPITAL MAKES TO ANNOUNCE THE
BIRTH WAS OVERLOOKED SO HE WAS
FULL TERM DO DID NOT GET A BIRTH
CERTIFICATE BUT A CERTIFICATE OF
DEATH. WHEN WE LEFT THE HOSPITAL
WE DID NOT BRING JUNE HOME WE
PAINFULLY LEFT ABOUT THE MARK. I
HELD THE BOXES OF MEMENTOS
INSTEAD OF MY SON. WHEN THE TIME
CAME TO FILE TAXES THAT YEAR WE
WERE BLINDSIDED AGAIN WE HAVE
THE EXPENSES JUST LIKE ANY NEW
PARENT HAD IN ADDITION TO THAT
WE HAD UNTHINKABLE EXPENSES TO
FACTOR AND- NOT QUALIFYING FOR
THE CHILD TAX CREDIT WAS LIKE
SALT IN OUR WOUNDS THAT WOULD
NEVER HEAL. AS A LOT OF PARENTS
EITHER EXCRUCIATING OMISSION. IT
COMMUNICATES TO US THAT OUR
CHILD DOESN'T COUNT. OUR
CHILDREN WERE BORN STILL BUT
THEY WERE STILL BORN. SO THIS
WILL NEVER HEAL THERE ARE WAYS
TO EASE THE BURDEN TO RECOGNIZE
WHAT WAS LAW. HONORING THE
IMPACT OF STILL BIRTH WITH A TAX
CREDIT COULD EASE THE FINANCIAL
BURDEN FOR MANY FAMILIES. IT
HONORS AND ACKNOWLEDGES WHAT WAS
LOST IN A CONCRETE WAY. SO OUR
CHILDREN BEAUTIFUL LIVES WERE
CUT SO HORRIBLY SHORT THEY'RE
WORTHY OF BEING COUNTED. THAT'S
WHAT ALL THE LOS PARENTS CAN
HELP FOR. PLEASE VOTE YES ON AB
ONE SIX NINE SEVEN FOR ALL THE
BABIES WHO DESERVE TO BE COUNTED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MRS ARTLAND
. ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN THE
ROOM BUT WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. BUT MODERATOR NOW
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINE FOR
SUPPORTING TESTIMONY. IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
SIXTEEN NINETY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
. WE DO HAVE SEVERAL QUEUING UP
WE WILL START WITH LINE NUMBER
NINETY ONE NINE ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY APOLOGIES ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. BY NINETY ONE YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. YES I WOULD LIKE TO
VOTE YES. THE BILL A. B. THE ONE
WE'RE JUST TALKING ABOUT SIXTEEN
NINETY SEVEN. GREAT THANK YOU.
NOT AT ALL I NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY EIGHT THAT'S ONE TWO
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AN
HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- MY NAME IS DR OKAY
JOKE I'M A STILL BIRTH
RESEARCHER AND A MEMBER OF THE
INTERNATIONAL SO BIRTH ALLIANCE.
I'M HERE TO VOICE MY STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB ONE SIX NINE SEVEN
THANK YOU. ANOTHER LINE NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY FIVE
THAT'S ONE FIVE FIVE YEAR ONE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS RENEE YOU BANKS
FROM THE SAN FRANCISCO CHAPTER
OF STAR LEGACY FOUNDATION. AND I
SUPPORT. EIGHTY SIXTEEN NINETY
SEVEN. LEVEL ONE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE THAT'S
ONE SEVEN FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. THIS IS MOLLY SHEEHAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
IN SUPPORT OF AB SIXTY NINETY
SEVEN THANK YOU CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. NOW GOING NUMBER FORTY
SEVEN THAT'S FOUR SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. IN FORTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN CHECK ON FOR
ME PLEASE. HELLO COMMITTEE ON MY
NAME IS LIZ THAT SMITH FROM THE
CENSUS SAMPLE CISCO CHAPTER OF
STAR LEGACY FOUNDATION. AND- I
JUST WANT TO GIVE A I'M PART
STARLET CONTAMINATION AND I WANT
TO GIVE JUST SUPPORTING KUDOS TO
MY PARTNER DANIELLE- AND ALSO
OUR- ASSEMBLY. SPOKESMAN WHO
LAID OUT- WHAT ARE FAMILIES ARE
GOING THROUGH PRETTY MUCH- I AM
THE FATHER OF LOOKS ON- I
REPRESENT THIS STYLIST
FOUNDATION AS WELL AND JUST LIKE
DANIEL EVERYTHING WAS PERFECT-
JUST EXPECTING NOW THIS IS MY
FIRST BORN. AND IS IT'S BEEN A
STRUGGLE- YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN
GOING ON TWO YEARS AND- IS THIS
A LOT THESE FAMILIES AND YOU
KNOW ALL WE ARE GOING THROUGH IN
MY LIFE AND- WHICH IS LOOKING
FOR SUPPORT WE'RE LOOKING FOR
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE
EFFORTS YOU KNOW. WE'VE BEEN ON
THIS COST IS GRIDLOCK CAMINO SO-
I'VE BEEN INDOOR IN INDIA'S
DANCE TRYING TO BE PATIENT
LISTEN AND EVERYTHING AND ALL
THESE DIFFERENT YOU KNOW CAUSES
AND THINGS GOING ON- WHICH IS
OPEN THAT YOU CONSIDER SAYING
YES- THEY LAID EVERYTHING OUT I
REPRESENT THE MINORITY THE
HIGHEST. OF THE STEEL BARS- I'M
AFRICAN AMERICAN FATHER IN THE
BABY DISTRICT OF SAN FRANCISCO-
SO WE ALREADY KNOW THAT
REPRESENT- OUR NUMBERS ARE HIGH
IN YOU KNOW YEAH DURING A
PANDEMIC A LOT OF OUR FAMILIES
HAD JUST. BEEN HIT WITH A LOT OF
DIFFERENT GREAT. IN OUR BY. YOU
KNOW IN BEGINNING THE PAN- JUST
THANKFUL THAT I WAS ABLE TO BE
IN THE ROOM WITH MY WIFE TO
HELP. DELIVER OUR BABIES- SO.
I'M JUST ASKING YOU GUYS JUST TO
SAY YES- IN SUPPORT OF AB
SIXTEEN NINETY SEVEN- REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THE TIME
JUST BE THAT LISTEN TO US AND
GIVE US THIS OPPORTUNITY- NOT
BEING THERE IN PERSON- DOING
THIS OVER THE PHONE ON THOSE BUT
A LOT OF UP AND DOWN TO THIS
WHOLE PROCESS SNYDER BY STILL
GETTING USED TO THAT. BUT THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY AND- YES
MY VOTERS- JUST ON A SUPPORT FOR
THIS- PERSONAL INCOME TAX CREDIT. THIS BILL BURKE. THANK YOU.
YOU WILL NOT A LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY THAT'S ONE EIGHT
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
MICHAEL HOLLAND FROM THE SENATE
DISCUSS OUR LEGACY CHAPTER AS
WELL. AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT AB
ONE SIX NINE SEVEN THANK YOU.
NOT A LINE ONE HUNDRED NINETY
TWO THAT'S ONE NINE TO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS ALLEY
FELKER I'M NOT A MOM TO HENRY
FELKER WHO WAS STILLBORN IN
TWENTY TWENTY. AND I STRONGLY
URGE YOU TO VOTE YES ON THE BILL
THANK YOU. NUMBER LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN THAT'S ONE
ONE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD EVENING EVERYONE MY NAME IS
KAYLA PENNY AND I'M CALLING IN
COURT AND BILL AB SIXTEEN NINETY
SEVEN AN HONOR OF MY SO FAR
DAUGHTER FALLON ELISABETH. I
DIDN'T KNOW HOW LARGE THE COSTS
WHAT NOT ONLY EMOTIONALLY BUT
FINANCIALLY LOSING A BABY AND-
SHOCKINGLY HAPPEN TO ME AT
THIRTY ONE WEEKS IN A BOX IN
NOVEMBER FOURTEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND RED BULL
CALIFORNIA DUE TO AN UMBILICAL
CORD ACCIDENT.  MEAN EXAMPLE OF
SOME OF THE BILL WOULD HAVE
GREATLY BENEFITED THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. I'M
NOT A LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY FOUR THAT'S ONE EIGHT
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI Y
NAME IS- JOSHUA VIC. AND MY WIFE
IS IN A THICK AND WE'RE WITH
PUSH EMPOWER PREGNANCY AND- OUR
SON PASSED AWAY TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN. A STILL BORN THAT WAS
THE WORST EXPERIENCE OF MY LIFE-
I PRISON CONSCIOUS BECAUSE THEY
JUST DELIVERED OUR SON AND THAT
RISK. I BROUGHT ME IN AND SHE
SHE WAS UNCONSCIOUS BECAUSE OF
THE C. SECTION AND THEN THEY-
AND TO ME MY SON AND TELL ME YOU
DIDN'T MAKE IT SO I HAD TO BE
THERE ARE COMPLETELY ALONE TO
DOCTORS BECAUSE AS A RUSSIAN. I
JUST I FEEL TERRIBLE FOR ALL
THESE PARENTS THAT HAVE LOST.
BABIES BECAUSE IT IS THE WORST
EXPERIENCE EVER WE LOST OUR SON
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN OCTOBER
THIRD. AND IT NEVER. NEVER IS UP
SO. WE ARE ABSOLUTELY ASKING TO
PLEASE VOTE YES FOR A BI SIXTEEN
NINETY SEVEN WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THAT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR EVERYONE BEING HERE AND
THERE TIME AND AGAIN MY
CONDOLENCES FOR EVERYONE THAT
HAS LOST A LOVED ONE. THANK YOU
ON THE OTHER LINE NUMBER SEVENTY
TWO THAT SEVEN TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ELIZABETH IVERSON I'M THE
FOUNDER OF ONE IN FOUR STILL
BORN STILL LOVED CNN'S WINGS
FUNDACION AND THE STILLBORN MOM
FROM TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND
I SUPPORT. STRONGLY AB SIXTEEN
NINETY SEVEN THANK YOU. NOT A
LINE NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN THAT'S
THREE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS JOSH HOFFMAN
I'M CALLING FROM THE SAN
FRANCISCO SHOP IN THE STARTING
XI FOUNDATION I STRONGLY
SUPPORT. SB SIXTY NINETY SEVEN I
THINK THE COMMUNITY EVENTS FOR
THEIR SUPPORT OF THIS IMPORTANT
BILL. WELL NOT ONLY NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY SEVEN THAT'S
ONE SIX SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
REBECCA APRIL AND I'M FROM THE
SAN FRANCISCO CHAPTER IN STARK.
VACANCY FOUNDATION AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB SIXTEEN
NINETY SEVEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
. WITHOUT A LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THAT'S ONE
THREE ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS SAMANTHA BANERJEE- TO
ALIGN WITH BORN FELL IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF PUSH FOR EMPOWER PREGNANCY A
pAWARENESS AND PREVENTION. I'M
I'M HERE TODAY REPRESENTING
TWENTY THREE THOUSAND FAMILIES
BORN OF BABIES BORN STILL EVERY
YEAR IN THE US- INCLUDING US
SEVERAL HUNDRED SUPPORTERS OF
OUR IN CALIFORNIA- AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT EIGHTY. SEVEN
THANK YOU. WITHOUT A LINE NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED ELEVEN THAT'S ONE
ONE ONE YOURLINE IS OPEN. ONE
ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS CARL MARSTON ST FISCAL
CHAPTER OF STAR LEGACY
FOUNDATION MY SUPPORT AB. ONE
SIX NINE SEVEN. OVERALL I NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY NINE
THAT'S ONE OF FOUR NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS NATALIE
MET. MET ON THE SAN FRANCISCO
CHAPTER OF THE STAR LEGACY
FOUNDATION AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT A BEACH. ONE SIX NINE
SEVEN. NO GOAL LINE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND ONE THAT'S TWO ZERO
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS LAURIE THE BILL HAS AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT A. B. SIXTEEN
NINETY SEVEN. NOT A LINE NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED NINETY THAT'S ONE
NINE ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS ANGIE ANDRADE
AND I SUPPORT AB ONE SIX NINE
SEVEN AN HONOR OF MY SWEET
LEILANI ROSE. THE WARM JULY
SIXTEENTH TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
ONE THANK YOU. I'M NOT A LINE
NUMBER NINETY SIX THAT'S NINE
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME.
IS KARINA PORTENT. MAMA
STILLBORN CHILD RETIREMENT
CONFIDENCE ON. AUGUST THIRTY TWO
THOUSAND AND ONE AND HE STRONGLY
SUPPORT. EIGHTY SIXTEEN NINETY
SEVEN. WELL I NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY NINE THAT'S ONE EIGHT
LINE ONE EIGHT NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
CONSIDERING THE BILL TODAY I
JUST MY NAME CANNELLA CASTER.
I'M CALLING ALL THE WAY FROM
TEXAS ACTOR TO PERFECT PREGNANCY
BY BECAME A SURROGATE MOTHER.
HOW TO PERFECT PREGNANCY AND THE
DAY OF MY SCHEDULED C. SECTION
SHE WAS BORN STILL IN A
DEVASTATED MY FAMILY. A PARENT
FAMILY AND EVERYBODY INVOLVED SO
I STRONGLY SUPPORT A. B. SIXTEEN
NINETY SEVEN THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GROWING NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
FORTY ONE THAT'S ONE FOUR ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
KRISTEN RESTAURANT FROM THE SAN
FRANCISCO CHAPTER STAR LEGACY
FOUNDATION AND I SUPPORT EIGHTY
SIXTEEN NINETY SEVEN. NOT A LINE
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND TWO
THAT'S TWO ZERO TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN.
BRING A RESPONSE WILL COME ON
THE LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
THREE TWO ZERO THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MY NAME IS SARAH AND
I'M CALLING FROM THE SAN
FRANCISCO CHAPTER OF STAR LEGACY
FOUNDATION AND I SUPPORT AB ONE
SIX NINE SEVEN. NUMBER ONE
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND FOUR
THAT'S TWO ZERO FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. CALLING FOR THE FIFTH IF
THE DOCTOR. LIKE CONDITIONS
MEDICAL THE TALKS EACH. THE
PUBLIC. WILL I NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED NINETY FIVE THAT'S ONE
NINE FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
THINK I GOT- AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF HELPING AFTER NEONATAL
DEATH. HE SANTA CLARA AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT EIGHTY SIXTEEN
NINETY SEVEN THANK YOU. GROWING
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND FIVE
THAT'S TWO ZERO FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU YEAH. FROM
THE SENATE THERE GO CHAPTER OF
STAR LEGACY FOUNDATION. APART AB
SIXTY SEVEN NORTH MY SON. ALL
THE LINE NUMBER SIXTY FIVE SIX
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ARE YOU
MY SIXTY FIVE. YES MA'AM- MY
NAME IS STEVIE WHEN I'M FROM THE
SAN FRANCISCO CHAPTER STARLING
HE FOUNDATION AND I SUPPORT AB
ONE SIX NINE SEVEN THANK YOU.
WELL I NUMBER TWO HUNDRED EIGHT
TWO ZERO EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. HI MY NAME IS SEAN CREEK
DRAVID JACOBS AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF AB ONE SIX NINE SEVEN
AND I'M CALLING FROM THE SAN
FRANCISCO CHAPTER OF STAR LEGACY
FOUNDATION. YOUR LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT ONE FIVE
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS MIR BURKE I'M FROM THE
SAN FRANCISCO. CHAPTER OF OUR
LEGACY FOUNDATION AND I FULLY
SUPPORT. AB SIXTEEN NINETY SEVEN. BUT THAT WE'VE EXHAUSTED THE
QUEUE IN SUPPORT. RIGHT- YEAH I
UNDERSTAND THERE IS- ONE PRIMARY
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION WITH
MODERATOR PLEASE CONNECT US WITH
SAMANTHA CORBIN FROM THE
CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION. YOU'RE FREE THIS
WEEK. THANK YOU SIR MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MET THE CARBON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM AND THE
BANK THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
INTRODUCING THIS MEASURE AND TO
THE PARENTS WHO TOOK THE TIME TO
CALL IN AND SHARE THEIR GRIEF
TODAY I IN SEVEN TO EIGHT YEARS
OF WORKING ON THESE ISSUES
CANNOT IMAGINE THE BILL I HAVE.
NOT WANTED TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO MORE- AT THE TIME
EACH YEAR A IS OPPOSED TO THE
MEASURE THAT WE DO LOOK FORWARD
TO HAVING CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS WE
DISCUSSED THE NEED TODAY IN A
VARIETY OF TAX POLICY MATTERS TO
TARGET VARIOUS PROGRAMS AND
ENSURE FUNDS ARE AVAILABLE FOR
THOSE MOST IN NEED WHILE
PRESERVING OTHER CRITICAL
PROGRAMMING. AND WHEN GENERAL
FUNDS ARE UTILIZED TO SERVE ANY
SPECIFIC PROFESSOR OF COURSE NO
LONGER AVAILABLE TO MEET OTHER
STATE PRIORITIES INCLUDING
SUPPORTING PARENTS AND CHILDREN
IN DIRE NEED ACROSS THE STATE.
IT'S TRUE WE DO HAVE A VERY
LARGE SURPLUS THIS YEAR- BUT
THAT MEASURE IT NOT JUST FOR THE
SHARING WHAT IMPACT THE STATE
BUDGET FOR THE NEXT FIVE YEARS
WHEN THE ECONOMY MAY BE FAR LESS
CERTAIN- THAT SAID ONE OF THE
PARENTS WHO SPOKE EARLIER TODAY
BROUGHT UP A VERY FAIR POINT
REGARDING THE FACT THAT PARENTS
WHO HAVE LOST THEIR CHILDREN
THROUGH STILLBIRTH. DO NOT
QUALIFY FOR THE CHILD TAX
CREDIT- THAT I FOUND VERY
COMPELLING PERSONALLY I WILL
JUST SAY- HOWEVER EVEN THE CHILD
TAX CREDIT IS TAILORED TO
CERTAIN FAMILIES. WHO ARE IN
MOST NEED OF THE CREDIT ON A
VARIETY OF FACTORS. TO DO LOOK
FORWARD TO TALKING TO THE
AUTHORS OF THE SPONSORS. TO
DISCUSS POSSIBLE OR POTENTIAL
MEASURES- EXCUSE ME AMENDMENT.
TO FURTHER TARGET THE MEASURE
THANK YOU. FOR ANYBODY IN THE
ROOM WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. WITH THE MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE MAIN LINE FOR
ANY OPPOSITION TESTIMONY. THANK
YOU IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB ONE SIX NINE
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. THE MANAGER
THERE'S NO ONE SHOWING UP IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINES
THANK YOU QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CORK YES ALSO I HAVE A
CONCERN ABOUT THE WAY THIS WOULD
BE ADMINISTERED I REALLY THINK
IT IS ASKING TOO MUCH OF A
PARENT WHO HAS LOST A CHILD TO
KEEP RECEIPTS AND THEN SIX
MONTHS LATER BUT IN A TAX RETURN
IT JUST THE PAIN WOULD BE TOO
MUCH I MEAN I JUST CAN'T
IMAGINE. HOW AWFUL YOU WOULD
FEEL AT THE TIME AND HOW. HI
KEEPING RECEIPTS MIGHT BE THE
LAST THING ON YOUR MIND. SO I
WOULD PREFER IT THE OTHER THING
IS IF YOU REALLY ARE KEEPING
RECEIPTS AND THERE ARE AUDITED
AND THIS AND THAT. IT REALLY
RAISES THE COST OF WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO. I WOULD THINK A
BETTER APPROACH WOULD BE TO TAKE
SOME SORT OF A STANDARD.
APPROACH AND THAT PERHAPS MIGHT
BE THE CHILD TAX CREDIT. JUST
MAKING PEOPLE ELIGIBLE FOR THAT-
AS YOU SAID IN YOUR STATEMENT-
IF YOUR LIFE FOR ONE MINUTE YOU
GET THE CHILD IS ELIGIBLE FOR
THE FAMILY TO TAKE THE- THE TAX
CREDIT AND IF THEY'RE STILL BORN
THEY'RE NOT. THAT SEEMS. MMHM
I'M JOSH TO ME AND I THINK AN
APPROACH ALONG THOSE LINES WOULD
WORK BETTER BOTH IN TERMS OF
ADMINISTRATION AND- AND ALSO
TARGETING AS WAS BROUGHT UP BY
THE OPPOSITION SO THANK YOU ARE
SIR- ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON
YOU CERTAINLY BROUGHT UP
SOMETHING WE ALL SHOULD BE AWARE
OF. BUT AGAIN- I KNOW THIS IS-
SORT OF PRELIMINARY- AND- AN
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPLORE THE
POSSIBILITIES AND I THINK THAT.
WHAT WE ARE ABOUT. IS AN IRAQ
ACTUALLY KIND OF THEM
SYMPATHETIC WITH WITH RESPECT TO
THE RECEIPTS AND ALL OF THAT-
AND IT DID STRIKE ME AS- UNFAIR-
THAT IF IT'S STILL BARNETT.
DOESN'T QUALIFY FOR THE CHILD
TAX CREDIT- WE HAVE OP
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE. ADD TO CRAFT
AMENDMENTS WERE MADE I DON'T
KNOW WHETHER WE HAVE THE- PRIMER
SPACE TO ESSENTIALLY REWRITE BUT
IF THERE'S AN INTEREST IN.
WORKING ON THIS AS SUGGESTED BY
MR QUIRK. UP WE WOULD LOVE TO
CHECK IN WITH- THE SUPPORT
GROUPS AND THOSE WHO WERE-
CALLING IN SUPPORT I WOULD ADD
THAT- ALONG WITH THE CATHOLIC-
THE CONFERENCE. THE COMMUNITY
HEALTH SYSTEM IS IN SUPPORT
THAT'S THE BIG COMMUNITY
HOSPITAL IN FRESNO IN CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA IT'S AND THE AND- AND
ALSO THE VALLEY CHILDREN'S
HEALTHCARE THAT'S THE BIG
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL IN. FRESNO
CALIFORNIA AT THE END IN CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA- WHAT THE CHAIR
PROVIDE SOME GUIDANCE AS TO HOW
WE MIGHT PROCEED. I THINK IT
WOULD BE HELPFUL TO TALK TO THE
COMMITTEE STAFF AND SEE IF
THERE'S ONE SOME WAY TO- THE
REFOCUS- THE BILL IN A WAY THAT
WOULD BE LESS BURDENSOME ON THE
PARENTS. I MEAN EVEN LOOKING AT
SOMETHING LIKE- GRIEF COUNSELING
OR- GAS LOOKING AT THE CHILD TAX
CREDIT I'M NOT SURE EXACTLY
THAT- THAT'S AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL SO I AM NOT ACTUALLY HOW
THAT WOULD WORK BUT I'M NOT NOT
NOT NOT TO. BE ARGUMENTATIVE
ABOUT IT BUT WE HEARD. A GREAT
DEAL OF SUPPORT FROM INDIVIDUALS
MUST QUICKLY DID IN FACT GO
THROUGH. THAT PROCESS AND
SUPPORTING A BILL THAT WOULD
REQUIRE THEM TO- YOU KNOW
QUALIFY FOR THE TAX CREDIT THEY
THEY WERE THEY WERE IN FACT IN
SUPPORT- HAVING HEARD THE
POSSIBILITY THAT WE COULD DO
THIS WITH A- WITH A TAX. CHILD
TAX CREDIT- I'M I'M WILLING TO
GO DOWN A PATH. IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH WITH THE COMMITTEE. IF THAT
WOULD BE SOMETHING THAT WE COULD
WE COULD WE COULD WORK THROUGH.
SHARES LET'S HAVE YOUR STAFF
TALK TO THE COMMITTEES OF AB AND
SEE IF WE CAN FIND SOME OKAY.
AGAIN I THINK. THE. THIS IS A
SOMEWHAT OF A FINITE COSTS
ANOTHER WORDS WORK ON AVERAGE I
THINK WE HAVE TWENTY FOUR
HUNDRED OF THE STILLBIRTH IN
CALIFORNIA SO AGAIN IT'S ABOUT A
FOUR FOUR AND A HALF MILLION
DOLLARS. NUMBER THAT HOWEVER WE
COULD HELP WITH THOSE BURDENSOME
. COST MAY BE SIMPLIFIED WAY TO
QUALIFY FOR THEM- BUT IS IT AS
SIMPLE AS- THE DECLARING THAT A
STILL STILLBIRTH IS A BIRTH AND
SHOULD QUALIFY FOR A TAX CUT
CHILD TAX CREDIT. AND MAYBE
MAYBE THAT IS AN ANSWER HI I'M
LOOKING FOR A SOLUTION- AND WILL
CONSULT WITH WITH YOU AND WILL
CONSULT WITH THOSE THAT ARE IN
SUPPORT. AND SEE IF THAT CAN IT
CAN SCAN SOLVE YOUR CONCERNS AS
WELL AS- BRING SOME DEGREE OF
RELIEF AND SOME DEGREE OF A-
HELP OUT FOR THE FOR THE FOR
THIS KIND OF A I'VE AYE UNUSUAL
CIRCUMCISED PREACH HATE YOUR
COMPASSION ON THE ISSUE AND YOU
KNOW OBVIOUSLY WE CAN'T DO THIS
FROM THE DIET I UNDERSTAND YOUHAVE. SOME TIME TO LEARN IT
WOULD ALSO AS ONE OF THE PEOPLE
CALLED IN STATE WITH IT WOULD
SUPPLIER THE RECOGNITION THAT
THIS WAS A REAL PERSON. GOOD
POINT THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
THE TIME I APPRECIATE VERY MUCH
AND FOR THE VERY CAREFUL AND-
SERIOUS THOUGHTFUL AND
COMPASSIONATE CONSIDERATION OF
THIS THANK YOU. VERY MUCH. ALL
RIGHT YOU HAVE BEEN SO- PATIENTS
MS QUIRK-SILVA- SO- CAN YOU COME
UP AND- PRESENT AB TWENTY FIFTY
FOUR PLACE. FIRST I WANTED TO
SAY CONGRATULATIONS TO THE NEW
CHAIR ASSEMBLY WOMAN- JACQUI
IRWIN NO IT'S QUITE EXCITING AND
GOOD EVENING INSTEAD OF MY NOTES
THAT SAY GOOD AFTERNOON BUT HEY
WE KNOW THAT TECHNOLOGY DOESN'T
ALWAYS WORK WHEN WE NEED IT TO
BUT I WANT TO ALSO THANK THE
CONSULTANTS WHO HAVE WORKED ON.
ANALYZING THIS BILL I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY FIFTY FOUR THE
BILL WHICH CONFORMS TO CURRENT
STATE TAX CODE TO FEDERAL TAX
CODE CONCERNING FEDERAL TAX
EXEMPT FIVE OH ONE ORGANIZATIONS
THAT'S A LONG SENTENCE BUT IT'S
BASICALLY- ALIGNING TAX CODE
CURRENTLY ONE IN MUTUAL WATER
COMPANIES ACCEPTS A GRANT FROM
THE STATE THOSE FUNDS ARE.
SUBJECT TO BE TAXED THOSE TAXES
ARE THEN PASSED ON TO THE
CONSUMERS SOME OF WHOM ARE
SENIOR CITIZENS ON FIXED INCOMES
OTHER DISKS AND IN OTHER
DISADVANTAGED INDIVIDUALS AND
FROM RURAL. COMMUNITIES THIS
BILLS AIMING TO FOCUS ON THE
UNDERSERVED WATER DISTRICTS THIS
BILL WOULD MAKE IT SO THAT
MUTUAL WATER COMPANIES CAN
QUALIFY FOR THE FEDERAL TAX
EXEMPT STATUS AND NOT PASS ON.
ADDITIONAL COSTS TO CONCERNED
CONSUMERS THAT ARE ALREADY TAX
FOR THEIR WATER SERVICES. THAT
WE HAVE I BELIEVE ONE PERSON IN
THE QUEUE TO TESTIFY A CIGAR
OTHER WITNESS JUMPED OFF BUT
WITH ME HERE TODAY TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
IS MISTER DON ORTEGA WHO IS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF MUTUAL
WATER COMPANIES. THE STRATEGIC
ORTEGA. A MERRY GO AHEAD YES
PLEASE THANK YOU TO IRWIN AND
VICE CHAIR NGUYEN- MY NAME IS AN
HONOR TAKE I'M EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF MUTUAL WATER
COMPANIES WE REPRESENT FOUR
HUNDRED NEUTRALS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND OUR MEMBERS ARE IN EVERY
COUNTY IN CALIFORNIA UNDER
CALIFORNIA CORPORATION CODE
MUTUAL WATER COMPANIES OR NOT
FOR PROFIT COMMUNITY OWNED WATER
SYSTEMS THEY CAN ONLY SERVE THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY WHICH
TOGETHER OWN THE COMPANIES AND
SHAREHOLDERS. GIVEN THAT MANY
MUTUAL WATER COMPANIES EXISTENCE
OLDER RURAL AN OLDER URBAN AREAS
MANY MUTUAL SERVE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. UNDER THE STATUS
QUO ACCEPTING STATE GRANTS IN
IMPLEMENTING SOME CONSERVATION
MEASURES WOULD REQUIRE RESIDENTS
SERVED BY THE MUTUAL WATER
COMPANIES TO PAY TAXES. IF THE
MUTUAL EXCEPT STATE GRANTS AND
OR- INSTALLED BOB METERED WATER
SALES OR EARN INTEREST ON
RESERVE ACCOUNTS FOR MAINTENANCE
AS MANDATED BY STATE LAWS. WE
ARE ASKING FOR A YES VOTE AND
PASSAGE OF AB TWENTY FIFTY FOUR
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA'S TAX LAW TAX
LAWS DO NOT CONFORM TO FEDERAL
BIBLE ONCE HE TWELVE TAX EXEMPT
DESIGNATION FOR MUTUAL WATER
COMPANIES AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
THE BILL HAS PERFORMANCE
PROVISIONS THAT ARE SURE THAT
THOSE WHO WILL REALLY NEED IT
WOULD QUALIFY FOR TAX EXEMPT
STATUS IN CALIFORNIA. AND THE
SUNSET PROVISION FOR TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT THIS IS A KEY
FACTOR WITH THE STATE'S FOCUS ON
THE CURRENT DROUGHT CRISIS AND
HELPING UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES.
AB TWENTY FOUR AB TWENTY FIFTY
FOUR WILL HELP TO IMPROVE ACCESS
FOR MANY DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THE STATE AND
FEDERAL GRANTS THAT WILL HELP
OUR DROUGHT RESILIENCY AND SAFE
DRINKING WATER GOAL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I'M READY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES. IN THE ROOM WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. A I THE
SECOND WHICH LEFT. OF WITH THE
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE MAIN
LINE FOR SUPPORTING TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR A BI TWO ZERO FIVE
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE FILED
BY ZERO TWO SO SUPPORT FOR AB
TWENTY FIFTY FOUR AND WILL BEGIN
WITH THE LINES. OKAY I JUST
WANNA REMIND EVERYBODY JUST NAME
THE ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
PLEASE. THANK YOU I WILL START
TODAY. WITH LINE NUMBER FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY FORTY YOUR
OPEN. ALL RIGHT- MY NAME'S
CALVIN WILLIAMS GENERAL
MANAGER'S RECAP AS LONG WATER
DISTRICT ENTIRE WISH TO ADVISE
YOU THAT I SUPPORT THIS BILL
WILL PARTIALLY. THANK YOU. THIS
WILL ALIGN TO TWELVE YOUR OPEN.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ENTANGLING
ON BEHALF MESA WATER DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE SIXTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I SIXTY
NINE PLEASE ON MUTE YOU ARE OPEN. ONE MORE CHANCE LINE SIXTY
NINE. WOULD YOU LIKE TO TESTIFY
. WILL MOVE ALONG THE LINE
THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
THIRTY ONE. HELLO MY NAME IS
JOHN LANG MILLER CALLING ON
BEHALF OF GENERAL MANAGER CAN
CHIANG FROM SENATE'S VOTE WATER
COMPANY AND WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FIFTY FOUR
. ONE SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE. SEVENTEEN ELEVEN WE CAN
NOW GO AHEAD. THANK YOU- MADAM
OF BOARD CHAIR AND REST THE
BOARD THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK MY NAME IS
LOGAN LAW L'ARGENT I WORK WITH
THE COMMUNITY WATER. ALLIANCE
AND FOR MANY OF THE REASONS THAT
MISTER KAGAN SO THANKFULLY-
NUMBER I. I STRONGLY SUPPORT AB
TWENTY FIFTY FOUR AND I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
INTRODUCING THIS BILL THANK YOU
. AS A FINAL REMINDER PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO TO SHOW SUPPORT
FOR AB TWENTY FIFTY FOUR AND
LINE TWENTY EUROPE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I LIKE TWENTY TO TAKE
YOURSELF OUT TO Q. PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AGAIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY. OKAY YOU ARE OPEN
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY ON
YES. GOOD EVENING AND THANK YOU
SO MUCH. SINCE MARINO WEST BIG
HORN DESIGNATE WATER AGENCY
GENERAL MANAGER AND POLICY CHAIR
OF THAT COMMUNITY WATER SYSTEMS
ALLIANCE. A GROUP THAT'S WORKING
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WITH THE
WATER BOARD ON SAFER AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND SO
WE'RE IN FAVOR THIS BECAUSE
GIVING GRANT MONEY AND THEN
ASKING FOR SOME BACKAGE REALLY
JUST CUTTING THE GRASS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
WE HAVE NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS
QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHTS AS ANYBODY IN THE ROOM
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
SEEING NONE WITH MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE MAIN LINE FOR
ANY OPPOSITION TESTIMONY. HE
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION
FOR AB TWENTY FIFTY FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND NOBODY IS QUEUING UP MADAM
CHAIR ALL RIGHT A QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MISTER CLARK. I REALLY LIKE YOUR
BILL. WHOA YES YOU DON'T HEAR
THAT FROM ME TOO OFTEN BUT- BUT
I LIKED BOERNER HORVATH FIRST
BILL AS WELL- IT'S NOT TOTALLY
ON HER DEATH- FIRST OF ALL IT IT
BRINGS AND- COMPLIANCE WITH WITH
FEDERAL WHICH ALWAYS IS
SOMETHING WE TRY TO DO- IT'S
CERTAINLY A LOT EASIER- BUT THIS
IS I THINK VERY WORTHWHILE THESE
ARE NON PROFITS. THEY ARE
SERVING COMMUNITIES IN NEED I
THINK IT WOULD BE A GOOD WAY FOR
THE STATE TO SPEND ITS MONEY
AND- THE TWO COMPARABLE TAX
BREAK TO WHAT THE GOVERNMENT
ENTITIES. GET THE CELL OF I JUST
THINK IT MAKES A LOT OF SENSE.
THANK YOU MISS QUIRK-SILVA WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. WELL I'D LIKE
TO THINK THE OTHER CORK IN THE
BUILDING OF FOR THOSE COMMENTS
AND- I CONCUR AND ASK- FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND AGAIN THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. THANK YOU
HAVE A GOOD EVENING EVERYBODY
ALL RIGHT AND WE'RE IN THE FINAL
STRETCH MISTER RAMOS SIXTEEN
TWENTY THREE WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- AB SIXTEEN TWENTY THREE
WILL PROVIDE A STATE TAX
EXEMPTION- FOR RETIRED MEMBERS
OF THE UNIFORMED SERVICES
SERVICES AT AGE SIXTY THIS BILL
WILL ALSO EXEMPT RECIPIENTS OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE
SURVIVOR BENEFITS PROGRAM. THIS
BILL ALSO RECOGNIZES OUR STATE
NATIONAL GUARD AND THEIR
SERVICES TO OUR STATE ESPECIALLY
DURING THESE TRYING TIMES. AB
SIXTEEN TWENTY THREE PROVIDES
THAT THE EXEMPTION BENEFIT
BEGINS AT SIXTY YEARS OF AGE AND
THE EXEMPTION SUNSETS AND TWENTY
THIRTY THREE. AB SIXTEEN TWENTY
THREE FOCUSES ON TWO PURPOSES TO
HONOR THOSE WHO DEDICATE THEIR
LIVES TO SERVING OUR COUNTRY.
AND FOCUSES ON UNIFORMS SERVICE
RETIREES STRAIGHTENING THE STATE
SKILLED WORKFORCE STABILITY TO
COMMUNITIES AND CONTRIBUTING TO
THE STATE AND LOCAL TAX BY
RETAINING AND DRAWING MILITARY
DISCHARGE INDIVIDUALS TO STAY IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO BE
ABLE TO PLAN FOR A BETTER
RETIREMENT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. TODAY YOU'LL BE
HEARING FROM TWO WITNESSES JEFF
BRIGHTEN A RETIRED POLICE
OFFICER AND PAST PRESIDENT OF
THE CITY OF SAMBAR DINO RETIRED
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION.
AND CURRENT VICE PRESIDENT FROM
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF CHAPTERS
AFFILIATED MILITARY OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA. IN SET
THREE A RETIRED ARMY VETERAN
WITH COMBAT TOURS IN IRAQ AND
AFGHANISTAN IN A LOBBYIST
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF CHAPTERS AFFILIATED
MILITARY OFFICERS ASSOCIATION OF
AMERICA I BELIEVE THOSE TWO
WITNESSES HAVE CALLED IN. ALL
RIGHT DO WE HAVE MISTER BRIGHTON
ON THE LINE. YES MA'AM. GOOD
EVENING. GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE- COMMITTEE- I'M
HONORED TO SPEAK TO YOU TODAY ON
BEHALF OF. THE OVER ONE HUNDRED
FORTY EIGHT THOUSAND MILITARY
RETIREES SURVIVING SPOUSES AND
ARE ACTIVE DUTY MILITARY MEMBERS
WHO ARE CONSIDERING WHICH STATE
TO RETIRE AT. BETWEEN TWO
THOUSAND AND TWENTY SIXTEEN THE
NATION'S POPULATION OF MILITARY
RECALL RETIREE HAS INCREASED BY
17% CALIFORNIA THAT LEAVES A
DECLINE OF 17% IN THE STATE'S
MILITARY POPULATION DURING THAT
PERIOD. TODAY CALIFORNIA IS ONLY
ONE OF THREE STATES AND THE
DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA THAT FULLY
TAX MILITARY RETIREES. THE
INTRODUCTION OF ASSEMBLY BILL
SIXTEEN TWENTY THREE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JAMES RAMOS IS TIMELY IN
RELATIVE. WHICH BECAME LAW IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THE STATE OF
GEORGIA ASSEMBLY RECENTLY VOTED
A HUNDRED AND SIXTY ONE TWO ZERO
ON GEORGIA HOUSE BUILT IN SIXTY
FOUR WEEKS SIMPLY PORTION OF
MILITARY RETIREMENT FROM STATE
INCOME TAXES. A RECENT
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE REPORT
SHOWS THAT CALIFORNIA HAD OVER A
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED UNIFORMED SERVICE
RETIREES IN TWENTY TEN. THAT
NUMBER WAS REDUCED TO A HUNDRED
AND FORTY NINE THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWENTY. IN
THAT SAME PERIOD ARIZONA NEVADA
RELY INCREASES IN THE NUMBER OF
MILITARY RETIREES MOVING TO
THEIR STATE. BOTH STATES FULLY
EXEMPT MILITARY RETIREMENT PAY
FROM STATE INCOME TAXES. A
RECENT ARTICLE IN THE MILITARY
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION MAGAZINE
WITH A MONTHLY CIRCULATION OF
OVER THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND LISTED CALIFORNIA AND
PER MONTH SB TWO LEAST TAX
FRIENDLY STATES FOR UNIFORMED
SERVICES MEMBERS TO RETIRE AT.
AS OUR NATION'S UNIFORM SERVICE
MEMBERS PLAN ON RETIREMENT ONE
HAS TO WONDER. THE DUCK ARTICLE
INFLUENCE SOME OF THOSE
UNIFORMED SERVICEMEMBERS. SHOULD
CHOOSE ANOTHER STATE INSTEAD OF
CALIFORNIA THREE THREE TALK TO
RETIRED. PASSAGE OF AB SIXTEEN
TWENTY THREE IT'S A VALUABLE
TOOL TO RETAIN VETERANS AND
THEIR SKILLS IN CALIFORNIA. MANY
MILITARY RETIREES CONTINUE WANT
TO SECOND CAREERS INCLUDING
ENGINEERS MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS
AND OTHER HIGH PAYING DEFENSE
INDUSTRY JOBS. AB SIXTEEN TWENTY
THREE WOULD HELP MOTIVATE
MILITARY RETIREES TO STAY IN
CALIFORNIA AND CONTINUE TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THE STATE'S
ECONOMY. ACCORDING TO THE SAN
DIEGO REGIONAL CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE WHICH HAS COME OUT IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN TWENTY
THREE. ANY LOSS OF TAX REVENUE
AS RESULT OF AB SIXTEEN TWENTY
THREE WOULD BE OFFSET BY AN
INCREASE OF FORTY SIX MILLION
THROUGH STATE SALES TAX IN
INCOME TAXES. ON THE RETIREE
SECOND CAREER. AFTER TEN YEARS
OF IMPLEMENTATION MODELS
PROJECTED STATE REVENUES WHICH
ACTUALLY INCREASED OVER SEVENTY
pMAINTAIN CONTACT WITH MANY OF
THE MEN AND WOMEN I SERVED WITH.
MANY OF THOSE INDIVIDUAL PLUS
SERVICE AFTER THEIR KINDLE IN
UNUSUAL ANNOUNCEMENT WITHOUT
EVER RECEIVING ANY RETIREMENT
BENEFITS. EACH AND EVERY ONE OF
THOSE VETERANS MANY OF WHOM ARE
DEDICATED PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
TODAY. HAVE VOICED THEIR SUPPORT
OF AB SIXTEEN TWENTY THREE.
CALIFORNIA HAS APPROXIMATELY TWO
MILLION VETERANS IN THOSE
SECTIONS ALL RECOGNIZE. THE
VALUE IN RETAINING UNIFORMS
SERVICE RETIREES IN CALIFORNIA.
NOT ONLY HAVE BETTER TRAINS AND
VETERANS ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS
THE STATE VOICE THEIR SUPPORT OF
EIGHTEEN AB SIXTEEN TWENTY
THREE. BUT PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATIONS- PORAC THE LARGEST
POLICE ASSOCIATION IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA HAS COME OUT IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN TWENTY
THREE. SAMBAR DINO COUNTY
SUPERVISOR DON ROPE IS WORKING
TO HAVE AB SIXTEEN TWENTY THREE
PLACED ON THE COUNTIES TWENTY
TWENTY TWO LEGISLATIVE PLATFORM
AND IT'S VOICED HER SUPPORT OF
AB SIXTEEN TWENTY THREE. I THANK
YOU ALL FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
AND ASK EACH OF YOU ON BEHALF OF
OUR ACTIVE DUTY MILITARY
RESEARCH AND THE CALIFORNIA
NATIONAL GUARD MEMBERS AND THE
STATE'S APPROXIMATELY EIGHT
HUNDRED AND FORTY EIGHT THOUSAND
MILITARY RETIREES AND SURVIVING
SPOUSES. THE POLICE REPORT AB
SIXTEEN TWENTY THREE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME ALL RIGHTS THANK
YOU AND OUR SECOND PRIMARY
WITNESS IN SUPPORT IS SEPARATE.
AFTERNOON OR EVENING CHEN
MEMBERS MINUS SUCH READ WHICH
THE GOVERNMENT RELATIONS AT THE
CORRECTION I DID NOT RETIRE FROM
THE MILITARY I SERVED IN US ARMY
INFANTRY FOR FIVE YEARS BUT TO
COMBAT DEPLOYMENTS ONE IRAQ IN
ONE GO UP AGAINST THEM. I
OFTENTIMES BOOKERS SERVICE RUNS
IN THE FAMILY RETIRED VETERAN
SWEDE CALIFORNIA. THEIR FAMILIES. WHEN RETIRED VETERANS
CALIFORNIA THEIR FAMILIES FROM
ACTIVE DUTY AND RETIRED
OFTENTIMES FOLLOW. THANK WHAT SO
MANY AMAZING VETERANS NEED
CALIFORNIA OVER THE PAST FIVE
YEARS YOU HIGH LIVING COSTS.
VETERAN CALIFORNIANS I HAVE BEEN
MEETING THE STATE. FOR THE TAX
BENEFITS AND LOWER COST OF
LIVING IN OTHER STATES.
INCLUDING A. B. SIXTEEN TWENTY
THREE THIS WILL HELP KEEP
VETERANS. M. DRYDEN VETERANS
STATE CALIFORNIA. I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
DETAILED ANALYSIS I WOULD LIKE
YOU TO KEEP IN MIND. ON AVERAGE
VETERANS BRING IN. HALF A
BILLION DOLLARS IN NEW MONEY
EACH YEAR. YEAH THIS THERE
FEDERAL. DISABILITY BENEFITS.
THE MONEY RECEIVED FROM
DISABILITY. THE PAYMENT TO SPENT
ON THE COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. COULD YOU COMMENT TAX
EXEMPTION SUCH AS- SUCH AS A. B.
SIXTEEN POINT THREE PROPOSES WE
WILL CONTINUE TO SEE THOSE
FEDERAL DOLLARS FLOWING TO
UPSTATE THOSE YOUNGER VETERANS
CALLED THE FAMILY TO THE
STATE'S. I'M PERHAPS MY CLIENT
AMERICAN LEGION DEPARTMENT
CALIFORNIA AND THAT'S DEPARTMENT
CALIFORNIA. PHONE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTY VETERAN
SERVICE OFFICERS CALIFORNIA
STATE COMMANDER VETERANS COUNCIL
. WELL TURNED OFF TO SOCIALISM
AMERICA CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
CHAPTERS IN THE VIETNAM VETERANS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
COUNCIL WHO ARE ALL THANKS
STRONG SUPPORT. I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND I- CAN I BOOK THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. I THANK YOU
ANY WITNESSES IN THE ROOM
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT WE
HAVE ONE. CAROLING ON THE- ON
BEHALF OF THE SOLANO COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS THIS IS A
VERY BIG DEAL TO THE FAMILY SAID
OF ME THEIR HOMES AROUND THE
TRAVIS AIR FORCE BASE IN THERE
AND STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WITH MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE
MAIN LINE FOR SUPPORTING
TESTIMONY. IF YOU'D LIKE TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR A BI SIXTEEN TWENTY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONE ZERO FOR AB
SIXTEEN TWENTY THREE. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE ONE NINETY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD ONE NINETY SEVEN. BUT NINETY SEVEN CONCURRENCE.
YES CAN YOU HEAR ME YES PLEASE
GO AHEAD ABOUT. OUR MANY WITH
OUR BILLS SEEKING ON BEHALF OF
THE SAN DIEGO REGIONAL CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE REPRESENTING OVER
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED MEMBER
BUSINESSES AND THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES IN THE REGION
I THINKING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB SIXTEEN TWENTY THREE. THANK
YOU. MY TO- TO YOUR OPEN. SURE
TO PLEASE ON MUTE. MY TO A TWO.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO TESTIFY. ALL
RIGHT MOVING ALONG LINE TWO
THIRD. BUT HAD TO A TO. HI MY
NAME'S DAVE YOUR COME DOWN THANK
THE A GIRL. AND I HAD TWO SONS
WHO ARE IN THE MILITARY. WHERE
MIDDLE CLASS. BASICALLY THEY
CANNOT AFFORD TO RETIRE IN
CALIFORNIA IT IS TOO EXPENSIVE
THEY LOVE TO. LIVE IN SAN DIEGO
BUT IT'S JUST TOO EXPENSIVE THE
YOUNG KIDS. ARE YOU GOING TO.
ASK YOUR- APPROVAL OF THIS VITAL
ISSUE FOR THE MILITARY THANKS
AGAIN DATE YOUR. Y. TO THIRTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I THANK YOU FOR TAKING
MY CALL MY NAME'S KERRY KOTOWSKI
ELEV IN ROSEVILLE I'VE BEEN A
LIFELONG LEGAL RESIDENT
CALIFORNIA AND I CHOSE TO RETURN
BACK TO CALIFORNIA IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE AFTER SPENDING
NEARLY THIRTY YEARS ON ACTIVE
DUTY WITH UNITED STATES AIRFORCE
I NOW TEACH- PART TIME AT OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND I
STRONG SUPPORT ASSEMBLY BILL
SIXTEEN TWENTY THREE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. NINE TO FOURTEEN
YOU ARE OPEN. YES GOOD EVENING
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY HI
MY NAME IS CLAUDE SHAW I'M
CALLING FROM BURBANK CALIFORNIA
UNITED TRONG WE SUPPORT AB
SIXTEEN TWENTY THREE AS A
MILITARY RETIREE WHO WORKED WITH
THEM ANOTHER TWENTY YEARS AFTER
RETIREMENT I WOULD APPRECIATE
THAT THIS KIND OF SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND NEXT WE WILL
LINE TWELFTH PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FIND TWELVE IT CALIFORNIA IN
HEARING WE CAN'T PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HI MY NAME IS RED GREEN I'M
THE PRESIDENT OF THE MILITARY
OFFICE LOCATION WHAT ACCOUNTS
FOR CALIFORNIA AND ALSO- SERVICE
OFFICER AMERICAN LEGION POST
THREE OF THREE ERIC'S RETIRED
SCHOOL TEACHER I AM FULL SUPPORT
OF AB SIXTEEN TWENTY THREE THANK
YOU MADAM THEN YOU'RE COMMITTEE
. THANKS OF ALIGNED TO EIGHTEEN
TO EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS ALAN PATRICIA SKINNER
RETIRED U. S. NAVY COMMANDER I
WAS STATIONED ENABLE TWICE I
LIVE IN LOS ANGELES NOW I'M NOW
A PROFESSIONAL ACTOR I'M A
MEMBER OF THE AMERICAN LEGION
POST FORTY THREE AND I SERVE AS
THE DEPUTY CHAIR OF THE SAG
AFTRA THAT'S THE ACTOR UNION.
MILITARY COMMITTEE HERE IN LOS
ANGELES DO A LOT OF WORK ON
BEHALF OF THAT BUT THE PANDEMIC
OPENED UP OPTIONS FOR ME SO I
CAN LIVE IN NEW YORK AND GET AS
MUCH ACTING WE'RE GOING TO GET
IN CALIFORNIA. I'M GONNA GET A
SIX THOUSAND DOLLAR RAISE THE
MOMENT I LEAVE THE STATE I TAKE
MY FIRST HOUSE HUNTING TRIP IN
APRIL I SUPPORT AB SIXTEEN
TWENTY THREE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU LINE EIGHTY YOU
ARE OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS AND NOT VERTICALLY OUR
SPONSOR ASSEMBLY MARINO'S- I AM
A RETIRED NAVAL OFFICER LIVING
IN ALAMEDA COUNTY WHEN I SUPPORT
BUILT SIXTEEN TWENTY THREE. I AM
A LEADER AND ALSO A MEMBER OF
VARIOUS VETERAN ORGANIZATIONS IN
THIS COUNTY. AND A MEMBER OF THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY VETERANS AFFAIRS
COMMISSION I AM WELL AWARE
SPECIFICALLY OF FRIENDS. IN
VETERANS THAT HAVE LEFT THE
STATE DUE TO THE COST OF TAXES
AND SO FORTH. I SINCERELY HOPE
THAT ALL MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE WILL SUPPORT A. B.
SIXTEEN TWENTY THREE. ALL OF
YOUR VETERANS WILL SINCERELY
APPRECIATE YOUR HELP THANK YOU.
YEAH WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE EIGHTY
ONE YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD EVENING
MADAM CHAIRMAN- CHARIMAN.
COMMITTEE MEMBER THIS IS A
RETIRED REAR ADMIRAL DON WIDELY
UNITED STATES PUBLIC HEALTH
SERVICE AND I'M CURRENTLY THE
PRESIDENT OF THE ALPHA
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
MILITARY OFFICERS ASSOCIATION IN
GREATER SACRAMENTO AREA I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY BERKELEY SHARE MY
FULL SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN
TWENTY THREE. I'D ALSO LIKE TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS AND
HIS PEOPLE INTO BUSINESS BELL
AND HOWELL MALL IS AMAZING
ADVOCACY THIS BILL HAS GAINED
TREMENDOUS SUPPORT FROM
UNIFORMED SERVICEMEMBERS ACTIVE
DUTY. RETIRED AND OTHER VETERANS
FROM ALL OVER EIGHT BRANCHES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA PASSAGE OF
THE BILL WILL MAKE A CRITICAL
DIFFERENCE IN KEEPING RETIRED
VETERANS AND THEIR FAMILIES AND
SURVIVING SPOUSES IN CALIFORNIA
AND INCENTIVIZING RELOCATION TO
CALIFORNIA. AS A VETERANS AND
OTHERS HAVE YOU KNOW A CHOICE
ABOUT WHERE THEY LIVE I THANK
YOU AND I ASK FOR YOUR FULL
SUPPORT A. B. SIXTEEN TWENTY
THREE AND APPROVAL MOVING
FORWARD THANK YOU. X. WILL GO TO
LINE TWO FIFTH AND IF THERE ARE
OTHER PARTICIPANTS WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF SIXTEEN
TWENTY THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. TO FIFTEEN
YOUR OPEN. THE MANAGER ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS THIS IS RETIRED CAPTAIN
NOT WRONG HOLDEN DONE BESIDES
SAN DIEGO AREA. I'M A GULF WAR
VETERAN PROBABLY SEARCH FOR A
THIRTY YEARS IN THE UNABLE
SERVICE- ON BEHALF VETERANS-
HERE IN SAN DIEGO VERY. VERY
MUCH IN PROPONENT OF. AB SIXTEEN
TWENTY THREE. I'M ALSO A- PUSH
NUMBER OF MERICAN DEPOSED IN
LAMESA CALIFORNIA TO EIGHTY TWO
AND- VERY MUCH SUPPORT THIS
BILL- VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
VOTES THANK YOU. AMX WE WILL GO
TO LINE- WILL ONE NINETY FOUR
YOU ARE OFTEN. HELLO THIS IS
CAPTAIN TOM WALTER I SPENT
TWENTY FOUR YEARS IN THE
AIRFORCE RETIRED FROM DEALER FOR
SPACE I SPENT ANOTHER TWENTY
FOUR YEARS WORKING IN HEALTHCARE
AND FINALLY RETIRING FROM SUTTER
HEALTH- WE ARE SO MUCH IN FAVOR
OF BABY SIXTEEN TWENTY THREE.
THANK YOU. AND WE'LL GO TO LINE
ONE SEVENTY YOU ARE OPEN. YES
SIR GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS GENE TALMADGE AND I AM A
RETIRED NAVAL OFFICER I LIVE IN
CAMARILLO AND- I HAD ELECTED TO
STAY IN CALIFORNIA. WHEN I DID
RETIRE FROM THE NAVY- BUT I
UNDERSTAND THE- THE NEEDS THAT
MANY PEOPLE HAVE. OF NON
AFFORDABILITY. I WAS ABLE TO
WORK FOR A STATE AGENCY AFTER
RETIRING FROM THE NAVY. BUT MY
INTEREST IS HERE AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT. A. B. SIXTEEN TWENTY
THREE AND I THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAINBOWS FOR HIS SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL IS SPONSORING THE
BILL. AND- I WOULD HOPE ALL OF
YOU. I SHARE THE SAME INTEREST
AND CAN APPROVE OF THIS BILL AND
HAVE IT MOVE FORWARD THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. MADAM CHAIR WE
HAVE EXHAUSTED THE QUEUE FOR
SIXTEEN TWENTY THREE IN FAVOR
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I UNDERSTAND WE HAVE ONE
PRIMARY WITNESS OF A- SPEAKING
AGAINST THE BILL OF WILL YOU
PLEASE CONNECT US TO SAMANTHA
CORBIN FROM THE CALIFORNIA TAX
REFORM ASSOCIATION. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS CAN'T THE KOREAN WITH
THE CALIFORNIA TAX REFORMS THAT
MEASURE- THE STATE DOES HAVE A
VARIETY OF DEDICATED PUBLIC
SERVANTS TEACHERS FIREFIGHTERS
LAW ENFORCEMENT. SCIENTISTS
NURSES- ONE COULD CERTAINLY
ARGUE THEY'RE EQUALLY DESERVING
OF GRATITUDE FROM THE STATE AND
AS A MATTER OF TAX POLICY IT'S
UNCLEAR IF THERE'S A COMPELLING
REASON AT LEAST RIGHT NOW TO
SINGLE OUT ONE SERVICE
POPULATION OVER ANOTHER AND THE
RECEIPT OF ADDITIONAL BENEFITS.
MOREOVER AND AS WE'VE DISCUSSED
NUMEROUS TIMES TODAY BECAUSE THE
GENERAL FUND WOULD SEE REDUCE
DOLLARS AS A RESULT OF THE
MEASURE IT COULD REDUCE SERVICES
OVER TIME TO THOSE MOST IN NEED-
THE MEASURE THAT CLAIM THAT THE
NUMBER ONE ISSUE FOR EMPLOYERS
AND CALIFORNIA IS ATTRACTING A
QUALIFIED WORKFORCE- AND LOOP
THAT APPROXIMATELY SIXTY
THOUSAND UNFILLED HIGH TECH JOBS
ARE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR HIGHLY
SKILLED SERVICE RETIREES- BUT
IT'S WORTH NOTING THAT THE
MEASURE IS ONLY APPLICABLE TO
QUALIFIED INDIVIDUALS OVER SIXTY
YEARS OF AGE. UNCLEAR IF THESE
INDIVIDUALS WOULD CHOOSE TO OR
EVEN WOULD BE ABLE TO RETURN TO
WORK- OR THAT THEY WOULD DO SO
IF THEY OTHERWISE WOULD NOT HAVE
SIMPLY BECAUSE OF THE TAX
INCENTIVES- THEREFORE
QUESTIONABLE THAT ONE OF THE
PRIMARY AIM OF THE BILL- WOULD
EVEN BE MET THROUGH THE BILL
ITSELF AND FOR THOSE REASONS WE
OPPOSE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISS CARBON ANYBODY. IN THE ROOM
IN OPPOSITION. AND MODERATOR
OPEN MAINLINE ANY OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE SP ONE SIX TWO
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND THE FINAL
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO. AB. SIXTEEN
TWENTY THREE. AND NOBODY IS
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COURT YEAH. SO PERHAPS YOU COULD
ADDRESS SOME OF THE CONCERNS
RAISED BY THE OPPOSITION I'M
ALSO. YOU KNOW IT'S NOT A BAD
THING TO HAVE PEOPLE MOVE OT OF
THE STATE WE HAVE A HOUSING
CRISIS. AND PARTICULARLY FUEHRER
ARE OLDER AND RETIRED AND YOU
DON'T NEED TO LIVE NEAR A
BUSINESS- SAY THE TEN SAN DIEGO
IT MAY MAKE SENSE TO MOVE
OUTSIDE OF THAT AREA. AND HAVE
THE HOUSING AVAILABLE FOR PEOPLE
WHO NEED TO COMMUTE TO THAT
HOUSING- I KNOW THAT SOUNDS.
DOESN'T SOUND RIGHT BUT- THERE
IS A HOUSING SHORTAGE AND IT'S A
REAL BIG CONCERN AND
INCENTIVIZING PEOPLE TO STAY. A
MAY NOT BE THE BEST WAY TO SOLVE
IT. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I'M
NOT SURE THAT QUESTION IS
DIRECTLY ASKED THEM IF I COULD
ADDRESS SOME OF THE OPPOSITION.
BUT SHOULD I ADDRESS THIS
QUESTION FIRST FOR HIS COMMENTS
WHATEVER YOU WOULD LIKE TO DO.
THANK YOU- MISTER CHAIR AS FAR
AS OPPOSITION IT TALKED ABOUT-
NOT REALLY FOR FILLING THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT HOWEVER- THE
ARGUMENT IS THAT IT ALSO WILL
SERVICE ON A PLAN OF RETIREMENT
THOSE THAT ARE DISCHARGED FROM
THE MILITARY THAT DO GO INTO.
THE SKILLED WORKFORCE HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA COULD
SEE THIS AS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
THEIR RETIREMENT PLANNING TO
AUTOMATICALLY GET TO THAT POINT
WHERE THEY COULD THEN BENEFIT
FROM THE EXEMPTIONS- MOVING
FORWARD. AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER-
THAT QUICK- WHEN PEOPLE ARE
DISCHARGED FROM THE MILITARY
THEY DO- ATTAIN GI BILLS TO
OFFER THEM TO PURCHASE HOMES SO
IT DOES HELP THE HOUSING
COMPONENT TO FOR OUR MILITARY.
THAT ARE THERE I THINK. THIS
BILL IS JUST I THINK IT'S NEEDED
I THINK IT'S- A BILL THAT- NEEDS
LONG AWAITED AND OVERDUE-
ADVOCACY- AND DEBATE ON THIS
ISSUE- SO I DO BELIEVE THAT-
WITH SOME OF THE OPPOSITION- I'M
TALKING ABOUT. THEY MENTION THAT
SIXTY YEARS PLUS THEN WILL THEY
BE PART OF THE SKILLED WORKFORCE
BUT I WOULD HAVE TO- MENTIONED
THAT THAT'S PART OF A RETIREMENT
TOOL AS FAR AS WHERE WE'RE GOING
TO RETIRE. IN THE STATE THAT WE
WOULD LOVE TO- BE AND I WOULD
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO STAY IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND RETAIN
THT KNOWLEDGE HERE. IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. ALL RIGHT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOURPRESENTATION I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAVE ANY
CLOSING WORDS. I JUST I BELIEVE.
THAT THIS IS JUSTIN AND I FEEL
STRONGLY ABOUT THIS ISSUE. I
THINK- HONORING OUR MILITARY AND
THE SURVIVORS THE FAMILIES THAT
ARE THERE I THINK THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT. WARRANTS SOME
DISCUSSION AND I WILL MAKE
MYSELF AVAILABLE MADAM CHAIR TO
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSIONS ON THIS
MATTER AS THIS PROCESS CONTINUES
TO MOVE FORWARD. REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU. FINALLY WE ARE ON OUR
LAST ITEM MR ROD REGUS A FILE
ITEM TEN AB. SEVENTEEN OH NINE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY PRESENT A. B.
SEVENTEEN ONLINE AND WITH THAT
I'M HAPPY TO TAKE THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. AMERICAN RED CROSS
RECENTLY DECLARED ITS FIRST EVER
NATIONWIDE BLOOD CRISIS AS BLOOD
BANKS ACROSS THE COUNTRY FACE
ONE OF THE WORST BUT SHORTAGES
IN DECADES. MANY HOSPITALS ARE
ONLY RECEIVING A QUARTER OF
THEIR NEEDED BUT WHICH FORCES
DOCTORS TO CHOOSE WHO RECEIVES
CARE IMMEDIATELY AND WHO MUST
WAIT. AND MORE DIRE CASES
HOSPITALS ARE UNABLE TO TREAT
ANYONE. FOR EXAMPLE HARBOR UCLA
MEDICAL CENTER LOCATED IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA HOW TO CLOSE
THEIR TRAUMA CENTER FOR TWO
HOURS AND EARLY JANUARY BECAUSE-
THEY EXHAUSTED THEIR BLOOD
INVENTORY. THIS BLOOD SHORTAGES
ALREADY CAUSING- DIRECTLY
CAUSING OTHERWISE PREVENTABLE
LOSS. OF LIFE AND I SURE
SCHRODER TO THINK THE LOSS WE
WOULD FACE IN THE EVENT OF A
MAJOR DISASTER EMERGENCY. AB
SEVENTEEN OH NINE ONE KURDS MORE
DONATION BY PROVIDING A FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLAR NET TAX CREDIT
FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO DONATE
BLOOD. FOUR TIMES IN THE
CALENDAR YEAR AND AUTHORIZING
CAL OH YES TO CREATE
PARTNERSHIPS WITH THE PRIVATE
SECTOR THAT COULD PROVIDE MORE
DISSONANT INCENTIVES FOR
CALIFORNIA'S TO DONATE BLOOD.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU DO WE HAVE
ANY- WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. OKAY
A SO- ANYBODY ANY WITNESSES IN
THE ROOM WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT AND AN THE MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINE FOR THE
MAIN LINE FOR SUPPORTING
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
IF YOU'D LIKE TO TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN ZERO
NINE. PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME WHEN FALL
BY ZERO TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
FOR A BI SEVENTEEN OH NINE. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WE HAVE A COUPLE
QUEUEING UP. FOR ANYBODY ELSE GO
EIGHT EIGHT ONE ZERO TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT FOR AB ONE SEVEN ZERO
NINE. AND WE WERE LYING TO
NINETEEN YOU ARE OPEN. R. THANK
YOU MY NAME IS DESIREE SMITH AND
I'M A RESIDENT OF NORTH COUNTY
SAN DIEGO AND I'M INSUPPORT OF
AB SEVENTY NINETY NINE. EIGHTY
SIXTEEN- TWENTY BE THAT WITH
EARLIER- BUT MY SUPPORT FOR
EIGHTY SEVENTEEN OH NINE FOUR-
THE TAX CREDIT FOR DONATING
BLOOD IS IT SUPPORT- AND I AND I
STAND BY MATT- BECAUSE YOU'RE A
MORE MILITARY HERE I BELIEVE I
DON'T HAVE ANY FIGURES TO BACK
IT UP BUT I BELIEVE THEY'RE
PROBABLY MORE DONORS. BECAUSE A
LOT OF THE MILITARY MEMBERS
DONATE HERE AND SO YOU HAVE A
LOT OF MILITARY PEOPLE HERE AND
IT WOULD BE A BENEFIT FOR THEM
THEIR DONATING A LOT AND THEY'VE
LIVED HERE IN A VERY EXPENSIVE
STATE TO LIVE IN. AND SO ANY
ADVANTAGES THAT CAN COME TO THEM
FROM HAVING LIVED HERE AND AS
THE SURVIVING SPOUSE OF MILLET
MILITARY SURVIVING SPOUSE MYSELF
LOOKING FOR LITTLE REASONS TO
STAY. ARE ARE ARE GOOD. THAT'S
IT. AGAIN I'M IN SUPPORT OF IT.
RIGHT DO WE HAVE ANY LIKE YOUR
BOOKS WILL. ANY OTHER WITNESSES
INSPECT BETTER. WE HAVE ONE MORE
ALLY TO ELEVEN YOU ARE OPEN. YES
HI MY NAME IS DR RECAPS FLUORIDE
I AM LIFESTREAM BLOOD BANK'S
PRESIDENT CEO AND MEDICAL
DIRECTOR I'VE WORKED IN
TRANSFUSION MEDICINE BLOOD
BANKING FOR ALMOST THIRTY YEARS.
LIFESTREAM IS A NONPROFIT BLOOD
BANK THAT HAS BEEN IN OPERATION
FOR OVER SEVENTY YEARS PROVIDING
BLOOD AND BLOOD PRODUCTS OVER
EIGHTY HOSPITALS AND MEDICAL
FACILITIES IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA THIS APPEAL PATIENT
NEED LIKE YOU MUST COLLECT FIVE
HUNDRED BLOOD DONATIONS A DAY.
CURRENTLY LIFESTREAM BLOOD BANK
AS WELL WHAT CENTERS ACROSS THE
NATION ARE EXPERIENCING THE MOST
SERIOUS BLOOD SHORTAGE IN
HISTORY KOPEN NINETEEN
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED OUR INDUSTRY
PEOPLE ARE NOT COMING IN TO
DONATE AS MUCH AS THEY WERE
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC. THESE ARE
ATTACKS WE EXPECT WILL CONTINUE
FOR A LONG TIME WITHOUT HELP WE
HAVE THAT WE HAVE HAD LESS THAN
A ONE DAY OF SUPPLY OF RED CELLS
AVAILABLE. FOR MOST OF TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE AND A GOOD
PORTION OFTWO THOUSAND TWENTY
TWO AND MANY OF OUR HOSPITALS
OFTEN HAVE HAD DAYS WITH LITTLE
OR NO CRITICALLY NEEDED TYPE OF
RED CELLS ON THEIR SHELVES THIS
IS A NATIONAL CRISIS AND WE ARE
UNABLE TO RECEIVE HELP FROM
OTHER BLOOD CENTERS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY. PATIENTS CANNOT AFFORD
TO THE SHORTAGE TO GO ON FOR
MUCH LONGER IT IS NOT ONLY RED
CELLS THAT ARE DESPERATELY
NEEDED A PLATE LOOKS AS WELL
PLATE WITH HER SPECIAL AND
SCARCE RESOURCE MANY PATIENTS
INCLUDING ADULTS AND CHILDREN
BATTLING BLOOD IN OTHER CANCERS.
DESPERATELY NEED FREQUENT BLOOD
TRANSFUSIONS TO SAVE THEIR LIVES
TAKEN HAVE PLAYED LET'S HAVE A
VERY SHORT SHELF LIFE OF ONLY
FIVE DAYS AND COMBINED THE
ONGOING BLOOD SHORTAGE IN DEMAND
FROM LOCAL HOSPITALS IT REQUIRES
US TO INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
PLATELETS PRODUCTS WE COLLECT.
TO PROVIDE AN AMPLE SUPPLY TO
OUR COMMUNITY EVERY TWO SECONDS
SOMEONE NEEDS BLOOD HOSPITALS
WITHOUT ENOUGH BLOOD PRODUCTS
SUPPLY WILL LIKELY CANCEL LECTIN
SURGERIES AND MAY NOT HAVE
ENOUGH BLOOD TO SEVERE TRAUMAS.
WE NEED HELP FROM OUR COMMUNITY
AND AB SEVENTEEN OH NINE COULD
HELP FACILITATE THAT THE BILL'S
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR TAX CREDIT
FOR TAXPAYERS MAKE A LEASE FOR
DONATIONS OF HUMAN WHOLE BLOOD
OR HUMAN BLOOD COMPONENTS WOULD
BE NEEDED INCENTIVE FOR DONORS.
WE GET T. SHIRTS GIFT CARDS AND
OTHER EMOTIONAL. BUT IT'S NOT A
AND SO A PERSON. AND WE-
COMPETE. THE FOR PROFIT PLASMA
CENTERS THAT COMPENSATE DONORS
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE. CURRENTLY
OUR LOCAL BLOOD DONORS AVERAGE
SLIGHTLY LESS THAN TWO BLOOD
DONATIONS A YEAR. EIGHTY SEVEN
TO. EIGHTY SEVENTEEN OH NINE
COULD HELP US DOUBLE OUR
DONATION RATE. THE NON-PROFIT
BLOOD CENTERS OF CALIFORNIA ARE
AT A COMPETITIVE DISADVANTAGE.
IN ATTRACTING. DONORS AND AB
SEVENTEEN ON I CAN HELP. THE TAX
CREDIT WOULD BE A HUGE HELP TO
SAVING THE LIVES OF PATIENTS. AS
WELL AS HELPING CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES IN NEED ESPECIALLY
DURING THE ONGOING AND
CONTINUING PANDEMIC THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND THEN THE UP WAS
THAT THE LAST WITNESS IN SUPPORT
. YEAH THERE ARE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS CUED UP MEDICARE
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE ONE WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION. MISS CORBIN. MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND THE
INTEREST OF TIME I WILL LIMIT MY
COMMENTS SIMPLY TO SAY THAT OUR
CONCERNS THAT THIS MEASURE BY
THE CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
REPATRIATION OR SIMILAR TO OUR
CONCERNS WITH MR LEVINE FRAZIER.
ON A SIMILAR TOPIC AND WOULD
ENCOURAGE THE AUTHOR TO CONTINUE
TO EXPLORE WAYS TO TARGET THE
MEASURE TO THOSE IN NEED WITH
THE LEAST IMPACT ON THE GENERAL
FUND. THANK YOU. RIGHT ANYBODY
IN THE ROOM WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION LOWOF WITH MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE MAIN LINE FOR
ANY OPPOSITION TESTIMONY. THANK
YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION FOR A B.
SEVENTEEN ZERO NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. THIS
PRESS ONE ZERO TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB SEVENTEEN ON.
AND I'M SURE NOBODY IS QUEUING
UP I THANK YOU QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CORE YES LONG
DAY- SO I USED TO BOB DONATE
FOUR TIMES YEAR WHEN I WORKED AT
LARGE FLAVAN. ONE OF THE MAJOR
REASONS FOR IT. BESIDES THAT
THEY GAVE OUT DONUTS- WAS THAT
IT WAS VERY CONVENIENT. AND THAT
THEY WOULD COME FOUR OR EVEN
MORE TIMES A YEAR TO THE LAB
BECAUSE THEY GOT A LOT OF PEOPLE
COMING IN IT WAS ENCOURAGED. THE
QUESTION I HAVE IS THIS FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLAR TAX CREDIT AND
I'M GLAD IT TO CREDIT NOT A
DEDUCTION OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT
THAT. I THINK THAT'S A MORE
APPROPRIATE WAY TO GO- IS THAT
GOING TO BE. THE MOST EFFECTIVE
WAY TO SPEND THAT MONEY. YOU'RE
ALSO GOING TO HAVE A PROBLEM
JUST ADMINISTERING THE PROGRAM
WHAT KIND OF PROOF FOR YOU CAN
HAVE IT CETERA- SO THAT'S A
QUESTION THAT I THINK YOU NEED
TO LOOK AT IN THE BILL BUT- MY
QUESTION IS THIS REALLY THE BEST
WAY TO SPEND THE MONEY WOULD IT
MAKE MORE SENSE TO SAY FROM THE
BLOOD BANK. TO MAKE MORE MOBILE
CALLS. I DON'T KNOW. WELL THE
WE'RE LOOKING AT IT NOW I MEAN
WE GOT TO BE ABLE TO THINK MORE
CREATIVE HOW WE GET MORE PEOPLE
TO DONATE BLOOD OBVIOUSLY. THIS
IS A CRISIS THAT WE HAVEN'T SEEN
IN DECADES SO I THINK WE HAVE TO
THINK ACOSTA DIFFERENTLY HOW WE
CAN GET INCENTIVIZE MORE PEOPLE
COME OUT TO DONATE BLOOD WE CAN
DO THE DIGITAL BLOOD BANKS AND
WHATNOT BUT IF WE DON'T GET MORE
PEOPLE OUT TO THOSE BUT BANKS
ARE KIND OF DEFEATING THE
PURPOSE BUT I THINK THIS IS JUST
ONE WAY. TO LET FOLKS KNOW THAT
THERE IS AN INCENTIVE FOR
CONDONING BUT IN ONLY FOUR TIMES
IN ONE YEAR SO I THINK IT'S THE
BEST APPROACH BUT I'M OPEN TO
ANY OTHER SUGGESTIONS OR COMES
AT. ANYBODY MALE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. VERY MUCH AND- DO YOU
HAVE ANY CLOSING COMMENTS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE AND
WE CAN HELP SAVE SOME LIVES
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
WE HAVE ANY. ALL RIGHT. WELL
WITH THAT I AM A JOHN THAT THIS
MEETING THANK.